MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE. THIS
MORNING.
THE CHAIR NOTICES THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM BUT ALSO RECOGNIZES
THE PRESENCE OF.
MULTIPLE MEMBERS AND INCLUDING
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS. AND OF
COURSE.
WE WANT TO WELCOME OUR TWO NEW
MEMBERS TO THE COMMITTEE THOSE
THAT ARE HERE ON TIME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN ASSEMBLY
MY FONG THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US HERE AND WELCOME TO
THIS COMMITTEE. A TODAY RULE IT
HERE BILLS IN SPECIAL ORDER
FOLLOWED BY FILE ORDER.
WITH RESPECT TO ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS FOCUS
ON THE.
BICU A PACKAGE AND THAT IS
WITH RESPECT TO BILLS OF FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE THROUGH TEN.
HAVING SAID THAT. TODAY HOW MUCH
OF THE LEGISLATION HAS BEEN PART
OF A COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF
BILLS BY A DIVERSE COALITION. OF
MEMBERS OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY OF
THIS.
PACKAGE OF BILLS REFLECTS HOW
THE UP YOU A CRISIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT TRANSCENDS PARTIES AND
POLITICAL OF ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION. ENOUGH
OPIOIDS WERE PRESCRIBED IN A
SINGLE YEAR IN CALIFORNIA FOR
EVERY MAN WOMAN AND CHILD TO BE
MEDICATED.
AROUND THE CLOCK FOR A MONTH.
THERE'S BEEN A MISCONCEPTION
THAT CALIFORNIA'S NOT BEEN
PARTICULARLY HIT BY THIS APPEAR
CRISIS.
BUT THIS IS NOT TRUE YOU WILL
HEAR PUBLIC TESTIMONY OF WITH
RESPECT TO ADDRESSING THIS
CRISIS.
SO TO BEGIN A TODAY I AM
PRESENTING THE FIRST THREE BILLS
IN ORDER THAT I HAVE AUTHOR THAT
ARE AIMED AT IMPROVING HOW WE
CAN USE DATA TO. SAVE LIVES AND
HOPEFULLY CRISIS SO HAVING SAID
THAT I'M GOING TO PASS THIS GAL
OVER TO EXAMINE BURKE CHEN. AND
I WOULD RESENTING ABOUT BILLS.
AND FILE ITEM ONE.
THROUGH THREE
.
EVERY KID EVERY MIGHT FEEL TO
PRESENT THEN OF FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ONE.
INTRADAY INTERSTATE DATA
SHARING.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ONE WILL EMPOWER THE STATE'S
PRESCRIPTION DRUG MONITORING
PROGRAM KNOWN AS CURES.
REGULATORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ALSO USE THIS TOOL TO FIGHT THE
OPIOID CRISIS.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IF IT'S
YOURS IS THE ONLY.
RECORDS OF PRESCRIPTION
DISPENSED BY PHARMACIES IN
CALIFORNIA IT DOES NOT.
INTERACT WITH OTHER STATE
DATABASES THIS PROBLEM BECOMES
THEIR FOR KNOWN AS DR SHOPPERS
IN WHICH OFTENTIMES INDIVIDUALS
WILL CROSS STATE LINES TO OBTAIN
MULTIPLES PRESCRIPTIONS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT PARTICULARLY FOR
DOCTORS.
NEAR THE BORDER TO IDENTIFY THIS
ABUSE
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE OTHER
STATES TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S
PATIENT PRIVACY AND DATA
SECURITY STANDARDS BEFORE
RECEIVING ANY ACCESS TO THIS
DATABASE.
AND WITH RESPECT TO ASK HER OUT
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND HAVE OTHER WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
HI I'M JENNIFER SUMMERS WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THE BOARD BELIEVES CARES
IS A VERY IMPORTANT TOOL
INEFFECTIVE AID PROPOSITIONS TO
USE TO PREVENT DOCTOR SHOPPING.
THIS SKILL BILL WILL GET
POSITIONS ACCESS TO PRESCRIPTION
DRUG INFORMATION FROM OTHER
STATES AND THE SIX SPECIALLY
IMPORTANT POSITIONS WHO PRACTICE
IN YOUR STATE LINES. AND THIS
BILL HELPS A PER THE BOARD'S
MISSION A CONSUMER PROTECTION IN
THE BAR RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RIGHT VOTE THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MARY WE CAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
OVER TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE. AYE
WE'RE SUPPORTING SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMAN MEET ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW WHICH CREATES A
FRAMEWORK FOR CURES TO CONNECT
WITH OTHER DATABASES OF AND
OTHER STATES.
ENHANCING CURES TO ALLOW
CALIFORNIA PRESCRIBERS AND
DISPENSERS ESPECIALLY THOSE
PRACTICING NEAR THE STATE'S
BORDERS.
TO NEVADA OREGON AND ARIZONA TO
SHARE INFORMATION ACROSS STATE
LINES WILL HELP CURB OVER
PRESCRIBING OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES AND HER FRIEND
UNLAWFUL DOCTOR SHOPPING. AS AN
ORGASM ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
PROVIDERS COMMITTED TO SERIOUSLY
COMBATING THE URGENT OPIOID
CRISIS CDA WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORTS THIS EFFORT AS ONE OF
THE MANY SOLUTIONS TO
PRESCRIBING.
PRESCRIPTION DRUG OVER ABUSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PRESENTATION.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE JUST TAKE YOUR
NAME ASSOCIATION YOUR POSITION.
I HAVE I GOT INVOLVED WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE TOP
ON BEHALF OF VIACOM IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ALL OF IRAQ OR A
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAVID AND SOLOMON OF AMERICA'S
POSITION GROUPS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THAT KAREN CYBER PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW ON IMPORTANT PATIENT
PRIVACY AND DATA SECURITY ISSUES
THANK YOU.
JACKIE SAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE PATIENT CO SHATTERPROOF
AND SUPPORT.
SHELVE GIBBONS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
VIRGINIA HEROLD CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF PHARMACY ARMED WE WISH TO
JOIN THE FORTY FIVE OTHER STATES
THAT ARE ALREADY SHARING DATA
THROUGH THE CENTRALIZED HUB.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AMY
BROWN ON BEHALF OF.
CHEN IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS READ ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
PHYSICAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
VINCE WERE IT NOT WITH THE WHITE
MEN GROUP FUND BEHALF OF THE
CATHOLIC CHIROPRACTIC
ASSOCIATION'S BOARD.
MR JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO HAVE ME
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WELCOME TO DYESS
.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MEGHAN ARE IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
HERE.
TO. HEAR IN AND OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. THAT WE HAVE
WORKS.
THIRD YOU KNOW A NUMBER OF YEARS
ON THE CURIOUS. DATABASE BILLS
AWAY WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF LOW
AND IN THE PAST WITH OTHER
AUTHORS.
AND WE HAVE STRESSED THAT THE
PRIVACY COMPONENT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED
AND THIS BILL WHILE WELL
INTENTIONED AND WE AGREE THAT
OPENING UP. TO OTHER STATES WILL
BE A GREAT TOOL FOR PROVIDERS.
THAT IT NEEDS TO BE TAPPED
SECURED FIRST AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO PUT INTO
PLACE SOME PRIVACY MEASURES.
AND THAT THE STATE COULD USE TO
PUT SOME PRIVACY MEASURES INTO
THE BILL THAT WOULD ENSURE THAT
PATIENT DATA IS PROTECTED BEFORE
WE OPEN UP THE DATABASE TO
SHARING ACROSS STATE LINES.
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR TO
CONTINUING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
AND THAT.
I HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT MOVING
FORWARD WE WILL SEE SOME
RESOLUTION TO THIS.
AND WE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR THIS WORK TO BE CONTINUED
BUT THE BILL TO CONTINUE HAVING.
I THINK.
THROUGHOUT THE CURRENT I ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND WOOD.
AFFILIATE MYSELF WITH THE SOME
OF THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE.
IF I'VE HAS HAS LONG HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT THE EXISTING ON
PRIVACY STANDARDS RELATED TO THE
CARRIER'S DATABASE AND AND
CARRIES THOSE CONCERNS INTO ITS
EXPANSION.
WHERE IT WOULD OPPOSE UNLESS
I'M IN A POSITION ON THE BALLOT
IN PARTICULAR?
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE CLARITY
AND THE LANGUAGE THAT ANY OUT OF
STATE ENTITIES SEEKING TO ACCESS
ON CALIFORNIA'S PATIENT DATA
WOULD HAVE TO IN FACT IT HERE TO
ALL OF CALIFORNIA STRONG PRIVACY
LAWS BEFORE DOING SO TO PROTECT
PATIENTS FROM. UNLAWFUL
DISCLOSURE I THINK IT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER I'M BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND IN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
SEEKING AMENDMENTS REQUIRING A
WARRANT FOR ANY. AYE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR A STATE OR
FEDERAL AGENCY ACCESS TO CARS.
JERRY HEX REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND LIKE IN OUR
COMMENTS WITH CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN. OPPOSE MUST
AMENDED BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH AUTHOR AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE WITNESSES
ON SEEING NO FOR THE WITNESSES.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS.
SEE NO QUESTIONS MISTER CHAIR
AFTER PLEASURE WHICH LIKE
CLOTHES YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I DID WANT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS LIKE YOURS IS
ALREADY REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH
THE NUMBER OF. FEDERAL AND STATE
PRIVACY AND SECURITY LAWS
ADDITIONALLY LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
REQUIRED TO HAVE A WARRANT. OF
FOR INVESTIGATIONS INTO PATIENTS
OF THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
HAS ALREADY RULED THAT ACCESS TO
INFORMATION EIGHT YEARS IS
CRITICAL FOR THE STATE. AND A
CURRENT STANDARDS ARE
APPROPRIATE AND I WILL.
MOST CERTAINLY I STAY COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH OPPOSITION OF
THIS.
DOES ENJOY A AND I I RECOGNIZE
RESPECT LAST FOREVER.
SENIORS NO QUESTIONS MEMBERS
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
NO ABSENT WARM WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL AYE AS AND IT APPEARS
THAT I WILL HAVE A VOTE WHEN.
NOW WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THE NEXT TWO BILLS AGAIN.
WITH RESPECT I DO IT INCH BOTH
ENJOY AND AYE AYE RECOMMENDATION
AND SO ALLOW ME TO SEE A BRIEF
IN THESE COMMENTS OF THIS IS AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO WHICH
ADDRESSES THIS WATER CRISIS. A
WITH RESPECT TO ADDING THE
SCHEDULE FIVE DRUGS TO THE
DATABASE CURRENTLY CHAIRS TRACK
SCHEDULE TO THROUGH FOR. US SO
EVERY OTHER PRESCRIBE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES SUBSTANCE IS ALREADY
REPORTED IN THE DATABASE
SCHEDULE FIVE INCLUDES A COUGH
SYRUPS AYE CONTAINING CODEINE
WHICH IS KNOWN AS.
AN OPIATE OF MANY OF THESE A
CHANGES ARE IMPORTANT DUE TO.
THE PHARMACIST HAVING TO REPORT
TO CURES FOR FROM SEVEN DAYS TO
ONE WORKING DAY AND REAL TIME TO
AGAIN A PREVENT AS MUCH DOCTOR
SHOPPING AS POSSIBLE I HAVE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SPORT OR
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT VOTE.
DOT TO KAREN CYBER I'M
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
REPRESENTING THREE TH OVER THREE
THOUSAND PHYSICIANS WHO
SPECIALIZE IN ANESTHESIOLOGY AND
PAIN MEDICINE. IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY CHAIR.
THIS BILL WILL STRENGTHEN OUR
PRESCRIPTION DRUG MONITORING
SYSTEM CURIOUS BY ADDING
SCHEDULE FIVE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES CONTAINING OPIOIDS TO
THE LIST OF MEDICATIONS THAT
TRACKS.
THE BILL MAKE SURE THAT THESE
SUBSTANCES WHICH INCLUDE COMMON
COUGH SUPPRESSANT SYRUPS FOUND
IN MANY HOUSEHOLDS IN MEDICINE
CABINETS. ARE APPROPRIATELY
TRACKED IN THE DATABASE AS THEY
TOO CAN PRESENT SUBSTANTIAL RISK
OF ABUSE AND DIVERSION.
CALIFORNIA POSITIONS WHO
SPECIALIZE IN ANESTHESIOLOGY AND
PAIN MEDICINE SHARE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO PREVENTING FURTHER
DEATH AND DISABILITY FROM OPIOID
ABUSE IN OUR STATE.
THE CURIOUS DATABASE CAN BE VERY
HELPFUL TO PHYSICIANS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS PHARMACISTS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IN TRACKING THE
PRESCRIBING AND DISPENSING OF
OPIOID CONTAINING MEDICATIONS.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO WILL MAKE
THIS DATABASE MORE COMPLETE AND
MORE ACCURATE.
WE'RE STRONGLY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE THAT PAIN IS
ADEQUATELY TREATED.
BUT OAK YARD ABUSE EITHER BY
PATIENTS OR BY INDISCRIMINATE
PREDICT PRESCRIPTION WRITING
MUST BE TRACKED AND OFFENDERS
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. TO THAT END WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO.
ON THE I'M VIRGINIA HURLED ON
WITH THE BOARD OF PHARMACY AND
THE BOARD IS THE SPONSOR OF THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
OUGHT THIS BILL WOULD ADD
SCHEDULE FIVE WHICH IS
TO THE CURE'S REPORTING SYSTEM.
ALL.
IT IS STILL SCHEDULED FIVE ARE
NOT AS OF USABLE AS OUR
SCHEDULES TWO THREE AND FOUR
WHETHER IT'S ALSO MEDICAL USE.
BUT THEY CONTAIN SOME VERY
POWERFUL DRUGS INCLUDING PRO
METHOD CODING I'M GOING TO
MENTION THIS ONE BY ME.
IT IS THE CAUSE OF MANY
ROBBERIES PARTICULARLY IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA OF PHARMACIES
AND ADDITIONALLY THE PRODUCT
ITSELF IS EXTRAORDINARILY
VALUABLE ON THE STREET. BUT COST
THE PHARMACY OR WHAT'S WHAT
WHAT'S ONCE CAUGHT COST THE
PHARMACY TWELVE DOLLARS A PLATE.
GOES FOR TWELVE HUNDRED TO
SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS ON THE
STREET.
THAT THAT CREATES A TREMENDOUS
DEMAND FOR THIS PRODUCT IT NEEDS
TO BE TRACKED AND TRACED AS
PEOPLE COME INTO PRESCRIBERS AND
TRY TO GET PRESCRIPTIONS TO COME
OUT AND THEN RESELL THE DRUG.
ADDITIONALLY ON THE DATA ON
REPORTING SYSTEM INTO CHAIRS IT
WOULD MOVE IT FROM THE CURRENT
SEVEN DAYS IN CALIFORNIA TO
WITHIN ONE WORKING DAY. WHICH
SOLVES THE PROBLEM WITH A THREE
DAY WEEKEND FOR EXAMPLE. AND
THAT WAY THE DATA WILL BE AS
FRESH AS POSSIBLE FOR
PRESCRIBERS INTO SPENCER'S WHEN
THEY ACCESS CURES TO IDENTIFY
WHERE THE PATIENT IN FRONT OF
THEM HAS BEEN.
SO.
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVE UP.
VETERAN MUST BETWEEN WHAT IS
OPPOSITION.
MAKE IT OUR ENEMY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WERE ACTUALLY SUPPORT AS
AMENDED.
I'VE WE THINK THE OTHER FOR
WORKING WITH US AND FOR TAKING
OUR ONE AMENDMENT FROM THE
BEGINNING THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY IN ADDING.
THAT MEDICATIONS
TO THE CARES DATABASE BUT WE
SUPPORT ALL THE REST OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL AND
APPRECIATE THAT IT HAS BEEN
AMENDED. TO BE SOMETHING THAT WE
REALLY CAN GET BEHIND WE ARE
VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF THE ONE
WORKING DAY REPORTING. AS IT
HELPS OUR POSITIONS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S NO LAG TIME BETWEEN
WHEN THEY SEE A PATIENT.
AND THE SEVEN DAYS PRIOR WHEN
THE PATIENT COULD BE GETTING
MEDICATIONS IN BETWEEN. SO WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE ON THIS AND CONTINUE
TO.
WANT TO WORK FOR THE CHAIRED
BECAUSE THEY'RE GREAT POSITION
TOOL THINK.
SKINNER PADRES WITNESSES IN THE
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH THERAPY
AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF US
EMPTY FIFTY TWO AND SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE THINKING.
JENNIFER SUMMERS OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THE BOARD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW
OVERTAKING THE BOARDS ARE
QUESTION AMENDMENTS AND RENOWNED
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JACKIE SAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE PATIENT GROUP
SHATTERPROOF IN SUPPORT.
MISSY JOHNSON WITH THE CUT BACK
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
AN IN BETWEEN THERE OUT WE THINK
CHAIRMAN LOW FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE WE HAVE THREE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS ONE OF
WHICH HAS ALREADY BEEN ACCEPTED
BY THAT. THE AUTHOR AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THE OTHER TWO ONE RELATES TO THE
MAINTENANCE OF THE ICD NINE AND
TEN COATS WE'D LIKE FOR THOSE
REMAIN IN THERE. AND THE OTHER
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TALK TO YOUR OFFICE ABOUT IS
PERHAPS.
EXTENDING THE TIME FRAME FOR.
THE INPUT OF THE INFORMATION
INTO CARES JUST A LITTLE BIT
LONGER THANK YOU.
AND VINCENT WORK MODULE WITH ONE
GROUP ON BEHALF CALCUTTA WOULD
SUPPORT.
JERRY CAN WITH CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS RENOWNED SUPPORT.
NOW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU A CALIFORNIA AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT THAT
pHAS BEEN TAKEN ADDRESS ONE OF
OUR CONCERNS. WE STILL ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT ADDING SCHEDULE
FIVE DRUGS TO CARES PARTICULARLY
WITHOUT THE ADDITIONAL PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS THAT WE FEEL ARE
NEEDED. AND SO AT THIS POINT WE
REMAIN OPPOSES.
SEVERAL CURRENT AGAIN I ON
BEHALF OF ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND AND SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF IS STILL YOU AND I
THINK IT'S IT'S WORTH TAKING A
MOMENT JUST TAG TO HAVE A VERY
QUICK OVERVIEW OF HOW CALIFORNIA
AND FEDERAL PRIVACY LAWS RELATED
TO HEALTH INFORMATION WORK. AND
THAT IS THAT INFORMATION IS ONLY
PROTECTED TO THE EXTENT THAT
IT'S UNDER A COVERED ENTITIES TO
YOUR HEALTH CARE INFORMATION
YOUR MOST PRIVATE INFORMATION
REGARDING PRESCRIPTIONS AND
DIAGNOSIS. THOSE ARE ONLY
PROTECTED UNDER FEDERAL AND
STATE STATUTES TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY'RE COMING FROM OR
GOING TO A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
OR IN OTHER COVERED ENTITY. ON
THE CURIOUS DATABASE IS NOT A
COVERED ENTITY AND SO THIS IS
WHY WHEN YOU HEAR YOU KNOW THEY
SELL YOU ASKING FOR MORE
PROTECTION GIVEN SORT OF THE
SENSITIVITY OF THIS INFORMATION
AND AND. AND US COULD OF BEATING
THIS DRAMA OVER OVER THE COURSE
OF A FEW YEARS FOR THE NEED FOR
PRIVACY IT IS BECAUSE PEOPLE
HAVE A PRESUMPTION THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS PROTECTED BECAUSE
IT IS COMING FROM THEIR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER. BUT IT'S
IT'S ONE DEGREE AWAY AND SO IT'S
ACTUALLY NOT PROTECTED UNDER THE
SAME FEDERAL AND STATE STATUTES
THAT FOLKS OTHERWISE I WOULD
THINK THAT IT WISE AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS ON THE
EXPANSION OF DATA WE WOULD
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
AND WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
CHAIR.
SURCHARGE APPLIES REFLECT CLOSE
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
AND THE COURT HAS REACHED.
YEAH YEAH A MAN PRESENT ON THE
THIRD AND FINAL BILL WHICH ALSO.
RESPECTFULLY HAS IN AND ENJOYS
AN AYE AYE RECOMMENDATION THIS
IS AB SEVENTEEN. A FIFTY THREE
WHICH IS THIS PUBLIC SAFETY
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING W. CRISIS
WITH RESPECT TO PRESCRIPTION
PADS.
THIS OPIOID EDITION CONTINUES TO
GROW AND CRIMINAL ENTERPRISES
MAKE TREMENDOUS PROFIT THROUGH
PRESCRIPTION PAD THEFT AND
FRAUD.
PICTURES BECAUSE THE CURRENT
STATUTE PROVIDES FOR A LITTLE
AFFECTED REGULATIONS OF THE
DOZENS OF SECURITY PRINTERS
ENTRUSTED WITH MANUFACTURING THE
PRESCRIPTION PADS THAT ARE
WRITTEN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A TRACKING NUMBER
SO THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY. OVER
HERE AND WHERE KNOW WHO THESE
ARE COMING FROM ATTEND POWER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF THEN ATTRACT
ACCORDINGLY WHEN THIS GETS INTO
THE WRONG HANDS SO. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OWN HAVE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TEARS MEMBERS.
JOHN FILM CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
THIS WINE KNOW WE'RE DEALING
WITH THE OPIOID CRISIS ON THE
STREETS.
PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE IS DEAF
Y. PART OF THAT AND FEELS IT.
IT'S DEVASTATING IMPACTS OUR
COMMUNITY SO ANYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO TO HELP TRACK.
.
FRAUD IN THIS CASE.
TO THE SOURCE.
SHUT IT DOWN IS INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL LAW ENFORCEMENT OVER
COMMUNITIES SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MORTY AGAINST CHAIR MEMBERS ALL
OF IRAQ RIGHT CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN AMY BROWN ON
BEHALF OF.
CHEN IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING DIVIDENDS ALSO
HALF AMERICA'S POSITION GROUPS
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
AND VINCENT WHERE MUCH WITH ONE
GROUP ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNICA
PRAXIS ASIAN AND SPORT.
REALLY WHAT THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CARDMEMBERS
MAKING ALREADY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
ALSO KNOWN OPPOSE MUST AMENDED
POSITION OUR CONCERNS TO CENTER
ON THE FACT THAT THIS LETS THE
DEPARTMENT ARBITRARILY TAKE
THEIR.
BASICALLY FAVORITE THREE OF
THESE SECURITY PRINTERS AND THEN
ABANDONED HARASSED AND WE WOULD
ASK THAT THIS INSIGHT BE
NARROWED TO LIMIT THE CRITERIA
IF THAT'S NECESSARY BUT TO
ENSURE. THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
PROTECT
I URGE OF TRACK THE PRESCRIPTION
PADS.
AND YOU SOMETHING THAT'S A
LITTLE MORE CONSISTENT IN THEIR.
THEIR NARROWING OF THE VENDORS
WE ALSO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS SUPPLY AND THAT
THE COSTA DOES NOT SKYROCKET BY
NARROWING THE STEP THREE. SO. I
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR WORK ON THIS AND.
WANTED TO RAISE THOSE CONCERNS
AND THINK.
GOING AGAIN COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN
CHAIR MERRYMAKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO TAKING AN OPPOSING LESS
AMENDED FOR SIMILAR REASONS
EITHER WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT
CMA. YOU'D LIKE TO SEE THAT THE
BILL FOCUSES MORE ON THE
SECURITY MEASURES RATHER THAN
THEM ON A VENDOR'S THINK IF.
SOON WERE FOR THE WITNESSES TO
ANY QUESTIONS WOULD BE MEMBERS.
MISTER GRAYSON YES THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
BILL IN FOR YOUR OF PASSION FOR
SECURITY.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE OPIATE
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE.
.
JUST A A VOICE FOR SMALL
BUSINESS ESPECIALLY WELL ONE OF
THE PRINTERS JUST HAPPENS TO BE.
IN MY DISTRICT HAS THERE BEEN
ANY KIND OF.
RESEARCH DONE AS TO WHAT KIND
OF IMPACT THIS WOULD BE ON THE
VENDORS ESPECIALLY THE THE FORTY
IF I UNDERSTAND IT CORRECTLY.
THIRTEEN OF THE VENDORS ARE OUT
OF STATE.
SO I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY WE WOULD
ELIMINATE THAT.
BUT THIRTY OF THOSE VENDORS ARE
IN STATE.
SO I'M ARE THE SMALL MOM AND POP
ORDER ARE THE BIGGER AND IT'S
NOT REALLY GONNA IMPACT THEM
VERY MUCH HAS THERE BEEN SOME
RESEARCH DONE ON THAT.
YES THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED UP
PARTLY FORTY THREE VENDORS AND
THEY ARE ARE GENERALLY SMALL
BUSINESSES.
SO COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU IN ADDRESSING
THOSE CONCERNS OF IT MIGHT BE AN
IMPACT OF SMALL BUSINESSES IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE. ALSO
ADDRESS CONCERNS FROM OPPOSITION
ON ENSURING THAT THERE'S A WIDE
VARIETY.
OF.
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT CAN STILL
PARTICIPATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VETERAN.
I THINK YOU AND AND MY COLLEAGUE
AS A QUESTION THAT I WAS GONNA
ASK AROUND AROUND.
IF WE'RE LIMITING IT TO THREE
ARE WE SURE THAT THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO CAPACITY AND AND WHEN IS
THERE GOING TO BE A CHECK BACK
AS IT WOULD BE A SUNSET ARE
GOING TO SEE HOW THIS IS GOING
TO WORK OR WE'RE JUST GONNA GO
WITH THREE AND. AND GOD BLESS.
YET AS I GET SOME REALLY WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE.
MITIGATE IMPACTS TO.
THESE SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE CALIFORNIA AND OTHER WHAT
OTHERWISE IN ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE A WIDE VARIETY SO WE'RE NOT
JUST FOCUS ON JUST ALLOWING A.
THE SMALLEST SELECT A FEW OF
PARTICIPATE.
AND THEN AND I THINK JUST FOR
THE RECORD I'D LIKE TO SAY WELL.
WE HAVE A LOT OF THESE CURES
BILLS OR LOOKING AT A LOT OF THE
STUFF THE BIGGEST PART OF THE
OPENCARD EPIDEMIC REMAINS WITH
IP DRUG USE AND PEOPLE DYING ON
THE STREETS. AND SO WE CAN DO
STEPPED UP ABOUT DATA
PRESCRIPTION ADDICTION IF WE
DON'T IF WE DON'T TACKLE HEAD ON
THE ISSUE WITH I DO TO DRUG USE
THAT WERE NEVER GONNA. GET OUR
HANDS AROUND THIS PROBLEM.
VETERAN NEWSPAPER THANK YOU AND
AND I AGREE WITH BOTH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT GOOD COMMENTS IN
AND INCLUDING MR GRAYSON.
OTHER PRETTY MAYBE IN STATE.
SO OFTEN IN THE LEGISLATURE WE
DEFINE WHAT A SMALL BUSINESSES
BUT ULTIMATELY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE EMPLOYER
CONSTITUENTS AND. AND BUSINESSES
THAT ARE ALREADY AND QUITE A BIT
OF REGULATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS OF THEIR
SIZE OF LIKE TO MAKE SURE THEY
THEY DO WELL AND CAN TAKE CARE
OF THEIR EMPLOYEES AND THOSE WHO
NEED THIS.
SO I'M RELEASED SUPER STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THAT FINDING A WAY TO
REACH A RESOLUTION ON THAT THANK
YOU.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE MISTER CHAIR WAS
LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
SHARE THAT CONCERN TO AND WHEN
THE US AND THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT ABOUT THE ACCOUNTABILITY
ATTRACTING SPECIFICALLY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND WE WANT TO
MITIGATE ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT HAVE BEEN
OUTLINED BY MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES
AND SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO
IN ADDRESSING. THOSE CONCERNS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHEN
ESPECIALLY ON YOUR FIRST.
MEETING FOR.
MAKING SURE THAT WE RUN SMOOTHLY
OF THE CHAIR STILL NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM BY ONE
MEMBER SO WELL WE WISH TO BE
ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE. ABOUT
I SEE. ONE ADDITIONAL OFF ON
MULTIPLE AUTHORS HERE AND WE ARE
GOING IN FILE ORDER SO OUT OF
THIS IS FILE AND OUR NUMBER FOR.
A ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER.
PLEASE COME AND PRESENT
WHATEVER READY AND FOR A POINT
OF REFERENCE.
MEMBERS WILL BE ABLE TO SPEAK UP
TO TWO MINUTES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO MINUTES IN OPPOSITION.
A SUMMER GALLAGHER PLEASE WHEN
EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I JUST
WANT TO START BY. BY THANKING
YOU FOR LEADING A BIPARTISAN
COALITION TO ADDRESS.
THE OPIOID CRISIS IN OUR STATE
AS WE AS WE KNOW IT YOU'VE HELD
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON THIS.
AND THIS REALLY AFFECTS EVERY
PART OF THE STATE AND THE ONE
PLACE IS CERTAINLY.
AFFECTING VERY DEEPLY IS THE
RURAL PARTS CALIFORNIA.
SO AB.
TWENTY EIGHTY SIX IS
YOU KNOW ONE OF.
ONE TOOL THAT WE'RE PROPOSING TO
HELP. I DEAL WITH THE OPIATE
CRISIS AND AND WHAT IT FOCUSES
ON IS TRYING TO.
CRACK DOWN ON FRAUDULENT.
PRESCRIPTIONS
BY ALLOWING PRESCRIBERS OF
OPIOIDS.
MILLION DOCTORS AND OTHERS.
.
TO REVIEW THEIR PRESCRIBING
HISTORY AND OUR TO VERIFY THE
ACCURACY OF WHAT THAT LIST IS
SHOWING HAS WHO THEY'RE
PRESCRIBING FOR. UNFORTUNATELY
UNDER CURRENT LAW PRESCRIBERS
CAN ONLY PULL UP INDIVIDUAL
PATIENTS TO CHECK THAT PATIENT'S
PRESCRIPTION HISTORY.
MANY OTHER STATES AYE WITH
PRESCRIPTION DRUG MONITORING
PROGRAMS ALLOW PROVIDERS TO VIEW
ALL OF THE PATIENTS. WHO ARE
LISTED WITH THAT PRESCRIBER?
SO AB TWENTY EIGHTY SIX INSURERS
A PRESCRIBERS IN CALIFORNIA CAN
DO SO AS WELL. BY ALLOWING THE
PRESCRIBED ACCESS SECURES
DATABASE FOR A LIST OF PATIENTS
FOR WHOM THEY ARE LISTED. AS A
PRESCRIBED HER.
ALLOWING REVIEW PRESCRIPTION
HISTORY TO VERIFY ACCURACY WILL
HELP PRESCRIBERS FLAG AND REPORT
SUSPICIOUS PRESCRIPTIONS THAT
THEY MAY NOT HAVE ACTUALLY. OF
WRITTEN THERE'S BEEN CASES
ACTUALLY WEAR PRESCRIPTION PADS
HAVE BEEN STOLEN FROM OFFICES
AND THEN. THAT PEOPLE USE US TO
WRITE FRAUDULENT PRESCRIPTIONS
AND AND THEY ARE ABLE TO GO AND
GET ACCESS TO MORE OPIOIDS WENT
THEN THE OTHERWISE.
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO.
AND AND AS I SAID YOU KNOW THIS
IS GONNA BE A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH.
TO TACKLE THIS ISSUE.
TREATMENT.
YOU KNOW IT CRACKING DOWN ON
FRAUD AND PRESCRIPTIONS.
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE YOU KNOW
SOME.
SOME BETTER CONTROLS ON ON HOW
THIS IS GETTING OUT INTO THE.
THE COMMUNITY ALL THOSE THINGS
SEEM TO BE DONE.
BUT THIS IS ONE OF THOSE TOOLS
AND I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB TWENTY EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT DID KNOW ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
JUSTIN ME TOWARD YOU OF WISH TO
SPEND UP TO TWO MINUTES.
FEEL LIKE.
THANK YOU MISTER CARDMEMBERS.
MAKE IT ALRIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THEY DON'T NEED ALL OF TWO
MINUTES BUT IT'S REALLY ONE I.
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR THE SPELL
AND SAY THAT WE ARE INSURANCE
SUPPORT. ESPECIALLY AS AMENDED
TO ALLOW THE POSITION TO CHECK
THEIR OWN RECORD AS OPPOSED TO
HAVING TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT FOR
THEIR PRESCRIBING RECORD.
AS IN THE EXAMPLE THAT MR
GALLAGHER AND NOTED. THIS IS AN
ISSUE WHERE PHYSICIANS HAVE NO
WAY OF SEEING. WHAT THEY'RE
WHOSE NAME OR I'M SORRY?
WHOSE HISTORY THEIR NAME COMES
UP UNDER UNLESS THEY KNOW THAT
THAT PATIENT SPECIFICALLY HAS
SEEN THEM AND BEEN PRESCRIBED
FROM THEM SO. I'M WE THINK THAT
THIS WILL JUST.
REALLY ALLOW POSITIONS TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS
ACCURATE.
AND WILL HELP IN YOU'LL ISN'T
YOUR SYSTEM TO ITS FULLEST IN
ORDER SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
DODD KAREN CYBER PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHTY SIX
WILL MAKE THE DATA EASIER TO
ACCESS AND MORE RELIABLE FOR
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER. PROVIDERS
AND IT'LL HELP KEEP THE CURIOUS
DATABASE FROM EVER ACTING AS A
ROADBLOCK TO THE PAIN RELIEF
THAT SO MANY PATIENTS URGENTLY
NEED THANK YOU.
CATHERINE ALSO SCOTT HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
MARY MECHANIC THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THE GOOD MORNING DAVID GONZALEZ
OF AMERICA'S POSITION GROUPS
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
JERRY HEADS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT.
THINGS WERE MUCH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIACHIROPRACTIC
ASSOCIATION'S BOARD.
THANK YOU DITION WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE OTHER
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEM NOT TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
DYESS MEMBERS WISHING TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE MISTER GALLAGHER
LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER WE'RE
STILL SUBCOMMITTEE WILL TAKE
THAT UP WHEN WE GOT A CORE.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM FIVE A. B.
TWO TWO FIVE SIX MISTER
SANTIAGO.
I'LL BE BRIEF IF IT SUITS THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU CAN ALWAYS TO US.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SIX WOULD
ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO APPLY
OPIATE OPIATE I AND.
ANTAGONISTIC  WITHOUT
PRESCRIPTION.
THAT MISTER CHAIR AND I HAVE A.
.
WITNESS.
MORNINGS RETURN MEMBERS BRENDAN
UP ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. WHEN WE
STARTED OUR NOR CAN PROGRAM LAST
YEAR WE.
WENT DIRECTLY TO A WHOLESALER
ASKED TO PURCHASE A LARGE SHOT
QUANTITY OF OF NOR KANSEN GET.
ADMINISTERED.
DEPLOY IT.
TORE FIELD TRIPS AND WERE MET
WITH A.
YEAH I WOULD LOVE TO SELL TO
YOU BUT YOU'VE GOT TO GET A
PRESCRIPTION FOR.
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM ANYONE
LISTENING TO THIS.
HEARING OR WATCHING IT CAN WALK
IN ANY FORM SEE TODAY AND BY NOR
CAN OVER THE COUNTER.
FROM THE PHARMACY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT HOWEVER HAS TO
GET A PRESCRIPTION FIRST THIS
BECAUSE OF THAT DELAY OF ABOUT
FOUR MONTHS.
IN IMPLEMENTING OUR PROGRAM. SO
WHAT WE WANNA DO IS.
ELIMINATE THAT ON THE SYRIA
BARRIER OF FIRST PERTAIN OR
OBTAINING A PRESCRIPTION FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITHIN THE
STATE.
I SINCE WE IMPLEMENT OUR PROGRAM
WE'VE DEPLOYED IT THIRTEEN
TIMES.
AND WE SAVED ELEVEN LIVES.
SO WE THINK IT'S.
IT REMOVED REMOVING THAT
BARRIER WAS A IS COMPLETELY
NECESSARY WOULD GET THIS OUT FOR
TRIPS FASTER APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEIR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MR JOHNSON BE HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION AND FOR.
MARY WE CANNOT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MAKE AN ORIGAMI HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
JERRY HEXUM MAY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVEN TO THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
IT'S PART.
GLENN BACCHUS DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DISH NO SUPPORT SEEING
NONE OF THE WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE WISH
ASK ANY QUESTIONS DR.
I THINK YOU AND THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD O.
AGAIN WITH THE ISSUE OF NALOXONE
REALLY IMPORTANT AND JUST AS. I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T SAY.
THAT WAS THE.
PROGRAM WE ALLOWED.
COUNTIES HE'LL GIVE IT OUT AND
THAT HAD HIGH INCIDENCES OF
OVERDOSE
AND SO THAT AGAIN IS WHAT WE
BASIS SAFE INJECTION SITE BILL
ON THAT EXACT SAME THING TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM DYING IN
OVERDOSING BY.
OF THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LOCKS AND IF SOMEBODY'S IN A IN
A. IN A FIELD SITUATION WHERE
THEY OVERDOSE SO AGAIN I THINK
IS A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH THAT
WE NEED TO KEEP LOOKING AT ALL
OPTIONS AND AND. AND AT SOME
POINT WE NEED TO BE COURAGEOUS
ENOUGH TO PUT ALL OPTIONS THAT
OUR DATA BASED ON THE TABLE
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK.
SEEING NONE MISTER SANTIAGO
DIRECT CLUBS. BIG MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS A SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT
BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW PHARMACIES
OR WHOLESALERS.
TO DIRECTLY.
.
FURNISH A LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH A
OPIATE ANTAGONISED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING WERE
STILL SUBCOMMITTEE WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM WILL TAKE A BULLET FOR.
SEE NO AUTHORS AT THE CURRENT
MOMENT THE SERGEANTS ARE CALLING
MEMBERS TO PRESENT.
SO.
WE'LL TAKE A. SHORT BREAK. TO WE
GET ADDITIONAL AUTHORS HERE
.
SO IF MEMBERS ARE STAFF FOR
WATCHING THIS COMMITTEE.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BURKE.
ASSEMBLYMAN WOULD.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CABALLERO
ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON
ASSEMBLYMAN BLOOM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY.
SOME LIMIT COOLEY AND
ASSEMBLYMAN CHIP WHO READY TO
HEAR YOUR BILLS
.
NOW THERE
WE HAVE AN AUTHOR SOMEONE WOMAN
BURKE THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WE WILL TAKE UP NOW FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB TWO SEVEN FOUR ONE.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
ONE SUCH A FIVE DAY LIMIT ON
WILL BE I'D PRESCRIPTIONS FOR
ACUTE PAIN MANAGEMENT FOR
MINORS.
WITH EXCEPTIONS FOR CHRONIC PAIN
MANAGEMENT HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE PATIENTS CANCER
PATIENTS MINORS WHO ARE UNDER
TREATMENT FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS IN CASE OF AN
EMERGENCY.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY ONE ALSO
REQUIRES A DOCTOR TO INFORM THE
MINOR'S PARENT OR LEGAL GUARDIAN
OF THE DANGERS AND RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE OP A
PRESCRIPTION DRUG USE. AND
CHRISSY RECEIVED CONSENT BEFORE
PRESCRIBING OPIOIDS MEDICATION
ACCORDING TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN STUDY BY THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS OPIOID
POISONING AND OVERDOSES ARE
SENDING INCREASED NUMBERS OF U.
S. CHILDREN AND TEENS.
TO THE HOSPITAL.
CONSULTATIONS WERE MOST COMMON
AMONG KIDS AGED TWELVE TO
SEVENTEEN IN THOSE EIGHT ONE TWO
FIVE.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
AMOUNT OF OPIATES PRESCRIBED WAS
ENOUGH FOR EVERY AMERICAN TO BE
MEDICAID AROUND THE CLOCK FOR
THREE WEEKS AND ABOUT SIXTY
PERCENT OF AMERICANS HAVE YOU.
HAVE AN UNUSED OPIUM OPIATE IN
THEIR HOME.
SEVERAL HAVE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE US FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION AND THE CENTER
FOR DC DISEASE CONTROL ALL AGREE
THAT OPRAH OVER PRESCRIBING OF
OPIOID MEDICATIONS HAS DIRECTLY
CONTRIBUTED. TO THE ADDICTION
CRISIS.
ONE OF ARE CO AUTHORS REPUBLICAN
LEADER BRIAN DOLLY HAS SEEN
FIRSTHAND THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF THE OPIATE CRISIS IN
HIS DISTRICT SOME PLACES HAVE
MORE OPIATE PRESCRIPTIONS THAN
PEOPLE.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE ON DRUG ABUSE NEARLY
HALF OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO INJECT
PARA MORE PORTED ABUSING
PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS BEFORE
TURNING TO HER WHEN.
IN JULY OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE CDC RELEASED
UPDATED GUIDELINES ARE
RECOMMENDED NO MORE THAN THREE
DAY PRESCRIPTION FOR ACUTE PAIN
MANAGEMENT THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
RECOMMENDS OPIOID FOR ACUTE
MANAGEMENT WITH MINORS. ONLY
AFTER NON OPIOID ALTERNATES HAS
FAILED. AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
ONE IS EVIDENCE BASED AND DATA
DRIVEN ABOUT SERGEANT TO
DISTRIBUTE THE EVIDENCE AND DATA
THAT SUPPORTS A FIVE DAY WOMEN
AS OUTLINED BY THE CDC.
ACCORDING TO THEIR MARCH TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN STUDY LONG
TERM OPIOID USE OFTEN BEGINS
WITH TREATMENT OF ACUTE PAIN.
THE PROBABILITY OF LONG TERM
OPIATE USE INCREASED MORE
SHARPLY IN THE FIRST DAYS OF
THERAPY PARTICULARLY FIVE DAYS.
NOW I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY ONE SUSAN
DAVIS.
THIS DAVIS IS WITH PATHWAY TO
PREVENTION AND IS HERE
REPRESENTING A MOTHER WHO LOST
HER CHILD TO OPIATE ADDICTION.
MY NAME WITH A C.
KING SO THAT I AM A CO FOUNDER
PATHWAY TO PREVENTION ARE
NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO STOPPING
KIDS FROM ABUSING DRUGS OR
ALCOHOL.
BOB WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT STOP
BEFORE IT STARTS AND I'M HERE.
OF FIRST LET ME THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN LOW AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB T. SEVEN FOUR ONE.
WE HOPE THAT FOR ME.
I'M SPEAKING IN PLACE OF LINDA
CHAPMAN WHO LOST HER DAUGHTER
TIFFANY TO COMPLICATIONS OF
LIVER FAILURE THE DIRECT RESULT
OF HER ADDICTION TO PRESCRIPTION
PAIN MEDICATIONS.
TIFFANY WAS JUST TWENTY SEVEN
WHEN SHE DIED.
TIFFANY NOEL CHAPMAN WAS A
GOLDEN CHILD WITH A BRIGHT
FUTURE SHE HAD JUST BEEN VOTED.
FAST PRESIDENT OF FOR SENIOR
HIGH SCHOOL.
CLASS
BUT FIVE WEEKS INTO THE START OF
THAT HIGH SCHOOL YEAR SHE WAS
REAR ENDED BY DISTRACTED DRIVER.
TIFFANY BROKER KNACK WAS PUT
INTO A HALO DEVICE Y. SCREWS IN
HER HEAD. AND SHE WAS HOME
SCHOOLED FOR THE REST OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR. SHE WAS PRESCRIBED
POWERFUL OPIOIDS AND OTHER
MEDICATIONS TO HELP HER SLEEP
AND HANDLE HURRYING SOCIETY.
THIS IS WHAT LINDA WRITES I WAS
NAIVE ABOUT PAIN MEDICATIONS AND
HAD NO IDEA THAT THEY COULD
BECOME ADDICTIVE.
PARTICULARLY TO A BRAIN THAT WAS
STILL DEVELOPING.
TIFFANY WAS IN A LOT OF PAIN AND
I TRUSTED HER DOCTORS TO MONITOR
THE AMOUNT OF PILLS SHE WAS
TAKING.
SOMETIMES THOSE SHE HAD A BOTTLE
OF NINETY PILLS FOR WHEN
PRESCRIPTION AND THEN HAD
ANOTHER FROM A DIFFERENT DOCTOR.
BY COULD IN NORCO WITH THE NAMES
OF TWO OF HER MOST COMMON
PRESCRIPTIONS.
ONE TIME WE HAD TO TAKE TIFFANY
TO THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
SHE WAS SO SICK AND DISORIENTED
THEY USE THE WORD OVERDOSED A
WORD I ASSOCIATED ONLY WITH
DEATH.
THEY TOLD ME THAT SHE WAS
PROBABLY ADDICTED TO HER PAIN
PILLS.
IN LESS THAN FIVE HOURS AFTER
SHE WAS STABLE THEY CENTER HOME.
I WAS IN SHOCK I THOUGHT THEY
WOULD KEEP IT THERE UNTIL SHE
GOT WELL REALLY WELL. I WANTED
MORE INFORMATION BUT THEY DIDN'T
HAVE ANY INFORMATION TO GIVE ME
EXCEPT.
THEY ADVISED ME TO GO LOOK ON
THE INTERNET.
AT ANOTHER VISIT TO THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT A DOCTOR
TOLD US TO TELL TIFFANY TO.
FLUSH ALL THOSE PILLS DOWN THE
TOILET OR SHE WAS GOING TO END
UP IN A BODY BAG.
STILL NO INFORMATION WAS GIVEN
ON WHERE WE CAN GO FOR HELP. IT
DIDN'T SEEM LIKE ANYONE CARED I
WANTED TO HELP HER BUT DIDN'T
KNOW HOW JUST TAKING THE PILLS
AWAY FROM HER DIDN'T SOLVE THE
ADDICTION PROBLEM.
LATER ON TIFFANY GOT A JOB AND
MOVED INTO HER OWN APARTMENT
PREDICTION GOT WORSE SHE NOW HAD
MORE THAN ONE DOCTOR SHE WAS
DOCTOR SHOPPING IN SHE WAS
PHARMACY SHOPPING.
HER NEW DOCTOR STARTED HER ON
ANOTHER PAIN MEDICATION ONE THAT
REQUIRED FEWER PILLS IN A DAY HE
TOLD HER ABOUT IT IT WAS CALLED
OXYCONTIN.
HE SAID THAT NOW SHOULD ONLY
HAVE TO TAKE ONE PILL IN THE
MORNING IN ONE IN THE EVENING.
THIS LATER JUMPED SHIP THREE OR
FOUR IN THE MORNING WITH THE
SAME AMOUNT IN THE EVENING.
PREDICTION EVENTUALLY LEAD TO
MORE AND MORE E. R. VISITS FIVE
DETOX IS
CHIU UNCOMPLETED TREATMENT
PROGRAMS A DUI LIVER FAILURE AND
LASTLY HER DEATH.
THE SEEDS OF ADDICTION WERE
PLANTED IN TIFFANY'S PLASTIC
DEVELOPING BRAIN WHEN DOCTORS
PRESCRIBE POWERFUL OP WHICH TO A
MINOR.
SHE WAS IS SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL
WHEN THAT BEGAN. HER PARENTS
WERE KEPT IN THE DARK AND
RENDERED HELPLESS AND AS MORE
AND MORE DOCTORS. PRESCRIBE MORE
AND MORE POWERFUL APPEAL RIGHTS
TIFFANY NO WELL CHAPMAN DIED AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY SEVEN.
WE NEED TO PASS A BE TWO SEVEN
FOUR ONE TO STOP ADDICTION
BEFORE IT STARTS.
TIFFANY WAS JUST TWENTY SEVEN
WHEN SHE DIED AND IT COULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR TAX MONEY WERE
ALSO I FEEL LOST AND EACH ONE OF
US HAVE FAR TOO MANY STORIES
LIKE THAT IN DISTRICT TO
REPRESENT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TO HEAR.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRMAN LOW IN MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME MY NAME IS
VALERIE LEVEL A LOT.
AND AYE AMERICA'S BRING HOPE YOU
IN THAT IT.
MY STORY BEGINS THE DAY AFTER
CHRISTMAS ON DECEMBER TWENTY
SIXTH OF TWO THOUSAND TWELVE I
WAS DRIVING I WAS ON MY WAY TO
PICK MY SISTER UP. I DIDN'T KNOW
IT THEN BUT ON THAT DAY MY LIFE
WOULD CHANGE FOREVER.
AS THEY DROVE THROUGH THE
INTERSECTION A CARD TO MY RIGHT
HAD RAN A RED LIGHT AND HIT MY
CAR AT APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE
MILES AN HOUR.
MY CAR SWERVED ONTO ONCOMING
TRAFFIC BEFORE COMING TO A
COMPLETE STOP MY DAD QUICKLY
ARRIVED AT THE SCENE AND DROVE
ME TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM FOR THE
NEXT TWO AND A HALF YEARS
STRAIGHT I WAS PRESCRIBED
COPIOUS AMOUNTS OF HYDROCODONE
OXYCONTIN. NINETY TO HUNDRED
TWENTY TABLETS WEEKLY TO BE
EXACT.
I HAD SEVERAL MONTHS OF SEVERE
BACK AND NECK PAIN BUT NO BROKEN
BONES.
DOCTOR WHO WAS PRESCRIBING THE
MEDICATION SO I MADE THE MISTAKE
OF DEEMING IT OKAY AND SAVE. IT
ONLY TOOK A FEW DAYS AND A FEW
TABLETS BEFORE THE DISEASE
CONSUMED MY ENTIRE LIFE
PARALYZING ME UNTIL I COULD TAKE
MY NEXT DOSE.
AFTER TWO AND A HALF YEARS OF
THE CYCLE OF PHARMACISTS FLIGHT
MY PRESCRIPTION STATING THAT IT
WAS SUSPICIOUS HOW QUICKLY I
WOULD GO THROUGH THE REFILLS. MY
DOCTOR WAS NOTIFIED AND I WAS
CUT OFF FROM FEATURE OPIATE
PRESCRIPTIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY BY THIS TIME I WAS
ALREADY HEAVILY ADDICTED AND NOW
WAS LEFT TO GO INTO WITHDRAWAL
ELEVEN WITHOUT ANY HELP OR
SUPPORT OR EDUCATION FROM THE
VERY DOCTOR THAT PRESCRIBED AND
TO ME.
I FELT ALONE SCARED ANGRY AND
ASHAMED I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WHAT
WITHDRAWAL WHAT'S BUT I LEARNED.
IN FACT THE FEAR OF GOING INTO
WITHDRAWAL IS WHAT CAN I
ADDITIONAL LIFE FOR OVER FOUR
YEARS MY LIFE QUICKLY BECAME ALL
ABOUT CHASING MY NEXT TYPE
BECAUSE IT WAS THE ONLY THING
THAT KEPT ME FROM GOING INTO
WITHDRAWAL.
I ISOLATED MYSELF FROM MY
FRIENDS AND MY FAMILY BECAUSE I
WAS ASHAMED OF WHAT I WAS DOING
AND I WAS AFRAID OF SOMEBODY
FINDING OUT. I FOUND MYSELF IN
THIS NEVER ENDING CYCLE OF
CONSTANTLY BEING IN FIGHTER
FLIGHT MODE. I DID THINGS I
NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD I LIED I
STOLE A BECAME SOMEONE I NO
LONGER RECOGNIZED I HAD GIVEN.
I HAD GIVEN UP.
I DID THINGS I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD DO I DID THAT.
I BECAME SOMEONE I NO LONGER
RECOGNIZE I'D GIVEN UP ON LIFE
AND HAD TRULY ACCEPTED THAT I
WOULD DIE YOUNG.
I SPENT MANY NIGHTS SETTING
MULTIPLE ALARMS TO TRY TO STAY
AWAKE BECAUSE I KNEW THERE WAS A
POSSIBILITY THAT I WOULDN'T WAKE
BACK UP.
I LOST MY MORALS MY HEALTH MY
SELF ESTEEM. AND MY HOPE AND MY
HAPPINESS BUT MOSTLY I LOST MY
WILL TO LIVE. I WENT FROM A
CARING VIVACIOUS AND SOCIAL
PERSON THAT NEVER DID DRUGS IN
THE PAST. TO BEING A FULL BLOWN
OPIOID ADDICT AT ONLY TWENTY
THREE YEARS OLD.
IF I KNEW THAT WHAT I KNOW NOW I
WOULD HAVE APPROACHED MY INJURY
AND TREATMENT MUCH DIFFERENTLY.
TODAY AS I STAND HERE BEFORE YOU
I'M EXACTLY TWO YEARS AND FOUR
MONTHS OVER.
IT IS WITH THE HELP OF MY
ADDICTION THERAPIST CURTIS BUT
SANSKI MY NEW PHYSICIAN DR ERIC
TUPPER MY FAMILY AND MY FRIENDS
THAT I'M ALIVE TODAY.
BUT THE BATTLE IS FAR FROM OVER
IT WILL NEVER BE OVER. EVERYDAY
THAT I WAKEUP I MAKE THE CHOICE
TO FIGHT FOR MY SOBRIETY MY LIFE
WILL NEVER BE WHAT IT WAS BEFORE
ADDICTION. I CONSIDER MYSELF ONE
OF THE LUCKY ONES BECAUSE I
LIVED TO TELL MY STORY BUT I'LL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR THE
MILLIONS OF LIVES THAT WERE CUT
SHORT AND FOR THE MILLION MORE
LIVES THAT WILL BE CUT SHORT IN
THE FUTURE.
I'M HERE BECAUSE I'M ASKING FOR
CHANGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVEN FOUR ONE
IS A GREAT STEP TOWARDS
PROTECTING MINORS FROM OPIOID
ADDICTION AND ENSURING THAT BOTH
THE PATIENT AND PARENTS ARE
FULLY EDUCATED ON THE RISKS AND
DANGERS OF OPIOIDS. I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD AND
ASKED THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES
ON AB TWO SEVEN FOUR ONE
THINKING OF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR SHARING
YOUR STORY WITH US OTHER
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
KATHY HALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARENT TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
SHERRI MCKEE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS READ UP THERE IN
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION WEREN'T SUPPORT LOOK
FOR TO FUTURE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR. RUN THE INCLUSION OF
ON.
INFORMATION REGARDING AND NON.
NON PHARMACOLOGICAL
INTERVENTIONS.
AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO PAIN
MANAGEMENT.
MAYBE CANNOT THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WHERE IN A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION I
WILL AFFORD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH AUTHORS OFFICE TO HAVE
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD INCLUDE.
OTHER REGULATORY BOARDS THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO CREATE THE
INFORMED CONSENT FORMS
THANK YOU.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF OF
GATEKEEPER INNOVATION IN
SUPPORT.
RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION WOULD
LIKE TO ADD OUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO SHOW WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT SEEN NONE OF THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
THE MORNING WAS RICHARD MEMBERS
MAKE AN ALREADY BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. I'M A WHILE WE ARE
DEFINITELY SYMPATHETIC TO. THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT WITH THIS AND
SHARE THE SAME GOALS OF ENSURING
SAFETY IN FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE
PRESCRIBED OPIOIDS I'M OR MINORS
ARE PRESCRIBED OPIOIDS. I'M WE
HAVE SOME VERY SAD. VERY SERIOUS
CONCERN ABOUT THE WAY THAT IT'S
WRITTEN.
SPECIFICALLY THE SPELL DRAWS A
HARD LINER FIVE DAYS FOR
PRESCRIPTION REGARDLESS OF
SPECIFIC PATIENTS AT NEEDS ARE
UNIQUE CHARACTERISTICS.
SUCH AS PROXIMITY TO THE DOCTOR
ACCESS TO APPOINTMENTS.
AND ANYTHING ELSE THAT
SPECIFICALLY RELATES TO THAT
PATIENT AND WE THINK THAT TIME.
FLEXIBILITY IS NEEDED AND THAT'S
WHY THESE ARE POSITION DECISIONS
THAT THEY'RE MADE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PATIENT.
IT ALSO PRESCRIBES I INFORMED
CONSENT LANGUAGE OR WHAT NEEDS
TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
CONVERSATION WE FEEL LIKE THAT'S
ACTUALLY DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
ASIDE.
BECAUSE THIS NEEDS TO BE PATIENT
SPECIFIC AND THE POSITION NEEDS
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS.
ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE RELEVANT
TO THAT PATIENT THE OTHER
MEDICATIONS THEY MIGHT BE
TAKING.
BUT SETTING A STANDARD FOR WHAT
EXACTLY HAS TO BE IN THAT
CONVERSATION PLAN WE WOULD SAY
THAT THAT IS.
I UNNECESSARY AND THAT INFORMED
CONSENT OF ALL THE RISKS AND
DANGERS TO SOMETHING THAT
POSITIONS ARE ALREADY TESTED
YOU.
BUT IT ALSO REQUIRES SIGNED
PARENTAL CONSENT FOR MINOR FOR
MEDICAL PROCEDURE WHICH WE
THINGS.
UP FINISH THE SAID SAY DANGER
FOR CITING GOING FORWARD BUT. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HOME TO WORKING
ON THIS AND TO ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE. AND WOOD.
.
I SWEAR OPPOSITION ON THE BILL
AS IT IS IN PRINT THINKING.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRAVE TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR ANY.
SOMEONE THEY CAN THANK YOU M.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT
WITNESSES WHO CAME AND
TESTIFIED.
ON BEHALF OF THE PARENT WHO
LOST A CHILD AND ALSO THEM.
AS OUR WITNESS YOU SHARED WITH
US PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
COGENT AND MEANINGFUL
EXPLANATIONS OF WHAT OPIOIDS CAN
DO YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING STRONG KEEP
IT UP AND.
IT IS A REMINDER TO US THE WORK
THAT WE NEED TO DO IN OUR STATE
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF YOU AND
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN.
SO VERY IMPRESSED BY IT.
TO THE QUESTIONS OF THE
OPPOSITION REYES ACTUALLY THINK
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR HIM SEEM
IS REPRESENTED.
ON THE INFORMED CONSENT
QUESTION.
.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE BILL THAT
PREVENTS THE DOCTOR FROM GIVING
ALL THE CONSENT THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED.
IS THAT CORRECT WHEN THEY COULD
STILL DO ALL THAT YOU JUST SAID
UNDER THE SPELL. LIST THAT'S HOW
I READ IT MAYBE I SHOULD ASK THE
AUTHOR YES YES YES IT DOES AND
WHAT THEY CAN SAN ACTUALLY THE
PURPOSE FOR IT IS BECAUSE IT
ALSO WERE ADDING TO WHAT THEY'VE
ARI. THE OPEN SPAN OF WHAT THEY
CAN ALREADY ASK YOU CAN CONTINUE
TO DO THEIR JOB THE WAY THEY'VE
BEEN DOING THAT PORTION WE JUST
ALSO ARE ASKING THAT THEY ASK IF
THERE HAS BEEN PASSED USE OR
PAST ABUSE APPARENTLY. HELPFUL
SO AND IT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOT.
CITY LOW BAR FOR WHAT IS
INFORMED CONSENT AND I MAKE SURE
THAT THE PHYSICIANS DON'T HAVE
THEIR HANDS TIED THAT'S ALL THE
CADENCE THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
AND THEN WITH RESPECT TO ACCESS
ANY IDEAS THAT MISTER DALI IS A
CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
REPRESENTS A FAIRLY RURAL PART
OF THE STATE. AND SO I I FIND
THAT.
NO WORTHY BUT ADD TO THAT POINT
HAVE THOSE WHO CANNOT EASILY GET
TO EIGHT PHYSICALLY TO A
PHYSICIAN.
SO NOT THE CASE YOU CAN OFTEN
CALL YOUR PHYSICIAN OR OTHERWISE
WOULD WITH ANYTHING STOP THAT
SUPERMARKET BECAUSE OF THE
SCHEDULE OF DRUG YOU CAN CALL IN
CAN YOU CAN'T CALLING HOWEVER I
WILL BE SUPER CLEAR THAT THAT.
THE BILL DOES ALLOW DOCTORS TO
PRESCRIBE MORE THAN FIVE DAYS IF
THEY FELT IT WAS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY SO LONG AS IT IS
NOTED.
IN THE MEDICAL RECORD.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T IF IT IS
MEDICALLY NECESSARY GOT OKAY I'M
THINK YOU KNOW I REALLY THE
STATUS WHEN CAREFULLY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE OVERLY
RIGID. BUT AS YOU KNOW PARENTS
HAVE TO FOURTEEN YEAR OLDS I AM
TERRIFIED AT THE PROSPECT THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS COULD HAPPEN
TO THEM OBVIOUSLY THE INJURY TO
BEGIN WITH BUT THEN THE
ADDITIONAL LIFELONG FAX.
SO I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL THINKING.
THANK YOU SOMEONE BAKER
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
BUT MR BLUE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPOSITION.
.
I THINK THE CAN YOU EXPLAIN JUST
ON THAT NARROW POINT OF THE.
FIVE DAYS IF THERE'S.
A AN ALLOWANCE FOR DOCTOR TO.
PLACED IN THE RECORD A NOTATION
THAT WHICH YOU WOULD THINK WOULD
BE IN THE RECORD ANYWAY THAT
IT'S MEDICALLY NECESSARY TO GO
BEYOND FIVE DAYS. WISER PROBLEM
JUST ON THAT SPECIFIC PROVISION.
I THINK SPECIFIC TO THAT THE
OPPOSITION AT. IS TO THE POINT
OF.
PUTTING THE PROVIDER IN A PLACE
OF LIABILITY BECAUSE IT ASSUMES
THAT FIVE DAYS IS THE MAX THAT
IS ACTUALLY NECESSARY. AND THAT
GOING ABOVE THAT WOULD BE
EXCESSIVE OR REQUIRES A SPECIFIC
EXPLANATION OF WHY THEY MIGHT
NEED TO GO ABOVE THAT. AND IT.
IT'S.
LIKE I SAID IT'S ASSUMING THAT
FIVE DAYS WOULD BE THE MAX THE
COULD EVER BE NECESSARY AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS SO PATIENT
SPECIFIC.
AND SHOULD NOT BE WRITTEN INTO
STATUE OF BECAUSE IT IS NOT.
THERE IS NO BRIGHT LINE THAT WE
CAN DRIVE WHAT NUMBER OF DAYS IS
SPECIFIC TO EVERY SINGLE PATIENT
AND WILL ALWAYS BE SUFFICIENT.
AND SO CUTTING IT OFF OF FIVE
DAYS MINCING AFTER THAT YOU HAVE
TO DEFEND YOURSELF WE THINK IS
REALLY LEGISLATING THE PRACTICE
OF MEDICINE. AND I'M.
AND REALLY IT'S JUST NOT
APPROPRIATE. AND DOES NOT HAVE
ANY DATA TO SUPPORT THAT THAT
WILL BE APPROPRIATE FOR EVERY
SINGLE PATIENT EVERY TIME.
IF THEY THE CHAIR I COULD
RESPOND ABSOLUTE I DOES THIS EDC
ACTUALLY DOES GIVE A
RECOMMENDATION AND IT IS THREE
DAYS SO WE HAVE WE HAVE TAKEN
THAT INTO ACCOUNT ALSO IF IT
WEREN'T. NECESSARY WE WOULDN'T
ALL BE HERE.
IF WAS A NECESSARY TO MAKE THEM
SOME HARD AND FAST DECISIONS WE
REALLY WOULDN'T BE STANDING HERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS AND QUITE
FRANKLY.
ANY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME
THROUGH THE MOUTH OR TAKE TEN
YEARS FROM THE RECOMMENDATIONS
BECOME COMMON PRACTICE AND THIS
EPIDEMIC HAS NINETY ONE DEATHS
EACH DAY FORTY TWO OF THEM ARE
FROM PRESCRIBE OPIATES.
JUDICIAL MEMBERS WISHING SPEAK.
I COULD JUST CALL MAYBE ASK A
QUESTION OPPOSITION SO IT IS.
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF US ARE TRYING
TO APPROACH THIS FROM DIFFERENT
ANGLES AND.
THERE'S BEEN A QUESTION BAILEY
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL ABOUT
WHETHER THE THIRTY DAY
PRESCRIPTION IS OBSOLETE AND
DISCUSSIONS AROUND THAT.
AND THEN YOU INVOLVED A STEP
THERAPY WHERE.
SOMETIMES HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS WILL SAY YOU NEED TO TRY
THIS FIRST THE SECOND IN A
PHYSICIAN WILL GET DOWN TO WHERE
MAYBE I DON'T FOR. A IS BEST TO
DECIDE EFFECTS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
WITHIN YOUR COMMUNITY.
OF BEING INVOLVED WHETHER
THE THIRD BECAUSE IN MY VIEW.
YOU KNOW I KNOW WE ALL WORRY
ABOUT THE COST OF HEALTH CARE
BUT.
WHAT'S THE HARM IN IN ISSUING
FIVE DAYS IN SAYING.
LET ME CALL YOU FOR FOLLOW UP
YOU HAVE ANY SIDE EFFECTS MAY
BE.
A DIFFERENT DRUG IS REQUIRED OR
ARE HIS.
ARE YOU WORKING ON ANY OF THESE
ISSUES ARE IS ANY. INFORMATION
TO KIND OF CHANGE WHAT'S GOING
ON.
YES ACTUALLY THERE HAVE BEEN
GREAT CHANGES THAT POSITIONS
HAVE MADE IMPROVE PRESCRIBERS OF
MAINE. I'M OVER THE YEARS IN
THEIR PRESCRIBING PRACTICES
WE'VE SEEN TWO YEARS AWARE
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF ONLY A FEW
STATES THAT HAS NOT HAD. AN
INCREASE IN OVERDOSE DEATHS
WE'VE BEEN CONSISTENTLY. I'M
DOWN TRENDING WE HAVE SOME OF
THE LOWEST PER CAPITA I'VE
OPIOID PRESCRIPTION PRESCRIBING.
AND.
SO WE WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
POSITIONS ARE TAKING THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY AND HAVE CHANGED THEIR
PRESCRIBING PRACTICES HAVE
STARTED WORKING WITH. YOU KNOW
LET'S TRY OTHER MEDICATIONS
FIRST AND SEE IF THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY WHEN
BEFORE.
THEY MAY HAVE GONE STRAIGHT TO
HAVE A STRONGER MEDICATION
BECAUSE YOU KNOW FOR YERS
THEY'VE BEEN TASKED WITH MAKING
FOR THEY APPROPRIATELY TREAT
PAIN AND DO NOT UNDER TREAT
PAIN.
SO COMING BACK FROM THAT AS
THERE'S BEEN A LOT THAT HAS BEEN
DONE ON THE THE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY OR BY THE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY.
AND SO WE WOULD ASK THAT WE ARE
ALLOWED. CONTINUED DOING THAT AS
AND MAKING THOSE DIFFERENT
CHANGES AND CONTINUE SEEING IT
AND THE DATA AS IT'S REPORTED.
I'M.
AND SO SETTING SOMETHING LIKE A.
IT'S JUST SOLID MIND AS TO WHERE
YOU CAN PRESCRIBE AND WHAT'S
APPROPRIATE.
WE CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN ITS JUST
NOT THE WAY TO GET THERE AND
IT'S NOT SPECIFIC TO EVERY
PATIENT. THAT. THEY DON'T ALWAYS
HAVE ACCESS TO BE ABLE TO CALL
THEIR POSITION AND. YOU KNOW I
FIVE DAYS AND SAY CAN MAKE MEN
THIS ISN'T WORKING FOR ME I
THINK IN AN IDEAL SITUATION THAT
WOULD BE GREAT BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT EVERY PATIENT HAS THAT WITH
THEIR PHYSICIAN. AND SO. IT'S
THOSE KINDS OF SITUATIONS WHERE.
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T DETERMINE
EVERYTHING THAT IS GOING TO
FOLLOW PATIENTS AND WE CAN'T
JUST SAY THAT.
THE BEST KNOW BEST CASE SCENARIO
LIKE THAT. IS THE WAY TO TREAT
IT BECAUSE THERE WILL BE
PATIENTS THAT WILL DEFINITELY
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IF
I END AND YOU GUYS ARE DIFFICULT
POSITIONS BECAUSE WE PLATFORM SO
THAT.
WHERE DOCTORS?
YOU KNOW. TOLD THE AUDIENCE THAT
IN THE NINETIES WE WERE MANDATED
TO TREAT PAIN AND IF WE DON'T
TREAT PAYING WE WILL GET A BAD
RECOMMENDATION FROM PATIENTS.
AND.
SO I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE WORKING
ON IT MY OWN PERSONAL SITUATION
WAS.
BUT MY DAUGHTER FELL OFF BARS AT
GYMNASTICS FRACTURED A WILL HAVE
A SCOOP PUT AN A CHOCK. AND WHEN
SHE WOKE UP SHALL DISCOMFORT YOU
KNOW WE'RE THINKING CHILDREN'S
TYLENOL THE ONLY THING A NURSE
COULD GIVE HER AN EIGHT YEAR OLD
MORPHINE.
AND UP SO OBVIOUSLY WE TURNED
THAT DOWN.
THAT MORPHINE IS SOMETHING YOU
GET FAR HOSPICE PATIENTS AND.
DYING SOLDIERS ON THE
BATTLEFIELD SO I THOUGHT THAT
WAS A LITTLE.
AND I'D NEVER RESEARCH IT TO
FIND OUT IF THAT WAS AN
INSURANCE STEAL OUR OR. OR WHAT
BUT IT'S A SINGLE LITTLE
EXCESSIVE TO ME BUT.
IF YOU SEE THE BILLS ARE COMING
UP TODAY THE CURSED AT A PACE
CROSS CITY LINES THE DATABASES
ONE IS PERHAPS TRYING TO DO WHAT
MR GALLAGHER STRANDED.
.
THERE'S A LOT THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS WE NEED TO WORK ON AND.
SO. THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF MY
THOUGHTS.
ON ANY OTHER MEMBERS MISSION
SPEAK SING NON RECIPROCAL ELECT
CLOSE.
YES AND I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I I DON'T THINK THE CONCEPT OF
PRESCRIPTION LIMITS LATELY
HOWEVER I BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME
CRIMES REQUIRE SAFETY AND
EXCEPTIONAL LEGISLATIVE
RESPONSE.
I THINK TO SAY THAT FIVE DAYS
CREATES LIABILITIES FOR DOCTORS.
IT.
AND QUITE FRANKLY IT'S A COP OUT
LOCK SOMEONE HAS TO BE
RESPONSIBLE WHEN THEY PRESCRIBE
A CHILD AN OPIOID.
AND IT IS MY AND PEOPLE TRUST
LIKE VALERIE SAID SHE TRUSTED
HER DOCTOR AND NOW PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NEED TO
TRUST US.
WE DON'T HAVE THE LUXURY TO WAIT
TEN YEARS FOR A PROCESS THAT FOR
FOR DOCTORS TO CATCH UP. WE'VE
WAITED LONG ENOUGH I WANNA THINK
VALERIA MRS KING FOR THEIR TIME
TODAY AND THEY'RE HONEST ON
THEIR HONEST A.
THERE OUGHT THEIR HONEST
TESTIMONY. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN ITEM
THANK YOU BUT WE'RE SO
SUBCOMMITTEE SO WHEN WE BECOME
QUORUM WILL TAKE THAT UP.
NEXT UP WE HAVE FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB TWO FIVE FIVE FIVE
MISTER COOLEY
.
SCHIAVONE KNOW MISTER VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU. PLEASURE TO BE WITH
YOU.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY FIVE
CONCERNING CANNABIS PLANT
TAGGING.
AND I DIFFERENT ONE I THINK.
MISTER FROM JUNE FOR THE
ANALYSIS OF THIS PRESENT TO YOU
TODAY OR.
FOLIO.
.
UNDER THE M. SIERRA SAY AND PROP
SIXTY FOUR NOW COLLECTIVELY
KNOWN AS. THE CURSE OUT.
ALL COMMERCIAL CANNABIS IS
REQUIRED TO BE IN A TRACK AND
TRACE PROGRAM.
THAT FOLLOWS THE PRODUCT FROM
ITS INITIAL CULTIVATION TO ITS
EVENTUAL SALE.
I AS IT IS NOW BEEN.
WORKING ON IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA PART OF FOOD
NEVER CULTURE.
OF PLANTS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO BE
ISSUED A UNIQUE IDENTIFIER OR
PLANT TAG. UNLESS THE PLANT IS
DEEMED MATURE.
WHICH HAVE DEFINED TO ME THE
CANNABIS PLANT THAT IS
FLOWERING.
AS A PRACTICAL MATTER I THINK
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT STARTS
PRESENT ANY SOME COMPLEXITY.
AS YOU START SEEING PLANTS GROWN
A CONSUMABLE SCALE IN LARGE
WAREHOUSE FACILITIES.
TWENTY DEFY WHICH PLANTS ARE
ACTUALLY MATURE FEAR FLOWERING.
INVOLVES A LOT OF.
DILIGENT INSPECTION
IN ORDER TO CHARACTERIZE WHAT'S
IN THAT WAREHOUSE.
AND SORT SHIP SOME BIRD NOT A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
EXPERIENCE OF OTHER STATES IS
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY THE ONLY
SOLUTION AVAILABLE. WE ARE NOT
THE FIRST PERSON TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT FOR STATE FOR THIS
SOUND.
CANNABIS GROW CYCLES CAN BE
NATURAL VIA OUTDOOR SUNLIGHT.
THEY CAN BE MANUFACTURED.
USING MIX SLIDER INDOOR LIGHT
CYCLES.
KEEP PLANTS IN A VEGETATIVE NON
FLOWERING STATE.
A.
WITH THE ABILITY DEMOING DECIDE
IT'S TIME TO GET A PICTURE AND
FLORA YOU CAN SPEED IT UP.
BY STEPS THAT THE GORE WILL
TAKE.
THE AMOUNT OF PLANTS ALLOWED TO
BE CULTIVATED IS CURRENTLY
DEPENDENT ON THE TYPE OF LICENSE
ISSUED THE AMOUNT OF CANOPY
SIZE.
OF EACH LICENSE ISSUED.
ARE.
UNDER THE CURRENT REGULATIONS
ONLY MATURE PLANTS ARE COUNTED
TOWARD THE CANOPY SIZE HE'S FOR
HAVE TO DIFFERENTIATE WHAT'S
FLOUR AND WHAT'S NOT.
THIS CREATES A PROBLEM FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES AS WELL AS LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SORTS A LOGISTICS
ISSUE.
A BECAUSE THEY NEED TO SEEK TO
ENSURE THAT CANNABIS BUSINESS
ARMENIAN ALL THE LEGAL
CULTIVATION ACQUIREMENT.
INCLUDING HAVING
PLANTS PROPERTY TAG OF TO SHOULD
BE PLUGGED UNDER THE TAG OF THE
REGULATION.
AND HAVING THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF
PLANTS WITHIN THE ALLOWED CANOPY
SIZE FOR THE GIVEN LICENSE.
WHEN WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
TO DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
FLOWERING AND NON FAR IMPLANTS
WITHIN A GIVEN FACILITY WHICH
MAY BE. A VERY CONSIDERABLE SIZE
EXPANSE.
YOU CAN'T REALLY SIZE IT UP
THAT READILY.
ARE. WHERE YOU MAY HAVE HUNDREDS
OF PLANTS PER ROOM TIGHTLY PLACE
TOGETHER?
?
IN OTHER STATES SUCH AS COLORADO
WASH IMPLANTS ARE EASILY
IDENTIFIED BY ME AS MATURE
PLANTS BY A HEIGHT REQUIREMENT.
SOMETIMES EIGHT INCHES CAN BE
GOING AS HIGH AS TWENTY FOUR
INCHES.
ARE.
SO THIS BILL PROPOSES TO SHORTER
RE CALIBRATE HOW WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING AND OVERSEEING THIS
GROWING INDUSTRY.
BY USING THE STANDARD OF TAGGING
PLANTS AT A YOUNG AGE.
ALLOWING THEM TO BE ASSESSED
BASED ON THEIR SIZE.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
DO QUICKLY VISUALLY IN A LARGE
FACILITY.
.
AND.
IT DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY BY
CHANGING DEFINITION MATURE
CANNABIS PLANTS TO MEAN ANY
PLANT OVER EIGHT INCHES IN
HEIGHT OR WIDTH.
CENTER FLOWERING.
REQUIRES PLACE WE TAGGED AT AN
EARLIER STAGE
AND EASIER TO UNDERSTAND.
IS YOUR OF IDENTIFY STATE.
DRAGON ACCORSI ANY OF US THAT
THAT.
GO OUT TO THE NURSERY TO BUY
PLANTS OR IT IN NUMBER PLEASE A
CELL PLANTS.
IT'S VERY COMMON NOW TO HAVE
LITTLE TAGS PUT ON ALL MANNER OF
PLANTS IT'S IT.
STANDARD TECHNOLOGY THAT
RECYCLABLE IT DOESN'T DAMAGE THE
PLANT.
IT'S ACTUALLY A BUSINESS RETAIN
IN A LOT OF SETTINGS
BUT HERE WE ARE USING FOR A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSE.
.
AND.
SO I PRESENT THIS BILL TWO YOU
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS MARKET WE DO
NEED TO HAVE RULES.
THAT ALLOW. LAW ENFORCEMENT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO IMPLEMENT
THEM IN A CLEAR AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD MANNER.
I PERSONALLY AM COMMITTED TO
MOVING THE BILL FORWARD.
.
AND JUST REMAIN IN A POSTURE OF
CONVERSATION WITH ALL INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT SORT OF
FEEDBACK WE GET.
.
AND.
BUT I THINK THIS BILL DEFTLY
ADDRESSES AN IMPORTANT NEED.
AND.
I'M PLEASED TO BRING IT TO
TODAY I UNDERSTAND YOU ARE NOT.
A.
SUBCOMMITTEE BOAT. BE DELIGHTED
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
ONLY.
THANK YOU RECYCLING TO HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NON PERHAPS NOT IN THE
ROOM AT THIS TIME SO THERE ARE.
PERSONS IN SUPPORT AND I DO
THINK YOUR PURSES ACTUALLY WHO
HAVE.
SOME CONCERNS.
BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY MY MY
APPROACH WILL BE TO COLLABORATE
WITH EVERYBODY.
TO WORK THROUGH THOSE THINGS I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE AND YOU TO
CONVENE THING CERTAINLY TAKE YOU
ARE NOT AT RISK.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YEAH.
VERY GOOD.
THIS JURY MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF CMG KHALIFA WHICH IS
WHY THE LARGEST VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED CAMP CANVAS
OPERATIONS IN THE STATE BASED IN
SAN JOSE WE DO A LOT OF
CULTIVATION. WE HAVE EXPRESSED
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL ON
A TO THE AUTHOR CERTAINLY TO
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER
THEIR WORKLOAD IN.
I IMPACTS ON US ON CONCERNS
ABOUT THE SIZE OF THE PLANNED
WHETHER IT'S A VIABLE OR NOT AND
WHETHER IT'S FRAGILE AND.
HOWEVER IN RECENT CONVERSATIONS
US IN LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS
WITH MY FOLKS IN SAN JOSE.
WE THINK THAT THERE MAY BE SOME
OPTIONS THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR OF
OTHERS WILLINGNESS TO LOOK AT
ALTERNATIVES LOOK AT OPTIONS
WILL FOR TALKING TO AND WE
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO MOVE
THE BILL FORWARD TODAY. THANK
YOU I THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE. MEMBERS WISHING TO
ASK. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. AS YOU MENTIONED WE
ARE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL TAKE IT UP
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU AND THE
OPPOSITION NOW WORKING THIS OUT
BEFORE BECAUSE APPROPRIATE.
VERY GOOD AND I DO WANT TO SAY
HELLO TO CLOSE I THINK THE WORK
OF THIS COMMITTEE. TAKING THIS
LARGE SUBJECT MATTER AREA AND
DEVELOPING ORANGE TO FLEX
PARTY'S HEARING THAT. BEING P.
COMMITTEE I THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT HAVE THAT.
POLICY EXPERTISE IN ONE
COMMITTEE.
AND I JUST THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORKLOAD. THANK THANK YOU
SCHOOL. WILL TAKE THAT UP AS
VOTE WILL BECOME A QUORUM.
NEXT UP WE'LL HEAR FILE ITEM
EIGHT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY BY SOME
WOMEN WOULD
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE UMPTEENTH
RESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY.
THERE IS A DRUG EPIDEMIC IN
CALIFORNIA PRIMARILY DRIVEN BY
OPIOIDS INCLUDING HEROIN.
ENDLESSLY MADE FENTANYL AND
OTHER HIGH THE HIGH HIGH POTENCY
OF SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE WERE
FORTY SIX HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
OVERDOSE DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA.
NATIONWIDE MORE THAN SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS DIED AS
RESULT OF OVERDOSES YOU OVERDOSE
RATE. EXCEEDS THE PEAK OF DEATHS
DURING THE AIDS CRISIS IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE.
GUN RELATED DEATHS IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE AND CAR CRASH
DEATHS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO.
THE FIGURE ALSO EXCEEDS A NUMBER
OF AMERICAN SOLDIERS WHO DIED
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY IS A BILL
DESIGNED TO DO ONE SIMPLE THING
SAVE LIVES.
THE LOCKS ON HYDROCHLORIDE IS AN
OPIOID ANTAGONIST THAT ACTS
IMMEDIATELY TO REVERSE THE
EFFECTS OF AN OPIOID OVERDOSE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY REQUIRES
HEALTH CARE PRESCRIBERS WHEN
ISSUING AN OPI PRESCRIPTION TWO
IDENTIFIED AT RISK PATIENTS.
CO PRESCRIBED NALOXONE AND
PROVIDE EDUCATION ON ITS PURPOSE
AND HOW TO USE IT.
HOW TO USE IT TO THE PATIENT
AND AND MEMBERS OF THEIR
HOUSEHOLDS?
IT ISN'T OFTEN ONE HAS THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING ABLE TO
DIRECTLY QUOTE THE SURGEON
GENERAL OF THE UNITED STATES.
HOWEVER LAST WEEK IN THE FIRST
NATIONAL ADVISORY ISSUED BY A
SURGEON GENERAL SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE. US ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEROME ADAMS.
ISSUED AN ADVISORY EMPHASIZING
TO THE US ATTORNEY US SURGEON
GENERAL.
DRUM ADAMS ISSUED AN ADVISORY
EMPHASIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE OVERDOSE REVERSING DRUG
NALOXONE.
STATED FOR THAT THAT FOR
PATIENTS CURRENTLY TAKING HIGH
DOSES OF OPIOIDS AS PRESCRIBED
FOR PAIN.
INDIVIDUALS MISUSING OPIOIDS
INDIVIDUALS USING ILLICIT OPIOID
SUCH AS HEROIN OFFEND NO.
HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONERS.
FAMILY AND FRIENDS A FEE OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE AN OP A DECISION
DISORDER AND FOR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO COME INTO CONTACT
WITH PEOPLE AT RISK FOR OPIUM
GOING OVER DOES. KNOWING HOW TO
USE THE LOCKS ON AND KEEPING IT
WITHIN REACH CAN SAVE A LIFE.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION ADVISES HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS TO CONSIDER
OFFERING NALOXONE TO INDIVIDUALS
WHEN FACTORS THAT INCREASE THE
RISK. OF OVERT OF FOR OVER DOES
ARE PRESENT FOR CONCURRENT
BENZODIAZEPINE USE OUR
PRESIDENT.
IN ADDITION TO CDC AT LEAST
ELEVEN OTHER NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS RECOMMEND
INTEGRATING THE LOCKS ON WITH AT
RISK HOPE YOUR PRESCRIPTIONS
INCLUDING THE AMA. THE APHA THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICAID AND MEDICARE SERVICES.
AND THE INDIAN HEALTH SERVICE.
WHILE THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
NOT LAW AND AS SUCH DO NOT CARRY
THE WEIGHT OF LAW AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY WOULD MANDATE
PRESCRIBERS TO FOLLOW A SPECIFIC
PROTOCOL RELATED TO IDENTIFIED
RISK POOLS OF PATIENTS.
A PROTOCOL THAT INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF SURVIVAL.
SHOULD THEY HAVE AN OVERDOSE
EXPERIENCE
HERE WITH ME TODAY AND SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE VA.
I'M NOT SO
SEE OUR.
EVER OUR PURSE FROM THE VA BUT I
DO HAVE.
I GLENN GLENN BACCUS FROM THE
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE'S HERE.
BECAUSE ABOUT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK IS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE.
WE'VE WORKED IN RECENT YEARS
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BLOOM
AVIANO AND MAYES.
ON BILLS TO WIDELY AVAILABILITY
OF NOW LOCKS ON THROUGH
PHARMACIES
THROUGH HARM REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
AND THROUGH CAKE YOU TWELVE
SCHOOLS.
WE'VE WORKED TO WIDEN THE USE OF
NALOXONE BY LINE FOR SATAN SEES
INCLUDING THE VERY SUCCESSFUL
PILOT SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND THE
PROGRAM IN SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY.
NOW LOCKS ON WAS FIRST APPROVED
BY THE FDA IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO SORT OF THE FORTY FIVE YEAR.
HISTORY AND TRACK RECORD OF SAFE
ADMINISTRATION IT'S WELL
ESTABLISHED THAT LAY PERSONS
SPOUSES OF A PATIENT FOR
EXAMPLE.
GOOD SUCCESSFULLY REVERSE AN
OVERDOSE AND SAVE THE LIFE OF A
PATIENT.
WE NEED THE ANTIDOTE TO OPIOID
OVERDOSE.
IT IS MANY PLACES AS WE CAN GET
IT.
WHEREVER AND WHENEVER PEOPLE ARE
USING OPIOIDS BE THEY HEROIN OR
PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS.
OR A PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS IN
COMBINATION WITH OTHER
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS LIKE
BENZODIAZEPINES OR WITH ALCOHOL.
IF THIS BILL IS NOT ONLY A
LOGICAL STEP A LOGICAL EXPANSION
CONSISTENT WITH THE SURGEON
GENERAL'S RECOMMENDATION.
IT'S AN URGENTLY NEEDED STEP TO
SAVE LIVES STARTING TODAY.
MY GUESS STARTING JANUARY ONE.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TOM RENT FREE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. AYE
ANYTHING THAT WOULD CAN INCREASE
ACCESS TO THIS LIFESAVING
MEDICATION THE LOCKS ON IS A
GOOD THING SO WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THE SHOCK EVENTS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MR JOHNSON TO BE HALF A
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE SHOWING DECISION
SUPPORT SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO
ASK QUESTIONS OR MAKE COMMENTS.
SEEING NOT. STUART TRULY CLOSE
ADJUSTER.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY WOULD BE
ONE STEP TOWARDS INCREASING THE
SURVIVAL RATE OF INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING AN OVERDOSE IT'S US
IT'S SIMPLE IT WORKS IT SAVES
LIVES ASK YOUR AYE VOTE WHEN YOU
HAVE A. FULL COMMITTEE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING OUT OF
FOUR THANK YOU MENTIONED WE ARE
SUBCOMMITTEE STILL WILL BRING
THIS UP FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GIVE A
SECOND ITEM I DO THINK. ITEM
NINE AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M PLEASE PRESENT AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
REQUIRES THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY
ALL PRESCRIBERS AND DISPENSERS
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO CREATE
PRESCRIPTIONS ELECTRONICALLY.
KNOWN AS E. PRESCRIBING AND THAT
BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE E.
PRESCRIBING FOR MOST MEDICATIONS
WOULD BE REQUIRED. THE RATIONALE
FOR THIS BILL IS TWO FOLD. FIRST
THE PRESCRIBING IS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL TO ADDRESS THE OPIOID
CRISIS BY REDUCING THE QUANTITY
OF OPIOIDS OBTAIN.
FRAUDULENT MEANS SUCH AS STOLEN
PRESCRIPTION PADS OR ALTERED
PRESCRIPTIONS.
SECOND E. PRESCRIBING WOULD
REDUCE PRESCRIPTION ERRORS AND
INCREASED INCREASED THE QUALITY
OF PATIENT CARE BY REDUCING
MEDICATION OR DOSAGE ERRORS.
MORE THAN ONE POINT THREE
MILLION PEOPLE ARE INJURED BY
MEDICATION ERRORS ANNUALLY IN
THE U. S. AND MOST FAMOUS MOST
THESE MISTAKES ARE PREVENTABLE.
ACCORDING TO A STUDY CONDUCTED
AT JOHN HOPKINS MEDICAID
MEDICATION OUTPATIENT PHARMACY.
EIGHTY NINE PERCENT OF HAND
WRITTEN PRESCRIPTIONS FAILED TO
ME BEST PRACTICE GUIDELINES
ORDER AND OR WERE MISSING EIGHTY
FOR HIM FOR MISSING INFORMATION.
EIGHTY NINE PERCENT.
AND THAT DOESN'T EVEN MENTION
HANDWRITING WHICH I'M TOTALLY
GUILTY.
BY COMPARISON NOT A SINGLE
PRESCRIPTION ISSUED
ELECTRONICALLY IN THAT STUDY AYE
CONTAINED THOSE TYPES OF ERRORS.
DESPITE WHAT YOU MAY HEAR TODAY
E. PRESCRIBING IS NOT A NEW
CONCEPT.
AS FAR BACK AS TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE THE CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES INCLUDED
E. PRESCRIBING IN THE MEDICARE
MODERNIZATION ACT. THEY LAUDED
THE PRESCRIBING AS AS A
PRESCRIBERS ABILITY TO
ELECTRONICALLY SEND AN ACCURATE.
ERROR FREE AND UNDERSTANDABLE
PRESCRIPTION
AND THAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELEMENT IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF
PATIENT CARE.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN ONE
POINT SIX BILLION PRESCRIPTIONS
WITH A BE. WEARING WISH IT WERE
WERE ISSUED ELECTRONICALLY IN
THE UNITED STATES
NINE STATES INCLUDING.
STATES WITH AN INCREASE OF
SEVENTEEN STATES.
INCLUDING STATES WITH LARGE
SIXTIES IN NINE STATES HAVE THIS
OF HAVE THIS.
LARA NOW SEVENTEEN STATES ARE
CONSIDERING IT AND EASIER LARGE
STATES.
LIKE NEW YORK AND SMALLER MORE
RURAL STATES LIKE MAINE IN RHODE
ISLAND.
AND A BILL IS UP IN CONGRESS
THAT WOULD MANDATE THE
PRESCRIBING FOR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES AND MEDICARE PART D..
EAST PRESCRIBED IS NO LONGER A
FUTURE TECHNOLOGY IT EXISTS IT
IS READILY AVAILABLE AND IT'S
TIME HAS COME ELECTRONIC
HEALTHCARE RECORDS AND.
SOFTWARE DEVELOPMENT HAD MADE
THE ADOPTION OF E. PRESCRIBING
THE NORM ADOPTION OF TECHNOLOGY
TO IMPROVE PATIENT OUTCOMES HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A HALLMARK OF THE
HEALTH HEALTH CARE PROFESSION.
ADOPTION OF E. PRESCRIBING IS NO
EXCEPTION
WITH ME TODAY TESTIFY.
IS.
ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL THE
VIRGINIA HEROLD EXECUTIVE
OFFICER THE CALIFORNIA FARM
ABOARD A PHARMACY. WHO ASSISTED
US IN DRAFTING THIS LEGISLATION
AND DOCTOR A REEF CARAMBA
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PHYSICIAN?
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING POP
THE BOARD IS ACTUALLY A VERY
LONG TIME SUPPORTER OF.
EAT PRESCRIBING GOING BACK WE
AMENDED CALIFORNIA LAWN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR TO ALLOW IT WE HAD
TO WAIT ANOTHER FIFTEEN YEARS
FOR THE D. E. TO DEVELOP THEIR
REQUIREMENTS. THAT WE HAVE
FORESEEN THAT ADVENT OF THE
PRESCRIBING AS A WAY FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION FOR QUITE
AWHILE.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE ON.
WAIT THINGS THAT YOU'LL PERSKY
PRESCRIBE IT WILL BENEFIT ANY
OPIOID CRISIS IS PART OF THE
REASON YOU SEE THIS MOMENTUM
FEDERALLY. IS OTHER STATES ARE
SEEING THIS IS A VALUABLE TOOL
TO ADDRESS WHAT THEY'RE SEEING
IN THEIR STATES.
SO ONE OF THE VERY OBVIOUS
THINGS IS THE IMPROVEMENT IN THE
ABILITY TO READ A PRESCRIPTION
AND MAKE IT MORE LEGIBLE.
THAT ALSO OCCURS IN THE PHARMACY
WHEN THEY'RE INPUTTING THE DATA
INTO THE COMPUTER IT WOULD COME
IN E. PRESCRIBING DIRECTLY INTO
THE SYSTEM SO NOT ONLY WITH THE
PRESCRIBER OR MISREAD THE
PRESCRIBERS WRITING. NOT OCCUR
AT THE PHARMACY ITSELF WOULDN'T
ADD ADDITIONAL AIRS WHEN THEY'RE
IN PUTTING THE INFORMATION INTO
THE COMPUTER.
IT WOULD REDUCE PATIENT WAIT
TIME BECAUSE PRESCRIPTION WOULD
ALREADY GO TO THE PHARMACY OF A
PRESCRIBERS CHOICE.
IT WOULD ENABLE FAST RETRIEVAL
OF RECORDS BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS
ALREADY IN THEIR ELECTRONICALLY.
IN A PHARMACY WHERE SPACE IS
VERY COMPACT AND VERY VALUABLE
IT WILL SIMPLIFY THE RECORD
STORAGE WE HAVE RECORD
REQUIREMENTS THAT REQUIRE RECORD
BEING KEPT ON THE PREMISES FOR
THREE YEARS. AND FOR VARIOUS
THINGS SOMETIMES OF ONE SEVEN OR
TEN YEARS AND THAT BECOMES A
REAL STORAGE PROBLEM.
BE ON IT WILL MOST IMPORTANTLY
THOUGH IT WILL SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCE THE ABILITY OF PEOPLE TO
GET A PRESCRIPTION AND MODIFY IT
FOR THEIR OWN GOAL.
SO FOR EXAMPLE I GET A
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
PRESCRIPTION NOW AND I ED A ONE
IN FRONT OF THAT TWENTY AND
SUDDENLY INSTEAD OF TWENTY PILLS
I'M GETTING A HUNDRED TWENTY
HILLS.
AND THAT IS VIRTUALLY
UNDETECTED.
ON ELECTRONIC PRESCRIBING THAT
WOULD GO AWAY.
IT WILL ALSO.
.
STOP SOME OF THE ON DRUG
DIVERSION THAT'S GOING ON IN SAN
DIEGO RECENTLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON WENT AFTER. A.
FRAUDULENT DOCTOR SHOPPER THAT
ENDED UP WITH ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
OXYCONTIN. THAT HE HAD OBTAINED
FROM GOING ONLINE FIND FAULTS
THAT WERE NOT LEGITIMATE AYE ME
THEY FIND OUT THAT WITHIN THE
PRESCRIBER INVOLVING YET HE WAS
STILL ABLE TO WALK OUT WITH ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WITH
THE.
SO THIS WOULD SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
BECAUSE AGAIN THE IDENTITY OF
THE PRESCRIBER IS ASCERTAINED AT
THE TIME THAT THE.
PRESCRIPTION IS BEING IN FACT.
AND THE PHARMACY CAN IDENTIFY IN
CONFIRMED THAT PRESCRIBER THIS.
AS DOCTOR WHAT INDICATED THAT
RIGHT AT THE MOMENT WE'VE GOT
THE SEVENTEEN STATES
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF THEM WHERE
AN E. PRESCRIBING LA IS PENDING.
AND I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE AND ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS.
THIS AND WE'VE BEEN WAITING A
LONG TIME TO ACTUALLY MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
MONNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS A DOCTOR KALRA MARA FROM
THE CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER WHO
WOULDN'T CLINIC OF MEDICAL GROUP
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S
POSITION GROUPS.
AS THE PRESCRIBING PHYSICIAN
AND.
ON BEHALF OF FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY PROVIDERS.
THEIR TWO PILLARS THAT WE DEEM
INCLUDING PORN TO PATIENTS.
.
HEALTHCARE PATIENT SAFETY AND
PATIENT EXPERIENCE.
THE PATIENT SAFETY BE SUFFERED
OF IT IS IS SELF EVIDENT.
WRITING PRESCRIPTIONS ON A
PAPER.
.
THIS IS BEING ABLE TO SECURELY
TRANSMIT THEM TO A PHARMACY.
AND REMOVING AND MINIMIZING THE
RISKS OF ERRORS AND LEGIBILITY
ARE INTRUDING PARKING BUT ALSO
AS A PRESCRIBING PHYSICIAN WHEN
YOU'RE WRITING A PRESCRIPTION
FOR MISSION IN FRONT OF YOU THAT
DAY. YOU ARE TRACK WHAT THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN ON.
AND IF YOU HAVE A LITTLE TRONIC
A BILL TO TRACK THAT IT
MINIMIZES THOSE ARE IS IN TERMS
OF CONSISTENT PRESCRIPTIONS
BETWEEN PAST AND AND AND KERN
PRESCRIPTIONS.
THE PATIENT EXPERIENCE PART OF
IT CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED.
.
AS A PATIENT YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN
I GOING TO SEE MY DOCTOR I DON'T
BE SHUFFLING THE PIECE OF PAPER
BETWEEN MYSELF. OF THE PHYSICIAN
AND THE FUN THE PHARMACY I'D
LIKE TO GET CONVENE HEALTHCARE.
US HE MY POSITION MAKE SURE THE
INFORMATION GETS PROSPECT OF THE
PHARMACY.
SO THAT YOU AS A PATIENT WHEN I
GO TO PICK IT UP ITS READY. AND
OF THIS ANY ISSUES THIS
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN PHARMACY
IN PHYSICIAN HAPPENING IN THE
BACK.
SO THE PATIENT SAFETY AND
PATIENT EXPERIENCE PART OF IT
ARE A HUGE PART OF WHAT WE DO AS
PHYSICIANS. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WOULD SUSPICIONS
BEGINS PORT NAME AND AFFILIATION
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO
AT DAVID GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA'S POSITION GROUPS
REPRESENTING PROVIDERS IN OVER
THREE HER MEDICAL GROUPS ACROSS
FORTY FOUR STATES. HAVE A BEER
IN SUPPORT.
BOB SHARON WE HAVE AGES
TREATMENT CENTERS WE'D LIKE TO
THANK DR WOOD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN THE ISSUE OF OPIOID ADDICTION
AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL
WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
CHRISTINE SCHULTZ REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION THANKING THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING AMENDMENTS TO EXEMPT
EYEGLASSES AND CONTACT LENS
PRESCRIPTIONS. WE HAVE NO
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE. ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SIMON BAKER AND I PUT APOLOGIZE
AFTER COMING FROM OTHER SPOT
THAT I MAY HAVE MISSED YOUR
ADDRESSES AND JUST AS THE TIME
FRAME AND THE FEASIBILITY. FOR
PHYSICIANS TO MEET THAT AND I
REYES ACTORS HAVE BEEN
CONSTITUENTS MY DISTRICT ARE
PHYSICIANS YOUR IQ THEY IF
EXPLAINED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS THEY PAID INTO
UPGRADING THEIR SOFTWARE
UPGRADING THEIR.
EQUIPMENT TO BE ABLE COMPLY I
JUST WONDER I KNOW THERE WERE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE TIME FRAME
AGAIN.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT YOU ADDRESS
THAT WHEN I WAS OUT BUT AM VERY
INTERESTED IN THAT AND THE
FEASIBILITY FOR IT HAPPENING THE
RECENT LISTAT THE TIME FRAME
NOT THE REASONABLENESS. OF THE
REQUESTED TIME FRAME.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
IMPLEMENTATION BEGINNING TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT'S
THREE YEARS FROM NOW?
A LOT OF ELECTRONIC
MEDICAL RECORD SYSTEMS ACTUALLY
ALLOW THIS CAPABILITY MY
PHYSICIAN DOES THAT NOW CAN.
AND.
WITH SEVEN STATES CURRENTLY ARE
NINE STATES A CURLY HAVE THIS IN
PLACE AND ANOTHER SEVENTEEN THAT
ARE ACTUALLY CONSIDERING IT.
I WOULD VENTURE TO GUESS THAT
THE THE TECHNOLOGY IS THERE AND
AND MORE AND MORE STATES TO COME
ONLINE THE MORE MORE AFFORDABLE
BE IT WILL BE EVEN MORE USER
FRIENDLY IT WILL BE.
IN AYE AYE IN ADDITION.
AT SOME POINT THAT PHYSICIANS
MAY BE ABLE TO DO THIS THROUGH A
NAP OR SOMETHING AS WELL.
OR A SECURE PORTAL BUT YOU KNOW.
I.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OR HOW FEW
I SHOULD SAY PHYSICIANS DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO A COMPUTER.
IN THIS DAY AND AGE UMP THERE
MAY BE ONE OR TWO WERE FEW OUT
THERE AND I'M SENSITIVE TO THAT.
BY.
BUT I THINK IN THE LONG RUN
THIS IS MUCH SAFER.
MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE AND MUCH
BETTER FOR THE CONSUMER GET
THINK YOU FOR ADDRESSING.
THEY DO VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENIOR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE THIS OUT WHEN YOU
HAVE A OF COURSE MADE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN THIS DOES
ENJOY AN AYE RECOMMENDATION
WHEN.
AT THIS. AYE SERVER I WAS REMISS
IN MAKING MY COMMENTS BUT I'D
LIKE TO WISH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD HAVE TO BIRTH UP. ALL. YOU
CAN THINK OF A BETTER PLACE TO
BE ON MY BIRTHDAY.
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO.
IF YOU LIKE TO COME TO MY
COMMITTEE THIS AFTERNOON I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
OKAY NO PLEASE DON'T THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR WOULD.
WILL NOW GO ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TEN WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABALLERO.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
THE MIKE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
AND THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR.
MEMBERS AND SUPPORT THREE
MINUTES FOR MEMBERS IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE AS I'M EVER CABALLERO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN
LOAN MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE
WHICH WOULD INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF STATE SAFE
STORAGE DEVICES IN PHARMACIES.
SO AS TO SECURE DANGEROUS
ADDICTIVE MEDICATIONS AT HOME
AND I BROUGHT.
SOME.
EXAMPLES OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT JUST TO GET AN IDEA OF
WHAT.
WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE AND HOW
THEY CAN BE UTILIZED BY MY
FATHER JUST A SUMMER COVERED
VIEW MIGHT BE JUST PAUSE FOR A
CULTURE?
COMMUNICATE.
CUNNINGHAM.
LOW HERE BRO NEAR ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHIU.
EGGMAN.
FALL.
GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MULLIN TING.
SO VERY MUCH REPEAT.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
LET ME START OFF BY SAYING THAT
I'M GLAD TO TAKE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REGARDING THE SUNSET
DATE AND BROADENING THE
DIFFERENT THE DEFINITION OF
THROUGH THE BILL SAFE STORAGE
PRODUCTS.
THANK YOU.
WE'VE WE'VE HEARD ALL MORNING
ABOUT THE OF HOPE OPIOID AT
EPIDEMIC I DON'T THINK I NEED
THAT KIND OF BELABOR THE POINT
ON ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES
OBVIOUSLY IS THE ACCESS OF
OPIOIDS. TO CHILDREN WHO ARE WHO
ARE JUST CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT'S IN
THAT MODEL IN TEAMS WHO ARE
CURIOUS ABOUT I WONDER WHAT THIS
DRUG WILL BE LIKE AND WHEN WHAT
WHAT WHAT THEY CAN DO WITH IT.
AND WE'VE HEARD ABOUT KILL
PARTY'S ROUTINES GO THROUGH THE
CABINET TAKE OUT PILLS.
SHOP AT A PARTY PUT AMENABLE IN
AND SHARE THEM WITH EACH OTHER
WITHOUT REGARD TO WHAT THEY
REALLY CAN DO AND AND WHAT
THEY'RE. ARE.
THIS.
BILL WOULD SET UP AN OP AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PHARMACISTS.
TALK TO PATIENTS THAT ARE
RECEIVING OP JORDANES ARE
DANGEROUS UP PRESCRIPTIONS AND
PROVIDE AND.
IT THAT THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT
THAT IT BE PURCHASE NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THE YEAH
PHARMACISTS HAVE ALL OF THE
SAMPLES JUST THAT THEY HAVE AT
LEAST ONE KIND OF SAFE DEVICE.
AND THAT THEY HAVE IT ON AND
TALK TO THEIR.
PEOPLE THAT ARE GETTING THE
PRESCRIPTIONS.
.
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS IS TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
DANGER OF OPIOIDS AND TO GIVE
THEM AN OPTION TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP IT SAFE AND AS YOU CAN SEE
THEY'RE. THEY'RE THEY'RE PRETTY.
.
THEY'RE PRETTY HARDY AND IT AT
AT A MINIMUM IF SOMEONE'S GOING
TO TAKE IT AND TRY TO DESTROY IT
OPEN AT THE PARENT WILL
UNDERSTAND THAT SOMEBODY IS IS
I'M MESSING AROUND WITH THEIR
DRUGS. AND THAT THEY NEED TO
TAKE ACTION IMMEDIATELY THAT'S
THE KIND OF OF PREVENTIVE
EDUCATION PROJECT TO THAT WE
WERE HOPING THAT THIS WILL
AFFECT IN OBVIOUSLY.
IT SAID CHILD SAFETY ISSUE. AND
ALL OF THEIR PHARMACIES WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO KEEP.
KEEP AND CARRY THE SAFE STORAGE
PRODUCTS FOR SALE AT THE
PHARMACY.
WITH ME TODAY IS DR RAJESH
DEPARTING. OUT DAY AFTER DAY A
MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF THE
PEDIATRIC EMERGENCY MEDICINE AT
SAN FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE WHATEVER READY.
THERE ARE MANY.
NEVER IS THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
AGAIN MY NAME IS RIGHT STAFF
YOU I'M A PHYSICIAN SPECIALISTS
IN PEDIATRIC EMERGENCY MEDICINE
AND THIS IS A PREP PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO AND MEDICAL DIRECTOR
FOR HAPPY AT YOUR MERCY MEDICINE
AT SIMPSON'S GOOD GENERAL HIGH.
I'M PROVIDING TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIFTY NINE AND SAFE STORAGE
PRODUCTS.
THE REASON BEING IS OF THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC AS WE KNOW.
HAS NOT SPARED CHILDREN.
AS OUTLINED IN A RECENT STUDY IN
THE JOURNAL PEDIATRICS.
WE HAVE SEEN INTENSIVE CARE
ADMISSIONS FOR PEDIATRIC
PATIENTS DOUBLE WITHIN THE PAST
TWELVE YEARS.
AND THOSE ARE TWO GROUPS OF
PEOPLE PREDOMINATELY ITS YOUNG
CHILDREN LESSEN THE AGE OF FOUR
AND TEENS.
KIDS ARE CURIOUS ESPECIALLY
YOUNG CHILDREN YOUNG CHILDREN
FREQUENTLY ARE EXPOSED TO
HARMFUL LIFE THREATENING.
MEDICATION THROUGH IMPROPER
STORAGE.
DESPITE BEST EFFORTS OF THE
SUBSTANCE ISN'T LOCKED UP IS A
PRETTY GOOD CHANCE IT'LL FIND
ITS WAY INTO THE HANDS RESOURCES
CHILD'S.
AND ADOLESCENCE ADOLESCENTS ARE
RELENTLESS.
ACCESS OPIOIDS INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THEY WILL BE
USED FOR RECREATION OR USED BY
TEEN IN ATTEMPT
OR SELF HARM.
OKAY WHICH ARE IMPORTANT CLASS
OF MEDICATIONS ARE USEFUL WHEN
OTHER MEDICATIONS HAVE FAILED TO
PROVIDE PAIN RELIEF ESPECIALLY
IN CHRONIC AND TERMINAL
CONDITIONS.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE THESE
MEDICATIONS ARE LIFE THREATENING
ESPECIALLY TO THE YOUNG CHILD.
THEN CALL THE SUDDEN DROP IN
BLOOD PRESSURE. BECAUSE IT'S
HARD TO STOP BREATHING AND CAN
LEAD TO DEATH EVEN IN SMALL
DOSES.
I'VE CARED FOR NUMEROUS CHILDREN
WHO'VE EITHER ACCIDENTALLY OR
INTENSELY BEEN EXPOSED TO THESE
MEDICATIONS
AND IN JUST ABOUT EVERY CASE THE
MEDICATIONS WERE IN THE
HOUSEHOLD AND HAD NOT BEEN
LOCKED OUT.
WE'RE OVER OPIOIDSARE NOT THE
ONLY CLASS OF MEDICATIONS THAT
NEED TO BE SAFELY STORED.
THERE'S A WHOLE LISTA
MEDICATIONS UP ALL THE DUBIOUS
LIST KNOWN AS ONE PILL CAN KILL.
COMMON BLOOD PRESSURE
MEDICATIONS PAIN MEDICATIONS AND
DIABETES MEDICATIONS CAN BE
LETHAL WHICH JUST A SINGLE DOSE.
KEY MEDICATIONS ARE LOCKED VICE
IS THE ONLY WAY TO ENSURE THAT A
YOUNG CHILD OR CURIOUS TEAM IS
NOT GOING TO BECOME EXPOSED TO
DANGEROUS MEDICATION.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE LAST
FAMILIES HAVE EASIER ACCESS TO
SUCH LOCKING DEVICES AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF INFLATION IF YOU WISH
TO DO SO.
YEAH JOHN WINGER ACTUALLY A
PINCH HITTING FOR CULT PEOPLE
THAT COULDN'T BE HERE SOME OF
VOIGTS MY SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR CHILDREN SEE
EIGHTEEN HEALTH. AS WELL AS
CORPS MEDICAL CLINIC.
KIM BOX WITH GATEKEEPER
INNOVATION AND SUPPORT.
RAND MORE NUMBER HAVE THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEEM NONE ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEEN NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
SOMEONE BAKER THANK YOU M.
STRICTLY LIMIT WITH THIS BILL
BECAUSE I WANNA MAKE SURE
THERE'S. FLEXIBILITY.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE MANY. OTHER
ITEMS THAT WE WOULD WANNA SECURE
AWAY FROM KIDS IN THE HOUSEHOLD
LIKE CLEANING PRODUCTS AND AND
OTHER POINTS SO. I WE DON'T
ALWAYS.
FOR SAY A RETAILER WHICH IS WHAT
THE PHARMACIST WOULD BE IT IN
THIS ROLE TO HAVE A EITHER
SPECIFIC DEVICE FOR SENATE
DEVICES FOR THINGS WE THINK THAT
OUR. OF DANGER AND TO
TWO KIDS SO I'D.
WONDERING. WHY YOUR HEY THAT
FRONTLINE HIM TO THE RETAILER
LINE WHAT FLEXIBILITY AS IT HAVE
FOR THE PHARMACIST WHO IS
FINDING THESE THINGS ARE MOVING
OFF THE SHELVES NOBODY'S?
LOOKING AT IT.
BECAUSE IT FLEXIBILITY IS
IMPORTANT ON THE SIDE OF COUPLE
OTHER FOUGHT QUESTIONS ON THAT
AS WELL.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
TYPE GUY APPRECIATED.
THE THIS HAS A SENSEI SUNSET SO
WE WILL KNOW WHETHER IT'S IT'S
HAVING SOME EFFICACY. UP BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE PHARMACIST
DOESN'T HAVE TO HAVE A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT MODELS.
THEY JUST HAVE TO HAVE AT LEAST
ONE TO BE ABLE TO SHOW PEOPLE
AND TO SAY HERE IS A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP YOUR DRUGS SAFE.
AND I THINK THE DISTINCTION IS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A WE DON'T
HAVE AN EPIDEMIC OF SOME OF
THESE OTHER CLEANING SUPPLIES NO
QUESTION THAT THEY'RE DANGEROUS
AND AND MANY OF THEM HAVE.
CHILDPROOF CAPS THIS ONE IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE SOPHISTICATED
BECAUSE TEENAGERS ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE LIKELY TO. TO DRINK THE
CLEANERS.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING TEENAGERS CAN
GET INTO AS WELL OR IF THEY GET
INTO IT THEN THE PARENTS AWARE
OF THE FACT THAT THERE'S SOME OF
THAT THAT THEIR. PRODUCT HAS
BEEN.
AT. TAKEN IN SOME WAY SO THE
IDEA AND IN REALLY WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS AND IT'S AN
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY AND AND
WE HAVEN'T. TOLD THE PHARMACISTS
HOW THEY HAVE TO. MARKET THIS
I'M JUST THAT IT'S AVAILABLE
OKAY AND.
EMMERT WE'RE TRYING TO GET AS
MUCH FLEXIBILITY AS.
SCRATCH VERY HELPFUL AND I ALSO
HAVE A QUESTION AS TO THE
PENALTY.
FOR THE PHARMACIST WHO MAY HAVE
FAIL FOR WHATEVER REASON OF
ITEMS TAKE OFF THE SHELF AND
THEY HAVEN'T QUITE HAD CHANCE TO
RESTOCK WHATEVER WHATEVER IT IS.
AND IF I READ THE BILL QUICKLY
THE.
PHARMACISTS BOARD IS THE ONE
THAT CAN.
IMPOSE A FINE.
AND.
AND IS THERE ANY SORT OF
PROVISIONS YOUR CONCERN MAKES
THAT'S NOT GOING TO TAKE AWAY
FROM THEIR ABILITY TO BE A
PHARMACIST YES. OKAY YES
ACTUALLY THEY CAN ACQUIT IMPOSE
A FINE IN THE CAN WAIVE THAT IF
THEY IF THEY IF THEY FEEL LIKE.
IT'S AN AND MINIMAL.
VIOLATION.
THAT'S IN TO GIVE THEM THE
FLEXIBILITY
WE ALSO WANT THEM TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES WITHOUT
IMPAIRING THEIR ABILITY TO BE
LICENSE ABSOLUTELY NUTS AND I
APPRECIATE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ALSO BRING US IN A SENSE THAT
HIS HAVING TO BE OPEN ENDED LIKE
THIS WOULD BE. VERY PROBLEMATIC
NEED TO RE EXAMINE IT SO THANK
YOU FOR DOING THAT THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BY SOMEONE
BAKER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SHE KNOWN DISH RELATIONS WHERE.
IF IT RAISES THE AWARENESS
WHERE.
OPEN HOUSES PEOPLE ARE ARE
SHOWING UP AND GOING TO THE
MEDICINE CABINETS.
UNBELIEVABLE BUT IT REALLY KIND
OF.
I THINK I IDENTIFIES THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF HAVING THOSE
PRESCRIPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR
ANYBODY THAT MIGHT WANT TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK IN THE MEDICINE
CABINET THIS IS ONE OF THE
SOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS SOMEONE
CAREER I APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
YOU IN YOUR OFFICE AS WELL ON
THE LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS OF SOME
OF THE BALANCING APPROACHES TO
IT. AND THEN ALSO RESPECTING OF
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT AND
DESIRE SO I APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE
HAD THANK YOU SO MUCH I THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND.
NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS COMMITTEE SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTION AS YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS LOW
AYE AYE LOW AYE PEROT.
BROWN NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
GEN NOT VOTING CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING EGGMAN.
FONG.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN TING.
BELIEVED ROLE OF IN FACT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SOMEONE UP. WILL NOW GO INTO.
EIGHT AGAIN FILE ORDER SEEING
AND THE PRESENCE OF ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS WHO ARE NOT ON THIS
COMMITTEE WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN WHICH IS AB. NINETEEN
NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON.
AND AGAIN THIS COMMITTEE ILL
ALLOW UP TO THREE MINUTES FOR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AND THREE
MINUTES IN.
OPPOSITION MUCH AVAIL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON. OF THIS
HAPPEN IT DOES ENJOY AND.
I I.
WITH IMMENSE.
PLEASE PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
SECONDHAND DEALERS ARE AT A HUGE
DISADVANTAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
SELLING ITEMS.
THEY HAVE PURCHASED.
FROM INDIVIDUALS FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN INDIVIDUAL WALK INTO A PAWN
SHOP A JEWELRY STORE OR A
BUSINESS TO THAT BUYS.
FROM A PRIVATE CITIZEN THEY
MUST HOLD THE ITEMS OR ITEMS FOR
THIRTY DAYS BEFORE PUTTING THEM
UP FOR SALE. MEANWHILE ONLINE
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF WEBSITES
WHERE YOU CAN EASILY BUY
SECONDHAND GOODS THE SAME DAY.
THIS WHOLE.
IS PUTTING AT SECONDHAND DEALERS
AT A TREMENDOUS DISADVANTAGE
WHEN RESELLING OF THESE ITEMS OF
THAT THEY COULD HAVE OTHERWISE
I'M TURNED AROUND THE SAME DAY
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN NINETY
THREE.
.
THE ARMS
SEEKS TO CREATE AYE LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD FOR SECONDHAND
DEALERS IN THIS SPACE FOR
RESELLING PRODUCTS I WOULD LIKE
TO ADD.
THAT I WOULD BE TAKING ON THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO EXTEND
A THREE DAY HOLDING PERIOD TO A
FIVE DAY WITH.
CONSUMER INFORMATION
COLLECTIONS TWO DAYS AFTER THE
WHOLE IS LIFTED I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
CONSULTANT FOR WORKING WITH US
TO MAKE THIS BILL.
BETTER AYE WITH ME HERE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES
MISTER BILL DUPLICITY WHICH
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
PAWNBROKER ASSOCIATION WHO WILL
INTRODUCE.
ANOTHER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SOMEONE WE GIPSON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS BILL
DUPLESSIS REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
PALM BROKERS ASSOCIATION.
WOULD BEEN WORKING SINCE LAST
AUGUST TO TRY AND REACH AN
EQUITABLE.
AGREEMENT WITH OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS TO.
SOMEWHAT OFFSET THE TREMENDOUS
DISADVANTAGE THAT BRICK AND
MORTAR SECONDHAND DEALERS SUFFER
IN CALIFORNIA.
COMPARED TO THOSE WHO NOW CAN
SELL THROUGH EITHER E. COMMERCE
OR M. COMMERCE.
.
THE ED IDENTICAL ITEMS THAT WE
SELL.
THIS COMMITTEE MAY REMEMBER
THAT THE BURDEN IS PUT ON ON.
SECONDHAND DEALERS BRICK AND
MORTAR STORES.
OF NUMBER ONE HOLDING THE ITEM
FOR THIRTY DAYS REPORTING IT TO
THE CAPS SYSTEM I DON'T THINK
ANY OF THE MEMBERS CURRENTLY
SERVING WILL REMEMBER IN.
WE DID A LA VERY SIGNIFICANT
BILL IN TWO THOUSAND AND.
TWELVE WHICH CREATED A VERY
LARGE LAW ENFORCEMENT DATABASE
PAID FOR BY THE SECONDHAND
DEALERS.
TO RECORD.
INFORMATION THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
HAVE HAVING TO BE PROCESSED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT NOW OUR
FOLKS DO IT AND PAY FOR THE
SYSTEM. AND WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HAS THAT INFORMATION AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
SPECIFICALLY THE M. COMMERCE
AND AND ACTUALLY MY MY OF MY
PAWNBROKER WITNESS HERE NEXT TO
ME IS GOING TO.
GO A LITTLE BIT MORE DEEPLY INTO
THAT BUT THAT'S TRULY WHAT
KILLING OUR INDUSTRY WOULD
WEAKEN THAT WE CAN TOLERATE SOME
OF THE OTHER. PLATFORMS
COMPETITION BUT. THE EASE WITH
WHICH ANYONE CAN.
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF AN ITEM
ALMOST INSTANTANEOUSLY ON THEIR
CELL PHONE IS REALLY TAKING A OF
OUR ENTIRE RETAIL SECTION OF OUR
BUSINESSES AND.
AND ESSENTIALLY GIVING IT UP SO
WE TRIED VERY HARD TO WORK THIS
BILL.
WAS ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED WITH
AT COMPLETELY ELIMINATING THE
WHOLE.
WE THEN IN HOPES OF GAINING
NEUTRALITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE.
APPS THAT HAVE BECOME A THREE
DAY HOLD NOW WE'RE ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
.
NOT JOYFULLY EXACTLY BUT WE ARE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MAKE IT A FIVE DAY HOLD. PLUS
FOR THOSE ITEM SOLD BETWEEN THE
FIFTH DAY IN THE SEVENTH DAY OF
OF.
AT AFTER ACQUISITION WE WILL
GATHER BUYER INFORMATION VERY
SIGNIFICANT IN THAT WE WOULD BE
THE ONLY RETAIL MODEL AND THAT
AT LEAST MY KNOWLEDGE. THE ONLY
RETAIL MODEL IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE TO COLLETTI
RIDERS TO THE MACY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ABOUT BRAND LET ME
INTRODUCE.
JAN SCHNEIDER FROM SAN JOSE.
WHO IS A LICENSED A SECONDHAND
DEALERS?
MY NAME IS JAN SCHNEIDER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE IONE TOO SOON
TO BE ONE PAWN SHOPS IN SAN JOSE
ALONG WITH MY FAMILY.
WE WILL BE CLOSING ONE FOR A LOT
OF REASONS BUT MOSTLY BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE OUT TO
BECAUSE OUR BUSINESSES IT'S
CONSIDERABLY DOWN. ON THE RETAIL
SIDE I DID BRING WITH ME TODAY
MY PERSONAL SHOPPER.
MY CELLPHONE.
ON THIS I JUST UPLOADED LAST
NIGHT BECAUSE THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING I DO I'M NOT A
MILLENNIAL OBVIOUSLY. BUT.
I UPLOADED A FIVE MILE. AND
OFFER UP THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
APPS NOW WITH PEOPLE POSTING
ITEMS FOR SALE. THE FIRST
LISTING I BROUGHT UP LAST NIGHT
AT HOME ONE NIGHT WHEN I
UPLOADED THIS WAS ON A LISTING
THAT WAS FOR A FLAT SCREEN TV.
THE GUY ALSO YOU CAN YOU CAN GO
TO OUR.
SELLER'S OTHER ITEMS HE HAD SIX
MORE TV'S FOR SALE THEY WERE
DISPLAYED ALONG THE FENCE ON THE
SIDEWALK. AND THE FIRST BIG BIG
ALL IN CAPS ON HIS SITE WAS.
CASH ONLY NO SALES TAX I THOUGHT
GREAT THIS IS WHAT WE'RE UP
AGAINST.
MY CUSTOMERS IN MY BRICK AND
MORTAR STORE HAVE TO.
GET UP GET DRESSED GET IN THEIR
CAR DRIVE DOWN PARK WALK INTO MY
STORE AND BUY AN ITEM THAT IF IT
IS A PRE OWNED ITEM HAS BEEN
REPORTED TO THE STATE DATABASE
HAS BEEN HELD FOR THIRTY DAYS
AND THEN I'M ALLOWED TO PUT IT
OUT FOR SALE.
THEY CAN GO ON THEIR PHONE AND
BY LIKE ITEMS THAT GOD KNOWS
WHERE THESE PEOPLE GOT THEM THAT
ARE LISTING THEM I'M NOT SAYING
THEY'RE ALL STOLEN BUT. I'M SURE
A GOOD NUMBER NONE OF THEM OF
BEEN REPORTED THAT'S FOR SURE
NONE OF THEM HAVE BEEN REPORTED.
IT'S A YEAR EACH DISADVANTAGE
FOR US WITH THE CAPS DATABASE
NOW WERE REPORTING WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS OF ACT WAS FISHIN BY
LAW. WE ARE.
MOST LIKELY TO OUR KNOWLEDGE AT
LEAST.
.
THERE'S PROBABLY ONLY ANOTHER
TEN PERCENT OF RETAILERS
SECONDHAND DEALERS IN THE STATE
THAT ARE REPORTING THE PAWN
INDUSTRY WE ARE ALL REPORTING I
WOULD VENTURE TO SAY TO YOU
MISTER SNYDER. THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO.
CRAWLED RETIN SICK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COIN AND BULLION
MERCHANTS ASSOCIATION WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE AMENDED BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH AN
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
SEEN NONE NOW WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE COME
AT THE MICROPHONES OF WE
EXCEEDED PREVIOUSLY I ON THE
SUPPORT FOR OVER THREE MISSILE A
GRADUAL THAT BIT MORE
FLEXIBILITY BUT PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION FOR
THE RECORD IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
I MISSED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH FROM
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
WE APPRECIATE OPTING TO WORK
LIKE THAT AUTHOR HIS STAFF AND
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL ON.
WHILE WE EMPHASIZED THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY UPON OP
BROKER INDUSTRIES CONFRONTING
AND SHE'S THERE'S DIGITAL MARKET
AT.
I SPEAKING PLAINLY THIS.
WILL NOT.
HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
ASSISTING VICTIMS WHO HAVE TO
PROPERTY STOLEN. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THE CURRENT AT THIRTY DAY.
COLD PERIOD IS WORKING WELL FOR
US AMBER OUT FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK OPPOSE THAT
MEASURE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
TYPE CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
DEVELOPMENT CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION I WOULD
UNDERSTAND THE THE ISSUE THAT
WAS RAISED AND WE.
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR THE STAFF
AND THE SPONSORS AND WORKING
WITH US.
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS TO TRY
AND FIND A COMPROMISE HERE. AYE
WE DID MAKE AN OFFER OF A TEN
DAY HOLD WITH TWENTY ADDITIONAL
DAYS OF.
RECORDING BUYER INFORMATION.
DOT THAT WAS A.
SO A GESTURE.
AND TRY TO WORK TOWARDS A
COMPROMISE THEIR UNFORTUNATE.
THAT TIME ONE I WAS GIVEN.
AND SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE
WAS ENOUGH TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION BUT WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT CHESTER MOVING.
I'D CLOSER TOWARDS.
ULTIMATE AGREEMENT.
IT'S STILL ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BAKER THINKING I
I AM JUST FOR THE OPPOSITION TO
SAY I'M CERTAINLY OUR STATE
CONCERNS BUT IT TWO POINTS THE
FIRST IS.
.
I MAY SEEM LIKE YOU WOULD WANT
WE WANT TO MAKE THIS AS
ACCESSIBLE AS POSSIBLE SO THAT
YOU'RE DRY PEOPLE ARE DRIVEN TO
GO TO THE PLACES THAT ARE MOST
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW. TO
HELP YOU DO YOUR JOB MA'AM I'M
COMPLETELY FOR MAKING SURE WE'RE
NOT PUTTING UP BARRIERS TO YOUR
ABILITY TO FIND FOLKS WHO ARE.
STEALING THINGS AND RESELLING
THEM
BUT BY BY NOT HAVING THIS AND
KEEPING THE EXISTING LAW WE ARE
ACTUALLY I THINK DRIVING PEOPLE
TO.
THE LEAST COMPLIANCE A OPTIONS
POSSIBLE SO I WONDER IF YOU CAN
ADDRESS THE ISSUE FOR HOW FOLKS
WHO WERE. IN VERY HIGH
COMPLIANCE LEVEL OR FROM WHAT I
SEE WORKING WITH YOU AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE IF WE DON'T CHANGE US
HOW WERE HOW WERE IMPROVING THE
SITUATION INSTEAD OF DRIVING
PEOPLE TO THE. THE PLACE YOU
DON'T WANT THEM TO GET.
YOU KNOW WE DID SYMPATHIZE WITH
THAT THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED
WHICH IS WHY WE MADE AN OFFER.
.
WHICH IS LESS THAN THE THIRTY
DAY NO CELL HOLD RIGHT NOW TEN
DAYS ATTEND IS WHAT WE THOUGHT
WAS REASONABLE FOR. BOTH THE
PUBLIC TO FIRST REALIZE THAT
THEY'VE BEEN STE.
ROB AND WHAT THEY'VE.
IDENTIFY WHAT HAS BEEN STOLEN
REPORTED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE DON'T
CHECK.
YOU KNOW WE WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
TIMELINE OF ALL THAT TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE PROPERTY AND UNITS
IN.
THEIR WORKLOAD AND AND REALIZING
WHAT.
WOULD HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF
THE.
.
THE BURDENS ON THE INDUSTRY BUT
ALSO ALLOW US TO DO OUR JOB AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
TOWARDS
AND WE JUST RAN OUT OF TIME FOR.
IS THE AUTHOR. ARE YOU
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS TO SEE
WHAT YOU CAN DO WE WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH.
WITH THE OPPOSING SIDE
REGARDING THIS MATTER I WANT TO
ALSO BRING OUT ARE YOU FINISHED
I DON'T WANT IT AND DON'T ASK
MORE QUESTIONS AND I NEED TO
THANK YOU. I WANT TO BRING OUT
THAT THESE ARE. DISSOCIATION IS
WORKING AND PLAYING BY THE RULES
AT WAS ARTICULATED FEW MOMENTS
AGO.
BY ONE OF MY WITNESSES THERE'S
A HUMOR EMERGING INDUSTRY THAT
YOU CAN GO ONLINE AND PURCHASE
ITEMS THAT YOU THINK ARE
LEGITIMATE AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY
STOLEN. THIS INDUSTRY IS
REGULATING THEMSELVES THIS
INDUSTRY IS WORKING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
SOMEONE IN FACT OF REPORTS THEIR
ITEM STOLEN COMES ON THAT LIST
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT SHOPPING
GO TO GO TO. ON THE WEBSITE YOU
DON'T KNOW THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DISCONTENT
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
A SIMILAR GIPSON TO WISH TO
CLOSE OUR RESPECT LASSEN AYE
VOTE.
ONE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT YOUR CONTINUED
EFFORTS IN TRYING TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD.
THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION IS
THEIR SECOND.
SECOND MOTION SECOND.
CONSIDER PLEASE COLORFUL.
ACTIONS DEPOSIT AMENDED LOW AYE
LOW AYE BRO.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
IF YOU'RE NOT VOTING.
BAKER PERSONS BLOOM.
WHEN I CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
FONG.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
I BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL.
ADD ONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEY KEEP.
I WILL GO BACK TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN BY
A SEMI MCCARTY.
AGAIN WE WILL ALLOW UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOR.
WHEN ASSISTANCE BEGIN SUPPORT
THREE MINUTES IS
THE THREE MINUTES FOR WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU THINK IS MY FIRST TIME
TO THE BNP COMMIT.
WELL WRITTEN WE HOPE THAT IT
WON'T BE YOUR LAST OKAY.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I THINK YOU
FOR A CALMING ME I WAS CHAIRING
A COMMITTEE IF THERE ISN'T IN
THE AND BUDGET.
WORLD.
AND.
I'M SORRY I MISSED THE SPECIAL
ORDER TALKING ABOUT THE OPIATE
EPIDEMIC AND HOW CALIFORNIANS
KID AND WORK TOGETHER. TO
ADDRESS THIS I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT A BIPARTISAN BILL AYE
WITH US TODAY AND FIRST I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE ON THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING. WITH US AND HAPPY
DO EXCEPT THE.
THE AMENDMENTS
PROVIDING THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
AND THE ISSUE BEFORE US TODAY IS
REGARDING.
TREATMENT WE KNOW THERE ARE
PROMISING TREATMENTS OUT THERE
DEALING WITH THAT. HOPE GOOD
EPIDEMIC MEDICAL MEDICAL
ASSISTED TREATMENT WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR ABOUT THEM IN A FEW
SECONDS FOR SOME. PRACTITIONERS
HERE LOCALLY. AND OUT ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS UNFORTUNATELY IS THAT
SOME PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
PRESCRIBE. THESE.
THE THESE TREATMENTS ARE ABLE
TO DO SO BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE NECESSARY.
TRAINING THERE IS OF COURSE
THAT A FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
THIS X. WAIVER TRAINING AND NOT
ALL PHYSICIANS HAVE HAVE THE.
LICENSING TO TO DO THIS AND I
LEARNED THIS FIRST HAND LAST
YEAR I WENT TO GO TALK TO SOME
LOCAL E. R. DOCKS AND THEY SAID.
IF SOMEBODY CAME IN THE E. R..
WITHOUT LET'S SAY A BROKEN FOOT.
THEY COULD LEAVE THAT DAY WITH
THIRTY PILLS OF OXY COTTON TO
DEAL WITH THEIR PAIN.
AND THAT POTENTIALLY YOU KNOW.
THE GO WRONG DOWN THE ROAD AT
SOME ACUMEN OUR LATER AND SAYS
I'M A HEROIN ADDICTS I'M
ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS I LIKE TO
GET ON MEDICALLY. ASSISTED
TREATMENT SUCH AS PEOPLE NOW
FRIEND THAT SAME DOCTOR IS NOT
ABLE TO PRESCRIBE THE MEDICATION
TO GET OFF OF THE OPIOID AND SO.
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN RESTRICTIONS ON HOW MANY
AT PATIENTS EACH DOCTOR.
COULD COULD TRAIN BUT BUT ALSO
THERE IS THE ISSUE THAT PEOPLE
WHO GET THEIR MEDICAL LICENSE
AND THOSE IN THE FIELD RIGHT
NOW.
I DON'T HAVE THE TRAINING AND
DON'T HAVE A CERTIFICATE TO
ALLOW THEM TO PRESCRIBE.
DRUGS LIKE DEEP AFRIN AND WE
KNOW THAT THE FIRST LINK THE
FIRST ITERATION OF THE BILL WAS
MORE BRIDES AND WE HAD SOME
OPPOSITION FROM.
THE CMA AND OTHERS WE THINK
WITH A COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
FOCUSING ON JUST THOSE WHO GET
THEIR DE A LICENSE. NARROWS IT
SIGNIFICANTLY AND DEALS WITH THE
ISSUE AT HAND AND FRANKLY WILL
ALLOW US TO PROVIDE.
MORE PHYSICIANS AND MORE
CLINICS THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO
TREAT INDIVIDUALS WITH ADDICTION
IN CALIFORNIA.
AYE WITH ME ARE.
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
TRANSITIONS CLINIC HERE IN
SACRAMENTO DOCTOR NEIL FLYNN AND
MISTER TOM RAN FREE FROM THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
CERTAINLY ASKING RIGHT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ROUTE MR MCCARTY.
I'M A RETIRED INTERNIST
INFECTIOUS DISEASE AND AIDS
PHYSICIAN.
NOT RETIRED.
I HAVE TAKEN UP A TREATMENT OF
OPIOID DEPENDENCE.
WHAT PEOPLE ARE FEELING AND MY
RETIREMENT?
I TREATED PEOPLE LIVING WITH
PAIN AND WERE SO PURE OBJECTION
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
LIKE MANY PHYSICIANS I.
RECEIVED INADEQUATE PAIN THAT.
INADEQUATE EDUCATION IN PAIN
MANAGEMENT.
OUR AND PAIN CONTROL DURING
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
AND RESIDENCY TRAINING AS WELL
AS AND POST GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION.
OUT. RECENTLY THE PARADIGM FOR
TREATMENT OF PAIN WITH OPIOIDS
AND OF OPIOID DEPENDENCE HAS
CHANGED RADICALLY.
CALLING INTO QUESTION OUR OUR
CURRENT METHODS OF DEALING WITH
OPIOID DEPENDENCE.
THERE ARE ALSO.
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
CHRONIC PAIN.
I ESTIMATE.
INTO THOUGH WELL INTO THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS AND
PERHAPS A MILLION.
UP FOR WHOM OPIOID TREATMENT OUT
MAYBE.
APPROPRIATE.
I SCRUTINY BY THE DA AND
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS OF
POSSESSIONS.
WHO PRESCRIBE OPIOIDS HAS
CREATED AN ATMOSPHERE OF FEAR?
AMONG PRESCRIBERS
IN RESPONSE MANY PHYSICIANS HAVE
ABRUPTLY CUT OFF THEIR CHRONIC
PAIN PATIENTS WHO ARE OPIOID
DEPENDENT.
OUT LEAVING THEM WITH NO
RECOURSE BUT TO SEEK THERAPY
LIGHTS ON THE STREET.
I EITHER BY TURNING TO HER ONE
OR BY PURCHASING.
ARE READILY AVAILABLE MEDICAL
OPIOIDS FROM DEALERS.
FINALLY ARE THERE ARE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF HEROIN USERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
CRUCIFIXION CAUSES UNTOLD
MISERY. RESULTS IN A LARGE
PROPORTION OF CRIMINAL CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR.
AND COST CALIFORNIANS BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS EACH YEAR FOR
TREATMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
INCARCERATION.
FEWER THAN ONE IN TEN OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAS ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE.
MANAGEMENT OF OPIOID DEPENDENCE.
AMBITIOUS FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS.
.
LACK OF AVAILABILITY OF PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS WILLING TO OBTAIN
THE DATA TWO THOUSAND WEAVER.
WHICH ALLOWS US TO PRESCRIBE
BUPRENORPHINE EXCELLENT
TREATMENT FOR OPIOID DEPENDENCE.
AND RESTRICTIONS PLACED ON
PRESCRIBERS BY THE D. E. A..
AND FIVE SAMSUNG.
.
CALIFORNIA HAS LEAD TO FIELD
WITH LEGALIZATION DISTRIBUTION
OF NOW WALKS HOME.
FOR THE TREATMENT OF OPIOID.
WE LEAD THE WAY AND IT'S
WORKING.
DATA TO THOUSAND OR THE X.
WAIVER ALLOWS PRIMARY CARE AND
OTHER MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
HE PRESCRIBED PEOPLE OR SEEN
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT.
OUT FOR OPIOID USE DISORDER
WHETHER IT BE HEROIN. OR WHETHER
IT BE MEDICALLY INDUCED.
OPIATE DEPENDENCE SUCH AS I
HAVE CAUSED THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER.
AN INTERESTING ASIDE. EIGHTY
PERCENT OF CHRONIC PAIN PATIENTS
WHO MIGHT HAVE TREATED FOR THEIR
OPIOID USE DISORDER AND THEIR
PAIN WHICH PEOPLE ARE FINE.
.
SAY THAT THEIR PAIN CONTROL IS
BETTER ON PEOPLE ARE FEELING
DOWN ON ANY OTHER OPIOID
REGIMEN.
THEY HAVE BEEN PRESCRIBED IN THE
PAST.
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS ARE NOT
PREPARING THEMSELVES FOR DATA
TWO THOUSAND.
AND THAT'S WHERE THIS BILL COMES
IN THEY WOULD BE MOTIVATED TO DO
SO.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES HAS
BRILLIANTLY AND PRO ACTIVELY.
CREATED A PROGRAM CALLED HUB AND
SPOKE.
BUPRENORPHINE SYSTEM THAT IS
READY AND WAITING TO CARRY OUT
TO HIM IMPLEMENTATION.
OUT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
IN CONCLUSION.
A WORD ABOUT THE OPPOSITION TO
THIS LEGISLATION IT'S LIKELY TO
COME FROM ORGANIZED MEDICINE ARE
PROFESSIONAL SOCIETIES.
WHO WILL CLAIM THAT IT PLACES AN
UNDUE BURDEN ON MEDICAL
PROVIDERS IT WILL COME FROM
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES?
IN SUBTLE AND OBLIQUE FORM WHO
STAND TO LOSE SALES OF OPIOIDS.
IT MAY COME FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES.
WHO BELIEVE
THAT? FROM OPIOIDS
IS THE BEST AND ONLY SOLUTION TO
OPIOID USE DISORDER. AND
PUNISHMENT AND INCARCERATION.
OUR OUR MORE APPROPRIATE
APPROACHES.
THESE VESTED INTEREST GROUPS ARE
POLITICALLY POWERFUL.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
RESISTED THEIR INFLUENCE IN THE
PAST.
AND SHOULD DO SO NOW FOR THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
I URGE YOU TO PROMOTE
LEGISLATION THAT WILL MOTIVATE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS TO
INCREASE THEIR KNOWLEDGE OF THE
CAUSES AND TREATMENT OF OPIOID
USE DISORDER.
THANK YOU NEXT WAS IF YOU BE
BRIEFLY OF UP TO MEET OUR
SPEAKER THANK YOUNG SUCH OUR
MEMBERS ARE TOM RENT FREE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. WE'RE ALL
WELL AWARE NOW THAT THE.
PURE EPIDEMIC IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS OVER TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE DYING EVERY
YEAR. OF OPIOID.
OVERDOSES
I STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
MEDICATIONS FOR ADDICTION
TREATMENT SUCH AS BUPRENORPHINE
IN COMBINATION WITH COUNSELING
OR BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTIONS. ARE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE INTERVENTION
FOR OPIOID USE DISORDERS
UNFORTUNATELY PROVIDERS TRAIN TO
EFFECTIVELY TREAT ADDICTION WITH
THESE MEDICATIONS ARE VERY IN
VERY SHORT SUPPLY.
CALIFORNIA HAS FEWER THAN TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED POSITIONS
AUTHORIZED TO PRESCRIBE
BUPRENORPHINE.
AND MANY OF THESE PROVIDERS.
DECLINED TO TREAT PATIENTS WITH
OPIE OR DISORDERS OUT OF CONCERN
THAT THEIR TRAINING IN ADDICTION
MEDICINE IS INADEQUATE.
THIS MEANS THAT FEWER THAN FIFTY
PERCENT OF THOSE ADDICTED TO
OPIOIDS ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS TO
A PHYSICIAN TRAINED TO PRESCRIBE
THIS LIFESAVING MEDICATION. WE
HEAR REPORTS FROM COUNTIES THAT
MANY PATIENTS WHO ARE ARE
PRESCRIBED OPIOIDS AND THEN
BECOME ADDICTED THAT THE
POSITION IS THEN THAT THEY'VE
HAD IS NOT. ABLE TO TREAT THEM
NOT BECAUSE OF STATEMENT
NECESSARILY BUT JUST BECAUSE THE
POSITION DOESN'T FEEL LIKE
THEY'VE BEEN ADEQUATELY TRAINED
IN IN YOU THE USE OF THESE
MEDICATIONS. AND SO THAT LEAVES
THESE PATIENTS THAN ARE
SCRAMBLING TO FIND OUT FIND SOME
HELP LIKE I SAY MANY OF THEM ARE
NOT ABLE TO DO SO.
THE.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
SEVEN TAKES THEM OUT ACTION TO
ENSURE THAT MORE CALIFORNIA
POSITIONS HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS NEEDED TO RESPOND TO THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC. IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THAT COALITION AWARENESS IS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SHOW GIVENS AT THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL THE WITNESSES IN
CHRIS READ OF THE CULPRIT IS
WILL THERE BE ASSOCIATION WERE
IN SUPPORT OF WHAT WE LOOK FOR
TO TALK WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE.
ABOUT INCLUSION OF A NON
PHARMACOLOGICAL EDUCATION AS
WELL.
ISSUE ONE THIS IS A SPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
COME UP AREA TWO MINUTES FIRST
.
I THINK MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MAKE IT ALRIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
TAKEN AND THAT THIS COMMITTEE
HAS WORKED ON. AND THEY DO MOVE
THE BILL EMIGRATE DIRECTION.
WE ARE STILL CONCERNED HOWEVER
THAT THE.
AMENDMENT STILL REQUIRE
EVERYBODY WITH A D. A LICENSE TO
TAKE THIS MANDATORY EIGHT HOUR
TRAINING CLASSES I'M SPECIFIC TO
PEOPLE OFTEN.
AT.
ANYBODY WITH THE D. A. NUMBER
CAN.
AB SORRY DE EIGHT NUMBERS
REQUIRED TO PRINT PRESCRIBE
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
WHICH ARE FAR GREATER IN NUMBER
THAN JUST OPIOIDS SO THERE ARE A
WHOLE HOST OF POSITIONS THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO TAKE THIS
THAT WILL NEVER NECESSARILY USE
THIS TRAINING. WILL NEVER GO ON
TO FILE FOR THE WAIVER TO
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO PRESCRIBE
IT.
AND WORK IN A FIELD ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT.
SO I.
I THINK THAT'S A LITTLE
FLEXIBILITY WOULD.
BE APPRECIATED I AM AS OPPOSED
TO A IN MANDATORY TRAINING
CLASS.
AB BUT OTHERWISE WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S I'M INTENT TO
ENABLE MORE PHYSICIANS TO
PRESCRIBE THIS TO. EDUCATE OUR
POSITIONS ON THE ABILITY ARE ON.
AT PRESCRIBING FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS AND WE WOULD URGE.
INCENTIVE BASED.
LEGISLATION TO.
TO PROVIDE TO GET MORE AB
PROVIDERS INTO THAT.
AREA OF SPECIALTY IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
BUT I THINK THE MANDATORY
TRAINING COURSES JUST THAT. THE
WRONG DIRECTION.
AS IT'S WRITTEN BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS WOULD
CONTINUE TO.
FOR TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCER WITH THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBG WANES AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR THE MAINTENANCE AND HIM
WORKING WITH THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY. LIKE TO ECHO CMA'S
AND CONCERNS AS WELL AND AGAIN
JUST REITERATE WE'RE NOT POSTED
EDUCATION AT ALL WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO THE MANDATE OF THE EDUCATION
IN FACT. A COG.
ACTUALLY HAS ITS OWN MEDICATED.
A MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
COURSE OFFERS FOUR HOURS ONLINE
AND FOUR HOURS IN PERSON
TRAINING ON ON THIS EXACT TYPE
OF.
COURSE AND SO WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT AND WE DO
ENCOURAGE OUR PHYSICIANS TO DO
IT IS JUST A MANDATING SUPPLY
DEMAND IT OF ANY TYPE OF TEANECK
MET. MEDICAID MEDICAL EDUCATION
IS OF CONCERN TO US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHERE TOP ON
BEHALF OF BIO COM UM WE HAVE AN
OPPOSING LESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL IT'S FOR A VERY
NARROW.
POINTS IN THE BILL WERE
ACTUALLY QUITE APPRECIATIVE OF
WHAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO
HERE I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE A THERAPEUTIC
MODALITIES AND THAT ARE
RECOGNIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THIS BILL ONLY
IDENTIFIES ONE OF THEM. ON THEIR
COULD BE ONES DEVELOPED IN THE
FUTURE THAT WE THINK THEY MIGHT
EVEN BE MORE EFFICACIOUS AND WE
THINK THAT.
THEY SHOULD ALSO BE IDENTIFIED
IN THE DUST WOULD LIKE THE
AUTHOR TO I CONSIDER THOSE
POINTS AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
THINK YOU.
IN ADDITION WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN EGGMAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OUT OF. THIS
RECORD AND I APOLOGIZE I WASN'T
HERE WORLD JUMPING AROUND OF
MULTIPLE COMMITTEES.
THIS TIME A YEAR. OF WHAT WAS IS
BASED UPON THE THE SITE IDEA OF
EIGHT HOURS TRAINING MANDATORY
TRAINING.
WELL IN THAT IN CALIFORNIA.
PHYSICIANS ARE ABLE TO
PRESCRIBE.
.
A PAINKILLER OXY COTTON'S SO
FORTH BUT IF AN INDIVIDUAL CELLS
UP AT THE ER.
OR A CLINIC AND IS A HEROIN
ADDICT YOU'RE ADDICTED TO
OPIOIDS AND THEY WANT TO BE
PRESCRIBED.
HAVE DEEPENED AFTER IN A LOW
LEVEL OPIOID TO GET OFF OF THEIR
ADDICTION THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO DO
SO UNLESS THEY HAVE THIS
LICENSE.
AND SO THAT THIS WOULD FOCUS ON.
THE.
THE TRAINING THAT INDIVIDUALS
HAVE TO GO THROUGH WITH WHEN
THEY GET THERE MEDICAL SCHOOL
TRAINING AND PICK AND FORGET
CONTINUED EDUCATION. PRESENT
NOTED THAT WE WEREN'T FOR
NARROWING IT.
TO FOCUS ON THOSE WHO ARE JUST
GETTING THEIR THEIR DE A.
UP LICENSE THAT THRESHOLD AND
WE WE DO HEAR THE THE CONCERNS
AND MAYBE WE CAN LOOK AT.
FURTHER FOCUSING ON THOSE WHO
ARE JUST GOING TO BE.
.
DESCRIBING.
YOU KNOW PAINKILLERS SINCE AND
THE SCHEDULED DRUGS.
OKAY.
I AM. I I I I AM NOT ONE WHO
LOVES MANDATORY TRAININGS
AND IT WAS A BILL LAST YEAR FOR
THERAPIST TO GO THROUGH
MANDATORY TRAINING TO DEALING
WITH SUICIDE. ON THE OPPOSITE OF
WHAT YOU DO WITH IT ANYWAY AND
TO.
ESTIMATED THERE POSTED MORE
TRAINING OR SOMETHING THERE
TRAINED IN THIS MAKING SENSE TO
ME SO ANYTIME I SEE MANDATORY
TRAINING IS COMING FROM.
NO NON PROVIDER OF UP THAT THAT
IT MAKES ME NERVOUS SO I'LL BE
WATCHING THIS AS IT GOES FORWARD
UP AND SING BUT DID YOU NARROW
IT TO TO TO NOT BE AS BROAD
BASED MAKING EVERYBODY TAKEN
EIGHT HOUR TRAINING COURSE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THAT THE
CAREER IS IN THE CURRICULUM
ALREADY ESTABLISHED IN PROVIDED
SOMEWHERE IT IT'S ALL IT'S ALSO
OPERATE.
OKAY.
VICE CHAIR BURLINGTON
ASSEMBLYMAN JUST A QUICK COMMENT
NOW THANK YOU ALSO FOR WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION
AND I HOPE YOU CAN NEED TO
SOLICIT.
THEY DO VERY MUCH FASTER SOMEONE
BAKER THANK YOU AND I AND THE
SAME QUESTION AND ONCE
IMPRESSIONS.
.
DOCTOR EGGMAN BUT THE THE
QUESTION IS WHY EIGHT HOURS
MY AT SIX TEN ONE TWO WHAT WORDS
COME WITH EIGHT.
I BELIEVE THAT THAT THAT IS THE
STRUCTURE TO IT TO GET THE JOB.
LICENSES AT EIGHT OUR PROGRAM
DOCTOR FLYNN.
THAT'S CORRECT ARM HOWEVER FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THE OF THE BELL.
IT MIGHT BE MORE APPROPRIATE TO
HAVE A MUCH SHORTER.
DISCRETION TO. AND PHYSICIANS
WHO ARE NOT PLANNING TO OUR GIVE
GIVE AND I THINK THAT THEY NEED
TO BE AWARE THAT IT TAKES.
OKAY THANK YOU SO I GUESS I'M
STRAIGHT STARS THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S THE STRUCTURE I ARMENIANS
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GET
THE X. WAIVER TO PRESCRIBE THIS
YOU HAVE TO HAVE EIGHT HOURS OF
TRAINING SO IT'S BASED.
OKAY.
IN ORDER TO GET THE T. A
CERTIFICATION. NOR TO GET THE
AXE WAIVER TO PRESCRIBE ANY OF
THESE CUBAN EFFORT OKAY
TREATMENT EFFORT THANK YOU AND
SAM I I APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S
THE FEDERAL.
.
REQUIREMENTS AT FIVE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE OPENING THAT WHEN
YOU'RE WITNESSES MAY WHICH IS
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT IN ADDITION
TO NARROWING THE SCOPE. TO THOSE
WHO ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
PRESCRIBING.
YOU MAY ALSO CONSIDER NARROWING
THE AMOUNT OF TIME.
IT'S NECESSARY BECAUSE WHEN I
LOOK AT THIS I SEE BIG TWENTY
HOURS OF.
CONTINUING EDUCATION REQUIRED IF
I'M CORRECT ABOUT THAT AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT NOW ST ALMOST HALF OF
THAT.
HAS TO BE IN ONE PARTICULAR
AREA.
AND I KNOW THAT DOCTORS ARE LOSE
TO BE COMPARED TO LAWYERS BUT
WE.
WE HAVE CONTINUING EDUCATION AS
WELL IN FOR ELIMINATING BIAS IN
THE PROFESSION AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND OTHERS BUT. THE WHAT
LET'S SAY THAT WE HAD A PROBLEM
WITH THAT.
PATENT LAW AND I HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH PAT LA I DON'T
PRACTICE IT IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT I DO BUT I'VE GOT TO TAKE
EIGHT HOURS WHICH IS.
ALMOST HALF OF THEIR OVERALL
TIME AS OPPOSED TO SOMETHING I
MIGHT REALLY THINK AYE I
DESPERATELY NEED OR WITH BENEFIT
FROM.
ADDITIONAL.
TRAINING AND ARE OR CONTINUING
EDUCATION AND FINDING THAT THIS
COULD BE VERY VERY RIGID AND
EIGHT HOURS IS A LOT WHEN IT'S A
HALF OF THE REQUIREMENT.
SO AND I LIKE A DOCTOR EGGMAN I
THINK IN OTHERS.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE WHERE
YOU'RE GOING WITH THIS I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THAT LOOKING
AT CERTAIN NARROWING THIS TO
HAVE MORE TARGETED FOCUSED
SENATE DOCTORS TO HIM THIS WOULD
APPLY AND PERHAPS THE AMOUNT OF
TIME. SO THAT WE ARE MAKING SURE
THAT PHYSICIANS ARE ABLE TO.
MEET THEIR HOURS IN OTHER AREAS
THAT WE REALLY REALLY WANT THEM
TO TAKING CLEAN AS EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS THAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO.
SWEET WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT EVERY TIME THERE AND AN
HOUR AWAY FROM PROVIDING MEDICAL
CARE A THAT PROVIDE IT BE THERE
PROBABLY NOT BEING PAID.
TO TAKE THE EDUCATION AND
THAT'S.
HOW THEY ALSO MAINTAIN THEIR
PRACTICES SO?
PUBLIC THAT CAN BE DONE IN
FUTURE ITERATIONS OF THE BILL IS
THE ONLY CHANCE I MEAN TO SEE IT
FOR HITS THE FLOOR SICKENING
MAKE SURE THAT'S. EXPRESSED
VERY.
DOCTOR AND.
I WANTED TO START BY. WELCOMING
YOU TO THIS COMMITTEE.
I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF GOING
UP TO BUTTE COUNTY WITH YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY WHERE WE
TALKED ABOUT A FEW.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY NOT
KNOW ON THE COMMITTEE I'VE IN
THE.
.
PREVIOUS TO COMING HERE ACTUALLY
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ATA
METHADONE CLINIC WHERE WE WERE
ABLE TO PRESCRIBE MANY
MEDICATIONS.
THAT CAN HELP THOSE WHO ARE
GOING THROUGH ADDICTION AND
RECOVERY AS WE ARE NOW.
AND AS A CURRENT DA HOLDER I WAS
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN THIS
BILL.
BUT I SHARE THE CONCERNS THAT
DOCTOR EGGMAN DOES ANY TIME
WE'RE HAVING INDIVIDUAL
LEGISLATORS BRING FORWARD.
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION
THAT'S NOT SUPPORTED BY THE
MEDICAL BOARD THAT FOR.
SOME OTHER. EXTERNAL VALIDATOR
THAT MAKES SURE THAT THE
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION IS
JERRY.
PARTICULARLY I WANTED TO FOCUS
OF I COULD ON THE WORDS OF YOUR
WITNESS HIS WORDS WERE MOTIVATE.
BUT THE WORDS ON THE BILL ARE
MANDATE.
AND AS WE ARE NOW ANY DE A
HOLDER IS ABLE TO IF THEY SO
CHOOSE. TO DO THESE EIGHT HOURS
OF CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION
IS AND TO RECEIVE THE SEX
LICENSE.
BUT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PHYSICIANS ACROSS OUR STATE FOR.
GOOD REASONS AND BAD REASONS
HAVE NOT SELECTED TO DO SO.
I AM UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE
CURRENT WAY THE BILL IS FRAMED
BECAUSE IT WOULD.
REQUIRE ALL PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS ACROSS OUR STATE
TO UNDER GO.
AT EIGHT HOURS OF CONTINUING
MEADOW WILL GO EDUCATION THAT
MIGHT NOT APPLY TO THEIR DAILY
PRESS.
AND WILL ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
WANTING THIS BILL TO BE NARROWED
OR TO BE. AND A SUCH A
RECOMMENDATION AND OR TO COME
FROM THE MEDICAL BOARD ITSELF SO
THAT WERE INSURED THAT THE. BEST
PRACTICES OF TODAY ARE THE
ACTUAL EVIDENCE THAT WE'RE USING
TO BASE OUR LEGISLATION.
SO WITH THAT AGAIN JUST WANTED
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD BUT. CAN'T SUPPORT THIS.
ITS CURRENT FORM.
A ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
IT'S TIME ASSEMBLY WERE MCCARTY
DO WE SHOULD CLOSE YES AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT FOR THE FEED
BACK INTO WORKING TO WORK WITH
THEM.
THOSE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND.
YEAH IN OPPOSITION AND I THINK
THE THAT THE NEXUS HERE IS THAT.
.
IN THE CURRENT STRUCTURE THERE
ARE NOT ENOUGH MEDICAL PROVIDERS
WHO EITHER. WHO WHO KNOW ABOUT
IT AND MAYBE THEY COULD BE
INFORMED ABOUT IT THROUGH THEIR
WHEN THEY GO TO YOU KNOW GET
THEIR THEIR? LICENSE IN THE
FIRST PLACE OR CONTINUING
EDUCATION AS WELL. AND THIS
CERTAINLY WAY I THINK I BENEFIT
I CALIFORNIANS WHO UNFORTUNATELY
ARE ADDICTED IT WOULD HELP WITH
THAT THE CLINICS OUT THERE WHO
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MEDICAL
PROVIDERS TO HELP IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
AND.
CERTAINLY ASK YOUR AYE BUT
TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A MCCARTY
AND I ALSO KNOW THAT OUR OFFICES
WORK WITH SOME LANGUAGE TO
ADDRESS IN THIS CONCERNS IN THAT
YOU'VE ALSO INDICATED. OF THE
WILLINGNESS AND INTENT TO ALSO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE CONCERNS I
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD.
CYPRESS SHOULD THAT VERY MUCH
THIS DOES AND JURY AND I'M A
RECOMMENDATION A WE DO HOWEVER
NEED A MOTION AT THIS TIME.
MOTION AND SECOND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TWENTY SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HELLO AYE LOW AYE BRO.
BROWN NOT VOTING ARAMBULA NO
ARAMBULA NO BAKER.
BAKER NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BUT I CHEN.
JENELLE CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AVERTING FALL.
GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. IRWIN
AYE MULLIN.
TING.
RICK I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW MOVE ON TO.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN.
AND THAT IS AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY OF
THIS BILL OF YOURS DOES ENJOY
AND I AYE RECOMMENDATION PLEASE
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT THIS
BILL AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY FIVE.
IT'S A BILL THAT SANTA HAD
ASSISTING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IN THEIR INTERACTIONS
WITH CANNABIS DISTRIBUTORS.
AND DELIVERY DRIVERS.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
LANGUAGE REGARDING A LOT
IDENTIFICATION CARD FURNISHED BY
THE BUREAU.
THE GOAL OF AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
FIVE IS TO PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WITH THE
GUIDANCE.
WHEN THEY ENCOUNTER A CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTOR OR DELIVERY DRIVER.
IT'S BILL AUTHORIZES AN OFFICER
TO WRITE A CITATION OF A
DISTRIBUTOR DOES NOT HAVE.
A PHYSICAL MANIFEST WITH THEM OR
IF THEY FAILED TO SUBMIT THE
REQUIRED INFORMATION INTO TRACK
AND TRACE.
THE BILL ALSO AUTHORIZES THE
CITATION OF THE LICENSEE DOES
NOT HAVE THEIR DELIVERY REQUEST.
UNDERCURRENT LAW LICENSEES ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE THESE ITEMS
WHEN TRANSPORTING CANNABIS.
THESE REQUIREMENTS OR BRIGHT
LINE THE DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
LEGAL OPERATORS AND DOES
BREAKING THE LAW.
WE WANT OFFICERS TO BE CHECKING
FOR THESE ITEMS SO THEY CAN
EASILY DISTINGUISH BETWEEN WILL.
A LICENSEE FOR ILLICIT
ACTOR.
SHAPE THAT WILL MOVE RIGHT
ALONG.
.
I DO HAVE A COUPLE SUPPORTERS
HERE THAT I WANTED TO. INTRODUCE
ALL TURN TO.
.
SEAN RUNDLE OF THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTORS ASSOCIATION.
DETERMINE BURST WITH THE.
RECOMMENDATION THE VOTE I'LL BE
BRIEF.
THE CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATIONS AND MEMBERSHIP OF.
OVER SIXTEEN THOUSAND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS FROM.
AGENCY HEADS TO LINE LEVEL AND
THEIR MAIN GOAL IS TO WORK WITH
THE BUSINESSES COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IN THEIR.
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT THAT THE COMMITTEES ARE
SAFE AND IF THERE'S ANY
VIOLATORS AFTER.
CURRENT STANDARDS THAT ARE PUT
FORTH BY THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL IF THEY'RE CONTINUING TO
VIOLATE THAT THEY HAVE THOSE
TOOLS.
AS MR LACKEY MENTION TO ATTEND
FORCES IN THIS COMMUNITY SO WITH
THAT.
AGAIN I'LL JUST BE BRIEF AND
KNOW THAT WE APPRECIATE HIS WORK
ON THE BILL AND ASK YEARS.
I ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AARON MORE WEIGHT ON THE
HOUSE OF THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION. FIRST
ONE I JUST THINK THE HOR
HIS STAFF FOR ALL HIS HARD WORK
IN THIS IMPORTANT AREA. AS HE
SAID WE BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL
HELP DISTINGUISH BETWEEN THE
LICENSED
COMPLIANT OPERATORS IN THE
MARKET AND THE NON LICENSED ON
THE. ILLEGAL OPERATORS SO WE
APPRECIATE HIS WORK AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THEM AND THEY CAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE NAME
AFFILIATION FOR THE RECORD IF
YOU DO WISH TO DO SO THAT TONY
BLOBBY HAVE REFLECTIVE THE
LARGEST CHEMIST. ATTEMPTS TO
BURN THE STATE HERE SUPPORT
THAT.
CAN HARDLY GET AND I AM IN
SUPPORT IF ANYTHING THAT'S GOING
TO STOP THIS FROM KILLING OUR
INNOCENT KIDS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE
DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION
ON THE BILL BUT WE DO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT AND WILL BE
REVIEWING IT. AT OUR NEXT LEDGE
SUBCOMMITTEE ME THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ARE IN
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES REGION'S
BEGIN SUPPORT SEEN NONE OF
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME TO MY PHONE
YOU'LL HAVE UP TO THREE MINUTES.
PLEASE WHEN EVERYBODY.
RICHARD MEMBERS RAN MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF BLACKBIRD LOGISTICS
UPPER STUFF WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT THAT THE COURT CAN
YOUR QUESTION THE AUTHORS AGREED
TO ON THE IDENTIFICATION CARD.
I'M WE ACTUALLY HAVE A CONCERN
WITH ONE PIECE OF THE BILL AND
THAT'S THE.
THE PENALTY IMPOSED ON THE
FAILURE TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
PHYSICAL COPY NUMBER ONE CURRENT
REGULATIONS DO NOT REQUIRED OF
PHYSICAL COPY IT DOES REQUIRE
YOU TO HAVE AN ELECTRONIC COPY
SO THAT'S A. AT LEAST A FIX IT
WOULD BE SHOULD SHOULD BE MADE
I'M IN THE LAW RELATIVE TO TO
THAT REQUIREMENT.
WE ALSO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
ADDING ADDITIONAL THINGS TO
DISTRIBUTORS AT A TIME WHEN WE
ARE NOW THREE AND A HALF MONTHS
ALMOST FOUR MONTHS.
INTO.
INTO THIS NEW LAW.
WE NEED TO TAKE TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHAT THE VOTERS
APPROVED AND TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
WHAT YOU WAS LEGISLATURE
APPROVED LAST YEAR.
THE GET SETTLED LONG LETTERS
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY'RE WHAT THE
PROBLEM.
MAY BE AND HOW AND HOW WE MIGHT
FIX THOSE IF THEY DO ARISE.
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS
SUBSTANTIAL ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSIBILITY I'M PUT ON THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL. ON
THERE IS NO INDICATION AT THIS
POINT THAT THERE ENFORCEMENT
ABILITY.
IS NOT GETTING AT THE ISSUE OF
DISTRIBUTORS WHO ARE FAILING TO
MEET THEIR OBLIGATION AND THEIR
SUBSTANTIAL PENALTIES INCLUDING
THE REVOCATION OF THE LICENSE
THAT ALREADY EXIST. ON TO ADD
SOMETHING NEW AT THIS POINT WE
STE I BELIEVE IS PREMATURE I'M
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE ON. TIME TO
LET THESE THINGS SETTLE BEFORE
WE MAKE SOME CHANGES NOT FOR
THAT REASON WE'RE POSTS THAT ONE
PIECE OF ALL I THINK EVERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SENIOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME. THERE IS A MOTION
AND A SECOND MISTER LACKEY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I WOULD CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
ALIVE VOTE BECAUSE I COULD TELL
YOU RIGHT NOW. THE BLACK MARKET
IS.
DOING MUCH BETTER THAN LEGIT
MARKET WE NEED TOOLS.
TO FIGHT AGAINST THE BLACK
MARKET WE BELIEVE THIS IS A VERY
CRITICAL PART OF THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS AS INTO
IT AS I MENTIONED ENJOYS AND AYE
AYE RECOMMENDATION THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND SECOND COMMITTEE
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ACTIONS DO PASS AS A MANAGED
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS LOW
AYE AYE THOUGH I BRO. BRO I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG. FONG AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
SELECT YOUR BILL IS THAT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE BY SYMBOL
NUMBER BLOOM. MISTER BLOOM THIS
DOES ENJOY AN AYE AYE
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT MONEY VERY.
ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE
WHICH UPDATES THE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY PRACTICE ACT.
THIS ACT WAS WRITTEN EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO AND THE BILL SIMPLY
UPDATES AND CLARIFIES THE ACT TO
ENSURE THAT OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST CAN PRACTICE TO THE
FULL EXTENT OF THEIR EDUCATION
AND TRAINING.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME ALLEN MY
WITNESSES TO SELF INTRODUCE.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR AYE BUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS IVAN ALL TOMORROW WITH
CAPITAL ADVOCACY. REPRESENTING
THE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
AMERICAN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION I WILL KEEP MY MY
COMMENTS VERY BRIEF.
WE ARE WE HAVE BEEN REACHING
OUT EARLY AND OFTEN WITH OUR
OTHER A HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS SAW IN THIS BILL
WE'VE BEEN ADDRESSING COMMENTS
CONCERNS QUESTIONS WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO DO SO.
THE ANALYSIS ARE BROUGHT UP A
FEW CLARIFYING THINGS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON BUT
WE BELIEVE THAT.
THAT TIME BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT
THAT YOU DO NOT SEE.
ANY OPPOSITION ANALYSIS WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK THROUGH AND
TRYING TO ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS
ANYBODY HAVE SO. I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE HEATHER KITCHEN WHO IS
THE PRESIDENT OF.
ATTACK AND ALSO THIS CHUCK
WILMARTH OF THE STATE OF THE
DIRECTOR STATE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE AMERICAN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY UP AGAIN MY MANY
MISS HAVE A KITCHEN I REPRESENT
THE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
JUST A FEW BRIEF POINTS SO IT
HAS BEEN ACTUALLY A PRETTY
RIGOROUS HOME AND ENGAGE
CONVERSATION WITH OTHERS. OF WE
DO SEEK A FEW KEY POINTS.
WE HELP TO A CONTEMPORIZE OUR
PRACTICE SOME ACTUALLY PRACTICE
HAS CHANGED SINCE OUR OF
PRACTICE ACT CAME INTO BEING IN
TWO THOUSAND. A WE ACTUALLY ARE
NOW. PROVIDING MORE EXTENSIVE AN
APPROPRIATE SERVICES TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS AND SO
THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE BILL AS
WELL AS.
AND ENRICHING THE DESCRIPTION
OF WHAT WE HOPE WILL BE ADDED TO
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR LICENSURE
RENEWAL A SPECIFICALLY.
TO PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
CLOETE NOT ONLY SELF ASSESSMENT
BUT ALSO ALL THAT ENCOMPASSES
EXPANSION OF ONE SKILLS IN
SERVICE PROVISION.  WE ALSO
HOPE TO ADDRESS ON THE ADVANCED
PRACTICE REQUIREMENTS FOR
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
PRACTITIONERS A SPECIFIC TO
REDUCING THE BURDEN OF THE
PROCESS THERE IN. IN ACHIEVING
OTHER DESIGNATION TO THEIR
LICENSE THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE.
SPECIFIC AREAS OF CARE. AND
THEN OF COURSE WE ALSO HOPE TO
EXPAND AND ENHANCE THE.
PRACTICE OF OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ASSISTANCE THIS IS A
VERY NECESSARY ARM OF OUR
PRACTITIONER COMMUNITY OVER ALL
MEETING THE NEEDS OF MANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO REQUIRE OUR
SERVICES AND BENEFIT FROM OUR
SERVICES.
OF SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE KEY
POINTS AND I THINK HOW.
ALLOW OUR REPRESENTATIVE FROM
OUR NATIONAL ASSOCIATION TO
SPEAK.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE RECORD A
CHUCK WILMARTH WITH THE AMERICAN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION
WITH OF COURSE THE NATIONAL
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SOMEONE
BILL TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE.
AS HEATHER MENTIONED I AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING HEATHER SAID OF
THIS THAT BILL DOES A MODERNIZE
THE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
PRACTICE ACT SINCE IT WAS FIRST
ENACTED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
THAT. SOME OF THE TERMINOLOGY
USED IN THE PROFESSION HAS
INVOLVED AND SO WE ARE SEEKING
SOME REFINEMENTS THERE. THAT WE
ARE LOOKING TO IMPROVE
ASSEMBLING WHICH OVERLY TAX
OFFICIAL THERAPY ASSISTANCE AND
ADDRESSING THEIR ROLE WITHIN THE
PROFESSION. AND THERE'S ALSO
CURRENT LIMITATION NOW ON THE
NUMBER OF ASSISTANCE THAT CAN BE
SUPERVISED BY OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST WE'RE INCREASING THAT
NUMBER TO CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM IT ALSO
IN THE ENHANCE THEIR ROLE WITHIN
THE PROFESSION. NO LASTLY WE'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT CONTINUE
DUCATION RECURRENCE FOR HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THIS BILL REFINES
THE EXISTING REQUIREMENT. OF TWO
TO STATE THAT ESSENTIALLY A
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT PLAN
SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN THAT WILL
DRIVE. OF THOSE REQUIREMENTS AND
THEN FINALLY THE COMPETENCY
ASSESSMENT IS IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SO FAR URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS NAME
AND AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO
DO SO.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BRIAN
THAT WORDS ON THE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA VICE PRESIDENT
AMENDMENTS.
IT'S BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LAURA WILL I MEAN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
PRACTITIONER CLINICAL EDUCATOR I
AM ALSO A FACULTY MEMBER IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. AND I WANT TO STATE MY
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LAUREN LOPEZ AN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
PRACTITIONER AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I WILL INELIGIBLE SNAG WITH C.
HERE ON BEHALF OF UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA UNION
HEALHCARE PROFESSIONALS YOU
NECK. A IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE REASONS STATED.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHES
BE CAN SUPPORT SAYING THAT
ANYONE ISSUES WITHIN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID NOT
BUT CAN IN THE NEUTRAL ZONE A
CARL LONDON ON BEHALF THAT
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION. NETWORK WITH THE
SPONSORS ON A COUPLE TECHNICAL
ISSUES THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
BILL. EMIGRATE TO WORK WITH
WE'RE CONFIDENT WE'LL RESOLVE
ALL YOU KNOW REMAINING ISSUES TO
OUR SATISFACTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM CAN
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
HE SAID.
I THINK YOU GUYS LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR IN THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL TO SEE
SOMETHING THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
LOOKING LIKE A SCOPE ISSUE HAVE
VIRTUALLY NO OPPOSITION.
SAYS JOB WELL DONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EXCITEMENT
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLY ROOM BLOOM DO WISH TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS DOES ENJOY AN AYE AYE
RECOMMENDATION AND I APPRECIATE.
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
BY SOMEONE EGGMAN AND SHARE THAT
OPINION AS WELL SO THAT WE SICK
THERE WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACTION IS THE PASTOR COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS LOW BY LOW AYE
BRO. BRO I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BAKER.
BLOOM. AYE BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN TING.
WE HAVE THE REQUISITE NUMBER OF
VOTES TO HAVE YOUR BILL PASSED A
BELIEF THAT WILL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER THANK
YOU. MEMBERS WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
LEFT ON OUR AGENDA.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AND I'M
NEVER SIXTEEN A THERE IS
CURRENTLY AN ABSENCE OF ONE
ADDITIONAL AUTHOR SO I WILL
PRESENT ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN IN
V. THREE AS POSSIBLE AND HAND
THIS OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR OF TWO BY THE CHAIR.
BUT. MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AYE SIR VICE CHAIR
THIS BILL IS A CONSUMER
PROTECTION ENSURING THAT. WE
HAVE A PRIVACY WITH RESPECT TO
CONSUMERS OF CANDIDATES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
HAVE WITNESSES TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT.
.
MEDICARE AND MISTER CHAIR JASON
RIGHT OF THE APTLY CALIFORNIA
GROWERS ASSOCIATION THE BILL
PROTECTS THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF CONSUMERS BY
PROHIBITING THE LICENSEE.
FROM DISCLOSING A CONSUMERS
PERSONAL INFORMATION TO A THIRD
PARTY. WE FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT THAT WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE CONSUMERS TO TO TO
MAKE PURCHASES AND IN THE
REGULATED MARKETPLACE WE NEED TO
PROTECT THEIR THE PRIVACY. AND
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE CONSUMERS
TURNED TO THE LEGAL MARKET
BECAUSE SOMEHOW THAT'S MORE OF A
OF A WAY TO PROTECT OUR OWN
PRIVACY. LET'S MAKE.
IT MAKES MAKE SURE THAT THE.
.
REGULATED MARKETPLACE HAS THE
PROTECTIONS THAT CONSUMERS NEED
A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO SHOW WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SORRY ME JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I JUST WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THAK YOU
POTENTIAL INNOCENCE MARK.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
KAREN LEGATE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
ALL OF MORE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
EVERYBODY IN THE INDUSTRY THANK
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING ABOUT
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE MISTER CHAIRMAN LET.
PROSPECT WE ASK FOR A VOTE.
WASH MY MISTER GIBSON SECOND BY
MISTER ARAMBULA.
COMMITTEE CLICK PLEASE KALRA.
ACTION IS TO PASS TO COMMITTEE
ON PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION LOW. LOW AYE BRO.
BROWN NOW ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BAKER.
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
PHONE NOW GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. BERMAN AYE
MULLIN TING.
AND THE LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ON THAT ONE AS
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE
CHAIR WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
BILL TO BE PRESENTED BUT GIVEN
THE ABSENCE OF THIS MEMBER AND I
KNOW THAT THE SERGEANTS ARE
CALLING AND. WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK THEN THROUGH VOLTA ALLOW
FOR MOTIONS IN SECONDS.
MEMBERS THESE BILLS.
.
WHERE HEARD DURING?
ARE CONVENING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE SO WE NEED TO MOTIONS
A SECOND SO ALLOW ME TO GO
THROUGH A EACH OF THE BILLS AND
FILE ORDER AND SO WILL BEGIN
WITH FILE. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE.
MOTION A SECOND.
CHRIS AFTER WHICH PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ACTIONS DO PASSED THE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY LOW AYE LOW AYE
BROKE. BROKE AYE ARAMBULA AYE
AYE GREENVILLE I BAKER.
BLOOM. BLOOM I'VE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. BERMAN
AYE MULLIN TING.
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES THE BILL
IS THAT WE'VE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL.
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO. SO
MOVED.
MOTION A SECOND COMMITTEES ARE
VERY WHICH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTION IS THE PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY LOW
AYE AYE LOW AYE PRO. PRO I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN. TING.
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES BELIEF
THAT ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
A I FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE IT IS
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE SOME
OF.
THERE'S A MOTION A SECOND
CONSECUTIVE PLEASE CULTURAL.
ACTIONS DO PASSED THE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY LOW.
I LOW EYEBROW. BROUGH AYE
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BLOOM BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG. FONG AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN TING.
GEN VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT
THREE SIXTY PLEASE GO ABROAD.
ACTIONS DO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
AYE AYE LOW I BROKE. THROUGH AYE
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
TING.
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND ABOVE POTS AT THIS
TIME MEMBERS AS WE HAVE TO FIND
AUTHOR THAT IS HERE. AND THAT IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU.
MS ASSEMBLY AREN'T YOU PLEASE
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR. AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FIRST OFF ALL I
WANTED TO A DECEPTICON MEDIA
MAMMON AND THANK THIS COMMITTEE
STAFF AND MISTER CHAIR FOR.
WORKING WITH US ON THOSE.
AND NOT AMENDMENTS
AB THIRTY SIXTEEN A THIRTEEN
THIRTY TH
THIRTY THIRTEEN.
EXPANDS HEALTH CARE OPTIONS. AND
* FOR THOSE SEEKING ANIMAL
PHYSICAL.
REHAB SERVICES BY CREATING A
STATE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
LICENSED PHYSICAL THERAPIST.
URGE SPECIFICALLY DOES BILL
DIRECTED DO BAD MEDICAL BOARD.
AND THE PHYSICAL SERVED THE
BORDER BOASTED TO TO BOARD TO
COLLABORATIVELY DECIDE ON THE
QUALIFICATION.
NECESSARY FOR A PHYSICAL SERVER
OPPOSED TO RECEIVE A
CERTIFICATION IN ANIMAL PHYS
GREENHOUSE.
WAS JUST BILL ASSUME OF ICING OF
A BAT AFTER YOU VALUE ROUTINE
EVALUATING AND ANIMAL CAN
REFERRED THEM TO A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST WHO WAS JUST.
THOSE THIRD CERTIFICATION BOTH
PHYSICAL REHAB REHAB SERVICES
UNDER THIS MODEL. DOES TO
REVISING A VAT CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER. THEY WILL CEASE
SUPERVISE THE PHYSICAL THERAPIST
ONSITE.
OR THEY WILL OPT FOR INDIRECT
SUPERVISION OF TO FISCAL SURPLUS
ALTERED PROMISES.
TO PROVIDE SERVICES ALT OFFSITE.
THE PHYSICAL SUREPOS.
MUST REGISTER THEIR FACILITIES
WAS.
AND A RECEIVED A PERMIT FROM
TIBET MEDICAL BOARD.
WE HAVE ALSO CLARIFIED THAT TO
FISCAL SERVICE.
IS SOLELY LIABLE FOR SERVICE
PROVIDED TO THE ANIMAL.
S. DEMAND FOR THOSE SERVICES
GRUEL AND CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL
THERAPIST WAS TRAINING TO TREAT
ANIMAL.
OFFERS AN EMERGING CHOICE FOR
CONSUMERS.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF STATE LAW
DOES NOT INCLUDE THOSE
PROFESSIONALS.
THEY ARE CONSIDERED UNLICENSED
ASSISTANTS.
AND AM MUST ALWAYS PROVIDE
SERVICES UNDER THE DIRECT
SUPERVISION OF A BAT. AND ONTO.
A BENCH BUT URANIUM UPLOAD OF A
PROMPT APPRENTICES.
THE SMALL DOSE MODEL RESTRICTIVE
DAY FUTURE EXPANSION OF DOES
SERVICES AND CONSUMER CHOICES.
AND*.
IN TWENTY IS SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATIVE.
A RECOMMENDED THE FORMATION
OFFICE STAKEHOLDER TASK FORCE TO
ADDRESS THIS INCREASED DEMAND
AND CONCERN.
ABOUT UNQUALIFIED PROFESSION
TREATING ANIMALS.
AND THIS TASK FORCE AND INCLUDE
OF BAD FISCAL SERVICE.
AND THAT TECHNICIANS MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND A PROFESSIONAL%
INDUSTRIAL. UNDERSTAFFED
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND THIS BILL CODIFIED DID
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE TASK
FORCE CREATING A STANDARD.
STATE CERTIFICATION PROCESSES
FOR THE PHYSICAL THERAPIST IN
THE ANIMAL BUT SCHOOL REHAB.
THIS MEASURE WILL PROTECT ANIMAL
AND CONSUMERS WHILE A ATTRACT
HIM PHYSICAL SERVE POSED.
TO DO THIS GROWING FILL
EXPANDING SERVICES AND CHOICES
FOR ANIMAL LOVERS.
A. B.
THIRTY THIRTEEN ENJOYS SUPPORT
FROM THEIR BACKS SURGEONS AND
NUMEROUS LOCAL ANIMAL HOSPITALS.
AND.
OF A BAT HORSE TRAINERS MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC.
S. ME TODAY I HAVE TALKED TO
KAREN. AT ELLIS
THE PRESIDENT OF TO ANIMAL
PHYSICAL SERVERS CORRELATION AND
DOC TO GENDER AND BENT*
FUNDER OF TO. A CANINE REHAB
INSTITUTE.
SO WAS THAT OUT.
IF I COULD BE A KIND WE ASK THEM
FOR THE PUBLIC JUST MY LIMITED
ONE MINUTE A PIECE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'D.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
FOR INTRODUCING AB THIRTY
THIRTEEN. OF MY NAME IS KAREN
OUT LISTS AND I AM A LICENSED BE
TEAM CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE BEEN
SO FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
I SPEAK TO YOU AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE SPONSOR.
AS AND ON ON BEHALF OF THE MANY
THOUSANDS OF CONSUMERS SEEKING
ACCESS TO HIGH LEVEL WELL
REGULATED ANIMAL FISCAL
REHABILITATION FOR THEIR
COMPANION ANIMALS.
TO CLARIFY I WOULD LIKE TO
STATE THAT THEY.
PT BOARD AND THE VET BOARD WILL
BE WORKING TOGETHER DETERMINE
COMPETENCY STANDARDS FOR.
WHAT THE ADDITIONAL TRAINING
AND CERTIFICATION WOULD LOOK
LIKE IN THIS STATE?
THE CURRICULUM FOR PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS I'M IT WOULD BE IS
TO.
I HAVE AN UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE
AS WELL AS A THREE YEAR CLINICAL
DOCTORATE DEGREE AND WE ARE NOT
SAYING THAT JUST BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THOSE QUALIFICATIONS THAT
IT WOULD ALLOW YOU TO WORK ON
ANIMALS WE DO. RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO HAVE ADDITIONAL TRAINING
AND SO INCOMES THAT.
CERTIFICATION FOR.
FOR THIS SPECIALTY OF PRACTICE.
I AM.
AT THIRTY THIRTEEN MANDATES THAT
THE.
THAT THE VETERINARIANS RETAIN
FINAL CONTROL OVER HOW ANIMALS
READ RECEIVE ANIMAL REHAB.
THERAPY AND.
AND THEY GET TO DECIDE IF THE
ANIMAL IS SUITED TO BEING
TREATED AND NOT CITING AND UNDER
WHAT CONDITIONS.
THE ANIMAL REHAB THERAPISTS
WOULD BE MANDATED TO REPORT
REGULARLY TO THE REFERRING
VETERINARIAN HOWEVER IT IS
IMPORTANT TO KNOW.
THAT THE ANIMAL REHAB THERAPISTS
WOULD RETAIN LIABILITY FOR THE
TREATMENT OF THE ANIMAL NOT THE
VETERINARIAN JUST DOESN'T CASE
OF HUMAN MEDICINE BENQ.
CHAIRMAN LOW AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK.
MY NAME IS JANET VAN* I'M A
VETERINARIAN WITH OVER THIRTY
YEARS EXPERIENCE.
AS A SURGEON OWNING AND
OPERATING REFERRAL SURGICAL
PRACTICES IN NEW YORK CITY AND
CHICAGO.
I'M ALSO THE FOUNDER OF THE
CANINE REHABILITATION INSTITUTE.
I STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
AND WHERE I REMAIN AS THE CEO.
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
DISCUSSION IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
BROKE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WHEN I
WAS FIRST ASKED TO CONSULT FOR
SOME COMMITTEES DISCUSSING.
COLLABORATION BETWEEN PT'S AND
VETERINARIANS WHO IS ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE ANIMAL
REHABILITATION TASK FORCE THAT
CONCLUDED OUR WORK LAST YEAR.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN I WAS
INVOLVED WITH COLORADO'S
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE TO THE
VETERINARY PRACTICE ACT THEY'RE
USING LANGUAGE VERY SPECIFIC AND
VERY SIMILAR TO THE ONE THAT'S
BEING DISCUSSED TODAY.
THAT MODEL HAS WORKED SO WELL IN
COLORADO. WE'VE HAD ZERO PUBLIC
COMPLAINTS SINCE IT WAS PASSED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. WE'VE
WATCHED ENORMOUS EXPANSION OF
THIS INDUSTRY IN COLORADO
EMPLOYING VETERINARIANS
VETERINARY TECHNICIANS AND
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS.
AND ADDING NEW PRACTICES AND
GROWING AND EXPANDING CURRENTLY
EXISTING PRACTICES.
THE DEMAND FOR THIS IS CLIENT
DRIVEN AND THE VETERINARY
PRACTICE IS NOW TRYING TO CATCH
UP WITH THE DEMAND ON THE BETTER
ON THE CLIENT SIDE.
IT'S A POTENTIALLY LUCRATIVE
FIELD AND I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
WHY VETERINARIANS WHO PRACTICE
IN THIS FIELD ALREADY IN
CALIFORNIA MIGHT WANT TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN REVENUE STREAMS.
SEVERAL OF THEM ARE TRYING TO DO
THIS BY PERSUADING THE
LEGISLATURE TO DENY PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS ACCESS.
TO THIS PRACTICE OUTSIDE OF
THESE VETERINARIANS OWN
PRACTICES.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IN THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
BOARD ARE TASKED WITH PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC.
NEITHER IS IN A POSITION TO
BENEFIT THE FEW OF PEOPLE'S
INCOME STREAM AT THE COST TO THE
PUBLIC.
THE THEORY IS NOT A VOTE YES ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME
INNOVATIONS OF FOR THE RECORD IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO.
DANIEL ROBBINS AND EVERY HAVE
PRACTITIONER IN SUPPORT.
SCHLUP ARE MEMBER OF THE TASK
FORCE THAT.
WAS THE V. NBA WE WORKED REALLY
HARD FOR A YEAR TO COME UP WITH
SOME LANGUAGE. I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHORS OF THE US FOR
SUPPORTING IN WRITING THE BILL
THAT SUPPORTS WHAT THE ANIMAL
TASK FORCE CAME UP WITH AN AYE
SUPPORT.
CARE HAND CALAIS OUT CONSUMER
MEMBER OF THE ANIMAL REHAB TASK
FORCE.
I URGE YOU TO.
.
VOTE YES ON THIS BILL AND MOVE
IT FORWARD THANK YOU.
JAIL COOL DOCTOR IN PHYSICAL
THERAPY IN SEVEN YEARS
EXPERIENCE AN ANIMAL
REHABILITATION. AND STRONG
SUPPORTER OF MORE OF A
COLLABORATIVE.
ENVIRONMENT FOR CONSERVATIVE
MANAGEMENT FOR PETS THANK YOU.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
PATTY FRASER OF ROSE FELL AND
I'M SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
JOHN RENNIE HERE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
SUSAN GRAHAM DOWN HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
HELLO I'M SHARON MCDONOUGH I'M
THE PUBLIC I'M PREMIER SITE
COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND AS THE PUBLIC I
ASK YOU TO VOTE YES THIS BILL.
HI KELLY BOY SAID I AM A
REGISTERED VETERINARY TECHNICIAN
A PHYSICAL THERAPIST AND A
CERTIFIED EQUINE REHABILITATION
THERAPIST I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR VOTE. YES THANK YOU.
CANDY BRAMLEY I'M A DOCTOR OF
PHYSICAL THERAPY AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY MILLION I'M A DOCTOR IN
PHYSICAL THERAPY AS WELL
LICENSED CERTIFIED AND CAN
REHABILITATION THERAPISTS AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MAUREEN SPELL INTERNAL MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN AND DOG OWNER IN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
CHRIS REDRESS IN CALIFORNIA IS
WITH THEIR ASSOCIATION WERE IN
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DR JAMES SIMS PHYSIOTHERAPIST
DOCTOR SCIENCE
AND MEMBER OF THE. ANIMAL
REHABILITATION TASK FORCE.
AND WHICH CAME OUT WITH A
SIMILAR RECOMMENDATION OF THIS
BILL A BASED ON THE EVIDENCE
THAT IS OUT THERE TO SUPPORT
THIS SITE DEVELOPMENTS THIS IS
NOT AN OPINION THIS IS THE
EVIDENCE THAT SUPPORTS IT. THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF A NOW LIKE
TO ASK MEMBERS THAT WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME UP AT THE THE
TYSON.
YOU ALSO HAVE UP TO THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL.
IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I CRISTINA CARO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALL BE VERY BRIEF
JUST WANTED TO INDICATE THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR SAYS
HAS TAKEN TODAY DO NOT REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION BUT WE REALLY DO
WANT TO THANK. THIS COMMITTEE
ALL THE TIME YOU SPENT WITH US
EVERY SINGLE MEMBER AND THE
OFFICIAL SITE BOTH SIDES REALLY
APPRECIATE I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
DR AARON TRIED.
THANK YOU CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DOCTOR AARON
TROY AIKMAN PRACTICING
VETERINARY MEDICINE IN ONE THE
CREEK FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
ENAMEL PHYSICAL REHABILITATION
FOR EIGHTEEN. OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS I TO HAVE PARTICIPATED IN
THIS PROCESS.
AND THE OUTCOME HAS BEEN THAT
PATIENT SAFETY WAS MOST
IMPORTANT AND REQUIRES ONSITE
VETERINARY SUPERVISION.
I'M HERE TODAY SPEAKING
OPPOSITION TO THIRTY THIRTEEN
BECAUSE IT DOES A TREMENDOUS
DISSERVICE TO CONSUMERS.
VETERINARIANS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO DO GREAT HARM TO OUR PETS.
VETERINARY MEDICINE HAS A VERY
DIFFERENT CARE DELIVERY MODEL IN
HUMAN MEDICINE WE PRACTICE ON
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT SPECIES WE
CARE FOR PATIENTS FROM BIRTH
UNTIL DEATH. AND NONE OF OUR
PATIENTS SPEAK.
OFTEN THE REASON ANIMALS BROUGHT
INTO S. IS NOT THE REAL PROBLEM
AND WE HAVE TO BE PREPARED TO
CHANGE DIRECTIONS AT A MOMENT'S
NOTICE AND CAREFULLY AND
COMPASSIONATELY EDUCATE THE
CLIENT. WE ARE EDUCATED AND
TRAINED TO READ X. RAYS
INTERPRET LAB RESULTS RECOGNIZE
SUBTLE CHANGES IN OUR PATIENTS
HEALTH STATUS INCLUDING THEIR
PAIN.
ACCESS IS NOT AN ISSUE IT IS
CONTINUING EVERY YEAR THERE ARE
MORE ANIMAL PHYSICAL PUT
ROTATION REHABILITATION
PROFESSIONALS IN CALIFORNIA.
THAN THERE ARE VETERINARY
OPHTHALMOLOGIST AND VETERINARY
DENTIST COMBINED.
THEY'RE NOT ONLY REFERRAL
PRACTICES EXCLUSIVELY OFFER
REHABILITATION BUT A GROWING
NUMBER OF PRACTICE IT PRACTICES
THAT OFFER DIFFERENT LEVELS. I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ONE THIRTY
THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THIRTY
SECONDS LEFT.
THANK YOU I'M DOCTOR SURE
WATERHOUSE I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE VETERAN MEDICAL BOARD AND
ALSO SMALLER PRACTITIONER AT A
PRACTICE IN FRESNO.
THE PHYSICAL AND THE BETTER A
MEDICAL BOARD HAS DEBATED AND.
DEBATED TO DELIBERATE THIS ISSUE
FOR OVER SEVEN YEARS AND WE CAME
OUT STRONGLY A FIVE TO TO VOTE
TO VOTE LIKE HAVE TO OPPOSE.
THE PHYSICAL THERAPISTS WORKING
INDEPENDENTLY FROM A VENDOR AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THEY NEED DIRECT
SUPERVISION OF A VETERINARIAN
WHAT PHYSICAL THERAPISTS DO OF
IN YOUR PRACTICE THAT REFORM AND
THE PHYSICAL REHABILITATION IS
ONLY PART. OF WHAT A PATIENT
NEEDS IN ADDITION TO
REHABILITATION.
PATIENTS UNDERGOING VARIOUS
REVISIONS RECEIVE A PHYSICAL
EXAM HAVE PAIN MEDICATIONS
EVALUATED HOUSE BANDAGES CHANGE
HAVE SPLIT CHANGED AB OTHER
MODALITIES SUCH AS EAST FAMILIES
AT THEIR PURE ACUPUNCTURE. ALL
THESE ARE CRITICAL FOR THE CARE
OF THE PATIENT
THERE IS PRECEDENT WHO ARE YOU
DOING IN ADOPTING THE DIRECT
SUPERVISION REGULATIONS.
BBC SECTION TWO ZERO THREE EIGHT
REQUIRES PER PRACTICE TO WORK
UNDER THE DIRECT SUPERVISION OF
AN AREA WHEN PERFORMING MUSCULAR
MANIPULATION ON ANIMALS. THIS
STRUCTURE HAS WORKED WELL FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS.
THIS BILL UNDERMINES EVERYTHING
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS STANDS FOR AS FAR AS
LICENSING REGULATION AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
IT UNDERMINES THE VETERAN
MEDICINE PRACTICE ACT AND WE
REQUIRE EXTENSIVE RENT OF
REVISIONS IN MULTIPLE SECTIONS.
THE BOARD BELIEVES THIS
LEGISLATION WHEN GREATLY MISLEAD
THE PUBLIC THE AMMO PHYSICAL
REHABILITATION FACILITY THAT
WOULD BE OPERATE BY PHYSICAL
THERAPIST INDEPENDENTLY OF ANY
VETERAN OVERSIGHT WOULD HAVE A
PREMISES PERMIT POSTED ON THE
WALL. THAT WOULD BE FROM THE
VETERAN MEDICAL BOARD GIVING THE
CONSUMER THE IMPRESSION OTHER
PEDALS UNDER SUPERVISION CARAVAN
WRITING WHEN AFFECT THERE'S NO
VETERINARIAN PRESENT AT ALL.
SO IS IN THE BEST INTRAVENOUS
AND THE CONSUMER TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE VETERINARIANS.
SUPERVISOR PRACTICE OF
VETERINARY MEDICINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINETY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME TO THE MICROPHONE
NAY MANIPULATION.
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
BUT NANCY EHRLICH REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA REGISTERED
VETERINARY TECHNICIANS
ASSOCIATION AND ALL THE OTHER
PARTY TEES WHO COULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO WORK.
WE.
ARE TRAINED IN.
AB TO RECOGNIZE AND TREAT
EMERGENCIES WHEN A VETERINARIAN
IS NOT PRESENT ON LIKE A PT AND
WE ARE OPPOSING THIS BILL FOR
THE. HEALTH WELL BEING AND
SAFETY OF OUR PATIENTS.
BROWN TO MONTAGUE I'M STUDENT AT
UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF VETERINARY
MEDICINE AND I STATE MY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
LARA I'M TRIAL ALSO A STUDENT AT
UC DAVIS VETERINARY MEDICINE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE SPELL.
HI BRIANNA AND COUGH REGISTERED
VETERINARY TECHNICIAN AND LUIS
CALIFORNIA OF ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF MY CO WORKERS AND CLASSMATES
I COULD BE HERE TODAY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FOR THE SAKE OF THE PATIENTS
AND FOR OUR PROFESSION IN THE
FIELD IN GENERAL.
ACTUALLY QUACKENBUSH REGISTERED
VETERINARY TECHNICIAN AND AYE
OPPOSED TO SPELL. VETERINARIANS
THAT SPECIALIZE IN PHYSICAL
THERAPY THEY CAN'T GO AND GET
CERTIFICATIONS TO THEN WORK ON
HUMANS SO WHY SHOULD HUMANS VERY
PHYSICAL THERAPY GET FURTHER
SPECIALIZATION TO WORK ON
ANIMALS.
IT'S DISCREDITING OR FIELD AND I
POST SPELL.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN HECKLER THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US SPEAK TODAY
I OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M A
REGISTERED VETERINARY TECHNICIAN
OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE ACADEMY
OF PHYSICAL REHABILITATION
VETERINARY TECHNICIANS.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WILL RESTRICT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE RVT IN
CALIFORNIA. INFRINGES UPON
PROTECT ANIMAL HEALTH CARE TASK
ALREADY ESTABLISHED SORT OF
CASTING SPLINTING EMBRACING AND
CONTRIBUTES TO THE RVT SHORTAGE
IN CALIFORNIA. IS A JOB IN PART
OF RVT TRAINING TO RECOGNIZE AND
REPORT PAINS TO LICENSED
VETERINARIANS. RBT PRESENCE IN
OPPOSITION WOULD BE LARGER HERE
TODAY BUT AS ALREADY STATED WE
ARE HAVING EXISTING SHORTAGE AND
WE ARE REQUIRED TO BE IN OUR
PROFESSIONAL HOSPITALS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR JESSICA
WALDMAN I AM OF REHABILITATION
VETERINARIAN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BEEN PRACTICING ONLY
PET WE HAVE FOR THE PAST TEN
YEARS.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE I
ACTUALLY WORK IN CONJUNCTION
WITH PHYSICAL THERAPISTS OF MY
PRACTICE YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL.
THING TO ADD TO OUR FIELD BUT
UNFORTUNATELY SAFETY IS NOT ONE
OF THE THINGS ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR OUR PETS.
THROUGH PETS WITH CAESAR'S
COLLAPSE
ISSUES PAIN MEDICATION QUESTIONS
THAT HAPPENED ALL DAY LONG FOR
ME AND ALL MY COLLEAGUES
IT JUST ISN'T FAIR TO PUT PETS
IN THE SITUATION. WHERE THE
PERSON SUPERVISING THEM IS
UNABLE TO PROVIDE SAFETY FOR
THEM? SO I URGE YOU TO PLEASE
VOTE NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
REMAINING IS BECAUSE IF YOU JUST
NAME INFLATION PLEASE THANK YOU.
BUT IT IS GENERAL PAYTON I'M AT
THAT MARION BOARDED IN EMERGENCY
IN CRITICAL CARE I'M ALSO THE
CHIEF OF SERVICE FOR THE
INTEGRATIVE MEDICINE. I'M
SERVICE AT THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL TEACHING HOSPITAL AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
AND I STATE MY OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. THINKING.
GOOD MORNING JOHN PASCOE.
BOARD CERTIFIED VETERINARY
SURGEON EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATE DEAN
OF THE SCHOOL OF VETERINARY
MEDICINE LIKE REGISTRY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
DR GRANT MILLER I'M A CALIFORNIA
EQUINE PRACTITIONER THIS BILL IS
NOT ABOUT.
REVENUE STREAMS ABOUT
PROTECTING ANIMALS WHICH IS WHY
ASK YOUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
VALERIE FENCED MAKER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
DOCTOR RICHARD SULLIVAN MEMBER
OF THE VETERAN MEDICAL BOARD. A
PRACTITIONER IN TORRANCE
CALIFORNIA ITEM OF.
RECORD OF A ASKED TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
KEVIN HAS A CHEF PRACTITIONER IN
OAKHURST CALIFORNIA PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA BETTER MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS. TIME FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU.
A SIMILAR BAKER THANK YOU AND
FIRST I AM.
I I DON'T THINK THAT
VETERINARIANS WHO OPPOSE THIS
BILL DO BECAUSE A REVENUE STREAM
SO I I JUST. OP WHICH WE SHOULD
BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT FOLKS TO
SAY THAT BECAUSE THAT'S OFTEN
THEM.
SO I WOULD RESORT TO THAT
ARGUMENT AGAINST A BILL ONLY IF
IT'S REALLY SUBSTANTIAL.
THEY'RE PROFESSIONALS AND THEY
CARE ABOUT PATIENTS AND
AND SO I JUST WANT TO GET THAT
OUT THERE. AND THAT SAID IT
MIGHT GIVE ME A QUESTION BE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE WHEN I SEE
THE AMENDMENTS THE AUTHORS TAKEN
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IT ACTUALLY
INCREASES
THE CONTROL OF VETERINARIANS
HAVE OVER WHETHER OR NOT IT'S ON
SITE OFF SITE DIRECT INDIRECT.
THE AMENDMENTS TAKE CARE OF
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF.
CONCERNS THAT I SHARED THAT YOU
ARTICULATED AND I THINK WELL.
WHERE IS THAT STILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN BECAUSE I'VE
LOOKED AT THEM PRETTY CLOSELY
INTO ME THAT HAS A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF?
USUALLY WILL STILL HAVE A IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT I THINK THE
VETERINARIAN HAVING HAVE QUITE A
BIT OF CONTROL OVER WHAT HAPPENS
HERE I THINK THE MEMBERS
ACCOMPLISH THAT I'M JUST LOOKING
FOR THE WHOLE MISTER CHAIRMAN.
USE IT IS BAKER WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM THE OFFICE OF THE FOR
WE'VE EVER WE.
YES.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION ON THAT ONE I KNOW
THERE'S ONE FROM ON THE CREEKS I
PARTICULARLY. THINK PLEASE SORT.
OF.
SO FOR THE AMENDMENTS AND
ACTUALLY IN SOME WAY THE LIMITS
MAKE IT WORSE FROM ONE THEY ADD
MOBILE SO NOW OF A P. R. RECALL
AND A PHYSICAL REHABILITATION AB
ARE CAN BE PRACTICED ANYWHERE.
AND NOTHING IS THAT REDEFINES
THE BETTER MEDICAL BOARDS.
REGULATIONS INDIRECT
SUPERVISION AT IS USED HERE IS
NOT THE CORRECT TERM THIS IS NOT
IN DIRECT SUPERVISION.
THIS IS A PRACTICE BY REFERRAL
SO INDIRECT SUPERVISION MEANS
THAT THE VETERINARIAN. THE
ANIMALS IN A PLACE WHERE THERE'S
STILL A VETERINARIAN.
THAT'S IN CHARGE OF
VETERINARIAN THAT IT IS ON THE
PREMISES OF VENDOR IN THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS CASE SO
THAT IS IN DIRECT SUPERVISION.
WE TALK ABOUT IN DIRECT
SUPERVISION WITH OUR OUR BEAUTY
IS WHAT YOU'RE LIKE NURSES A WE
DISK DESCRIBE AUTUMN IN DIRECT
SUPERVISION WITH THEM SO THAT.
WERE JUST CERTAIN PRACTICES FOR
CERTAIN PROCEDURES.
SO THAT WE CAN WE FOR GO FOR
LUNCH FOR INSTANCE WE CAN WE FOR
A FEW MONTHS AGO LUNCH SO THAT.
OTHERWISE UNDER DIRECT
SUPERVISION OF FOR AN RPG.
HE YOU KNOW WHAT HAS TO STOP
WHEN WE WHEN WE LEAVE THE
BUILDING AND CAMERA RETURN AGAIN
UNTIL WE GOT INTO THE BUILDING.
BUT SO RVT IS I CAN'T WORK DO
SOMETHINGS AND THEN THE PT IS
GOING TO SAY
WELL IT DIDN'T DIE FROM THE AP
ARE THAT WE DID IT DIE FROM SOME
UNDERLYING REASON. BUT THEN THE
VETERINARIANS GONNA SAY HEY I'VE
BEEN YOU'VE SEEN THIS ANIMAL FOR
A MONTH OR THREE MONTHS OR SIX
MONTHS. AND SO THERE'S GOING TO
BE THIS BACK AND FORTH WHO'S
REALLY RESPONSIBLE. AND AND WHAT
THE VENDOR SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T SEEN THIS
ANIMAL FOR QUITE AWHILE IF THIS
HAD BEEN DONE IN THE FACILITY
THAT WHERE A VETERINARIAN WAS IN
CHARGE. OF THEY WOULD HAVE SEEN
WHEN SOMETHING WAS STARTING TO
EMERGE.
THANK YOU AND
ARE DEFENDING.
SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME SEEN THEN AS A MEMBER CHIU
WOULD YOU WISH TO CLOSE GROUND
APPROACH ALL FOUGHT ALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF FOR YOUR
PATIENT AND. ALL THOSE PEOPLE
DEAD A WAY TO SO LONG FOOD TO
TEST MONEY. I ALSO HONOR TO
INDICATED THAT THE MODEL AND
PROPOSED A PROPOSED BY A. B.
THIRTY THIRTEEN HOUSE BEING.
DONE FOR DECADES
AND GO TO A HOW HIGH
RECOMMENDATION GIVEN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU HAVE TAKEN.
THAT WE STILL NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
BUT IN THE SECOND.
TWENTY SIX DAVE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACTION IS DEPOSITED TO COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE LOW
AYE BRO.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM NOT VOTING.
CHEN.
CHIU. CHEN AYE.
JILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING FONG.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
CREEK GRAYSON NOT VOTING HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN NOT VOTING MULLIN.
MULLIN UP VOTING TING.
TING AYE.
MR JUNIOR OF THE BILL HAS NINE
VOTES A WILL KEEP THEIR ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE CONCLUDED WITH
AUTHOR PRESENTATIONS AND SO LET
US GO BACK TO FILE ITEM ORDER.
AND WE WILL THEN GO TO WHERE WE
LEFT OFF A FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE.
AT THAT IS AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SIX WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
IS THERE A SECOND SECOND
MUSICALLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTIONS DO PASSED THE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY LOW. I'VE LOW
AYE BROUGH. ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE. FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
BUT HAS FOURTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO ADD BACK TO FILE
ADAM NUMBER SIX.
SEE THAT THERE IS ALREADY BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND SO WE ALL GO
THROUGH. OTHER WILL GET.
AB TWO FOUR EIGHT SEVEN BY AMOS
MCCARTY. AYE ADOPTION AS DEPOSIT
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
JILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
PUTTING I'M NOT VOTING.
FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THAT HAS EIGHT VOTES WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA GO ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
THAT IS AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
ONE.
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
COMMISERATE PLEASE GULLIBLE.
ACTIONS DO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH LOW. AYE LOW AYE BRO.
WELL I ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
JOHN AYE TO. CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG NOT VOTING.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THAT'S FORTY VOTES WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OF IT FOR AFTER
MEMBERS.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY BY SOME REMEMBER
WHAT.
MOTION AND WE SIT IN A SECOND
CONSECUTIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACTIONS DEPOSIT COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH WELL I'VE LOW EYEBROW.
WELL I ARAMBULA.
BAKER. BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I JOHN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THAT HAS FOURTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE RELEVANT FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
LIVING ONTO UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE WHICH IS TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE BY DOCTOR WHAT.
MUCH A SECOND CONSECUTIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ACTION IS DO PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS LOW
AYE AYE LOW AYE BRO.
BROWN NOW ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER NOT VOTING.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I JOHN.
GEN NOT VOTING JAIL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING GIPSON OF AYE
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THAT HAS TO VOTES LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN.
WHICH IS AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
NINE BY SOMEONE COVER OF THIS OR
EVEN A MOTION AND A SECOND.
COMMITS A TRIP WITH A LITTLE.
ACTIONS DEPOSIT AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ARAMBULA.
CHEN.
JOHN NOT VOTING CHILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
COMING I'M NOT VOTING EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING ABOUT IN.
THAT HAS TEN VOTES BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN THIS IS
AB IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE BY
SOME I GUESS IN THIS IDEA BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND. OF
CONSECUTIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACCESS DEPOSIT AMENDED BROWN.
BRA AYE ARAMBULA.
JILL.
SURE I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOLLOW NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY ONE BY SUMMER BLOOM.
THIS I HAVE BEEN IN MOTION AS I
CAN MUSICALLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACTION IS DEPOSIT COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BAKER.
BAKER I CHAU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING.
SIXTEEN KNOW THE BILL IS OUT.
A.
NOW MOVING ON TO.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY FIVE THAT IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AS
EMERIL LACKEY. OF THERE'S A LOT
OF EMOTION SECOND TO COMMIT SUCH
A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTION IS TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THAT IS SO WITH RESPECT TO A
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS AS WELL
SO.
CONSIDER RECOGNIZE THAT SIXTEEN
ZERO. WHENEVER MOVING ON TO FILE
IN MY FORTUNE AB TWENTY FOUR OH
TO LOW.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
COMMITS ACCURATE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACTIONS DEPOSITED COMMITTEE ON
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
BAKER.
BAKER I CHILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING. TING AYE.
THE VOTE IS FOURTEEN TWO. OF
THAT BILL IS OUT.
NOW MOVING ONTO FILE AND AND
NUMBER SIXTEEN.
ALLEN IS AYE OKAY AYE FARMER
FIFTEEN I'M PUDGIE'S OUT WE NEED
A MOTION AND A SECOND SUMMER
COOLEY.
MOTION A SECOND CONSECUTIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACCESS TO PASS A COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE AYE. LOW
AYE BRO.
BROUGH NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
GEN I CHILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
AS A FOURTEEN VOTES WILL LEAVE
THE WILL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THE FINAL I NEVER SIXTEEN A. B.
THIRTY THIRTEEN AS SUMMER CHIU
KANSEN CHU.
OTHERS ARE GONNA MOTION AND A
SECOND COMEY SECTOR PLEASE
HELLO.
ACTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BROWN.
FOR NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
THAT BILL HAS NINE VOTES AND
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS MEMBERS WILL NOW
TO A BEGIN GOING AGAIN THROUGH
THE FILE EITHER. UNLESS THE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH SIXTEEN UP A
CONCLUSION OF US GOING TO FILE
ITEM WE WILL ADJOURN THIS
MEETING SO IF YOU ARE NOT
PRESENT.
WE WILL ADJOURN THIS MEETING SO
LET'S GO BACK TO A FILE ORDER SO
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTIONS DEPRESSIVE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY BAKER.
BAKER I CHILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
SIXTEEN ZERO THAT BILL AS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
AB SEVENTY FIFTY TWO COMEY
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTIONS THE PASSED THE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY BAKER.
BAKER I CHAU. CHIU AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING. TING AYE.
SIXTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE.
ABSENCE DEPOSIT COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY BAKER. BAKER I
CHILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
FIFTEEN OR ONE THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM IN OUR FOR AB TWENTY
EIGHTY SIX BY SUMMER GALLAGHER.
ACTION AS DEPOSIT THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BAKER. BAKER I
CHILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING. TING AYE.
SIXTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B.
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SIX BY SOME
MEMBERS SANTIAGO.
ACTION IS DAY PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
BROWN.
WELL I ARAMBULA.
BUT IT'S FIFTEEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
SOBRE GOING TO THEN GO TO A FIVE
OR SIX FILE ORDER AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY.
AND.
COOLEY SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE.
VOTERS IN NINETEEN I'M A NINE TO
THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY ONE BURKE.
ACTIONS YOU PASS THAT COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH ARAMBULA.
FONG.
BUT IF OF FOURTEEN OH. THAT BILL
IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS
AB. TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY.
MY DOCTOR WOULD.
ACTIONS YOU PASS A COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH ARAMBULA.
FOR VOTERS FOURTEEN TO ONE THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY NINE BY DOCTOR
WOULD.
ACTION IS YOU PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ARAMBULA.
THE VOTE IS TEN TO ONE THE BILL
IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN WHICH IS
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE BY SOME
WOMAN CABALLERO.
ACTIONS DEPOSIT DOESN'T IT TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ARAMBULA.
FONG.
FONG GOVERNING.
THAT BILL HAS TEN VOTES THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN WHICH
IS.
AB NINETEEN NINETY THREE BY A
SUMMER GIPSON.
ACCESS TO PASS AS AMENDED
ARAMBULA.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES THAT
BILL IS OUT.
WE'RE GOING TO FILE I NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE
BY SUMMER BLOOM.
THAT BILL HAS OUR IS SIXTY VOTES
IN THE RD.
IS ALREADY OUT OF THE T. FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY FIVE BY SOME OF OUR
LACKEY WHICH ALSO HAS SIXTEEN
VOTES THAT BILL IS OUT. WE'RE
GOING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN.
AT THAT BILL HAS IS FOURTEEN TO
TO THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN.
THAT HAS FOURTEEN VOTES THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU.
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES THAT
BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL ADJOURN
THIS MEETING